[music]
>> [ __ ]
>> [music]
[music]
>> [ __ ]
>> [music]
[music]
>> What's up, everybody? I have Houses here
in Hartford. How's your weekend going so
far?
>> I'm doing all right. X3 in the main
event, but uh
we're doing our best. We're doing our
best.
>> Okay, so having fun?
>> Yeah, I'm I I love this game. It's
It's so challenging, but
>> Yeah, yeah, X3 still not too bad. And
now you're still playing the Master Yi,
I'm assuming. Cuz you're kind of the
Master Yi guy right now.
>> Of course, man. I'm doing my best out
here trying to trying to keep further
advancing the deck.
>> Okay.
>> Uh
I'm running into some tough beats.
Everybody's coming back with
Yeah, their own response to how to beat
this deck, so I'm having some trouble
there, but
I'm glad some of the everyone else is
seeing success, so I'm very happy for
them.
>> right? Top Yi in Vancouver, best of
Master Yi.
>> of Master Yi.
>> So, tell me about like the innovations
since then. Have there been any other
discoveries in Master Yi from your
perspective?
>> Yeah, so I was number two in Sydney, and
then and then I made a lot of changes to
get to the number one in Vancouver. And
then uh but ever since then, everybody
copied my list and realized that if we
take out the bad cards and put in the
good cards, we were going to win a lot
more. And then now we ended up at 60%
win rate.
>> Yeah.
>> Master Yi, so I'm very I'm very proud of
my work. And I'm very proud of the Yi
gang who's like bringing it home for us.
So, I am so happy to see it. Even if I'm
not doing it, I'm so glad to see that
everybody's like catching up and doing
doing really well.
>> Proving the haters wrong. I was a Yi
believer as well in Spear Forge. I
thought it was under explored. I'm happy
to see it finding a lot of success now.
You're also part of a team. I want you
to talk about a little bit about the
team cuz you all have been traveling to
like every regional.
>> So, I'm I'm one of the founding members
of the secret sauce.
They're founded by the Todd Father
himself, Mr. Todd.
>> Who is the Todd Father?
>> His name is Todd. His name is Todd. He's
He's been He's been creating a lot of
Rift Bound content since the game before
it was even released. He was like the
first meta-fi. He created the first set
meta-fi back in the day. So, he's very
well known in in like other card games
as well, but yeah, he brought all of us
together. We've been playing since
Origins spoiler season. And
you know, we've been we've been building
up to getting
here. And now, you know, our team has
brought, you know, more than more best
ofs than you can count with your hands.
Myself, just two. You know, there's a
lot of a lot of good performance, but uh
>> Well, you hey, you you founding member
of a team. You're taking credit for
Master Yi's success as well as the cool
list. There's also a couple other things
you're known for, specifically hashtag
lift bound.
>> What's up? Woah.
>> Yeah, so were you the first one to tweet
that out cuz you're the first one I ever
saw tweet that out?
>> Yeah, it was it was
it was basically me. I started talking
about like um
You got a looks max for the best of
picture and everybody's just like, oh,
we got to like get in the gym and stuff.
And that's how it started.
>> Can you give me 10 speed push-ups right
now? I'll do them with you. All right,
let's do it real quick, okay?
Thanks for watching everybody. That's
lift bound.
>> That's Houses.
>> He's got to be lift bound.
>> I lost track.
>> All right, watch the camera.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> One of the recent additions to the
regional qualifier series here is our
pack opening booth. That's right, you
can go ahead and take your badge, come
and get a pack where you open it in
front of everybody for their eyes to
see. And if you get a hit, basically
everyone cheers for you because all eyes
are new. So, right now, of course, we're
opening packs of Unleashed, but in the
future, of course, you'll be able to
open up a pack of Vendetta, and who
knows in the future here at each
regional qualifier. So, of course, it's
been busy all weekend long, and people
have been coming in and opening exciting
hits. I've seen plenty of Poros being
opened up. It's been pretty busy all
weekend long, but I think I'm going to
go ahead and step in the booth myself
and see what I can get.
>> [music]
>> Ah!
Oh! Alternate Elder Dragon, let's go!
Did end up pulling something exciting
with this Elder Dragon here. Shout out
to Philip. Thanks for giving me the
pack. And this is just one of the many
things you can do here at RQ Hartford.
>> Hello, everybody. Charmer here, joined
with a none other than Gonkra, a
fantastic Annie player, and we're going
to take you through some tips and tricks
for playing against Annie. That's right.
We thought we would ask one of the
experts at piloting Annie to maybe
provide some insight on how to defeat
this menace in the mix. So,
we're going to put up Prismatizism's
list. This is what Prismatizism played
in Utrecht, so we're not giving away any
secrets here for what he was playing at
this event, but
walk us through some of the key cards in
Annie, and if you're playing against it,
how you would navigate around them.
>> Yeah. Um so, what's important against
Annie is just optimizing the two mana
you have because right now, we're not
like very aggro, we are kind of
mid-rangey, and we have to use the mana
well and use the
um little resources we have very well
because the problem of Annie is that,
except Kai'Sa and Merchant, which is a
discardable, but sometimes we can just
draw because the end is empty. We don't
have much draw and we have to find our
way to make the mana
trade with him his cards in a fact. So,
for example, flash is a great card
because your opponent has to like push a
lot,
play a lot of cards, put much value and
then you just flash out and you get a
lot of value from the flash. So, this
this type of card, for example, is doing
a lot of value. The long sword, too.
We were on two before like most of the
Annie players, but card is just too
good. So, now we're on three. Like it's
a good interaction for two mana and you
can make a lot of value. Like right now
we have Master Yi, which is like the
most popular decks and long sword just
shine in the match-up. So, it's really
good to play long sword against Yi.
So, we have static that can be used
during the opponent turn.
And so, we have some counter spells of
abundant bargain, but it's not shining
that much in the current meta because
it's not that great against Yi and
earlier. So,
personally I stopped playing abundant.
So, I don't I don't like the card that
much right now, but yeah, that's the key
interaction. So, most of the best
interaction is flash and long sword.
That's That's the best ones.
>> Okay, so with that in mind, just so that
I understand as somebody who is trying
to learn from you, it sounds like when
you talk about making sure that your
cards for the resources you have answer
them, you're trying to use flash in my
opinion when they're spending more
energy on their card and then you're
essentially spending less energy to kind
of negate that. Or in the case of long
sword, I'm glad you talked about Master
Yi because Master Yi is obviously the
most popular deck in the room here at
Hartford. It did very well in Utrecht.
Long sword, you mentioned not having
card draw, does give you a reusable
after you play it way to kind of go over
the top on might. But outside of those
things that you mentioned, can you talk
about maybe some of the key units and
how somebody might answer those?
>> Yeah. So,
what's fun with Annie is that when we
are when we are on the draw,
we have some key units. So, Rengar is
the best one. Like, you play your turn
one and then your opponent try to
conquer and then you say, "Okay, Rengar
in days." And suddenly you are the one
with the more unit and you are the first
player in a way. So, it's the best unit
I would say in the deck right now.
Grim is a good card, too, but it's a bit
different. In some match-ups you can
like bounce something to get value, save
a unit, save a Rengar, save an Inferna
that you will use later. And most of the
time you just use it as something to
help you to hold when you are on the
draw because you can do like turn a turn
one, then you do like a Katarina
effects, and then you have three help
and you can like have something better
than a long sword because you have three
mites for three mana, so that's a bit
better. So, it can helps. But, yeah, I
would say Rengar is the best one.
Traveling is the go-to because we we
don't draw and Annie has to filter a lot
and that's why the deck is that hard
because you have like two or three cards
in your hand and you have to understand
exactly what you need to discard right
now and try to find something and dig
dig in the deck. But, if you take the
wrong decision in like one, two, or
three turns sometimes, it will just cost
you the game. That's why the game the
the game the the deck is that hard, in
my opinion. So, yeah, I would say
traveling, Rengar, and of course, my
beloved Ferus.
>> Yeah.
>> Against against Irelia, against like
Aurora is shining, too. Against orange
decks, like Ferus is just amazing, like
it's it's kind of
the same like last meta. Last meta we
had the Rebuke and so people were kind
of afraid of playing Ferus, though I
sell out them when I'm against purple.
And it was the same because Star Cross,
you can't even flash out the Rebuke. So,
you get Star Cross easily. But, in fact,
the deck that play Star Cross, you're
fine with them Star Crossing your stuff
because they don't have much unit
developed and so they lose value, too.
They lose tempo, too, by doing that.
Except
against Diana, you don't like Ferus that
much.
>> Well, I really appreciate you
highlighting both the interactibility
and the key units that are played in
Annie. Thank you for taking the time to
have this interview and with that we're
going to throw it back to you.
>> My name's Granton and I have the
pleasure of being joined by SwagYolo420.
Yeah, congratulations on making day two
and everybody kind of knows you as, you
know, the Aurora guy. You played some
Misfortune in Origins, right? Played
some Sivir in, you know, Spirit Forge
and we're still playing Sivir all the
way now into the last regional of
Unleashed. How's your run been so far?
>> Uh it's been pretty good. Um
I've only lost I mean to myself.
Uh but I'm I am X2 now on day two, 7-2 I
believe 7-2. Uh deck's sweet. I love
this deck. Uh
I only play Aurora till it's out either
out of
out of format or people get
tired of it for some reason, so we're
banned or something, but yeah.
>> Cool. So, uh obviously we saw more or
less the same list uh from the beginning
of Unleashed, right? We were running
those Elder Dragons. Yeah, we were, you
know, running that one of Mind Splitter
as well just to be able to rip some
cards out of our opponent's hand, but a
completely different list here at
Unleashed. So, I want to let you kind of
talk about this because
this has been kind of sweeping the rooms
today. I've got a lot of people talking
about this Baron Aurora list that we're
seeing where a lot of players, when
Baron was leaked, they said, "Oh, this
isn't really a good Aurora card cuz, you
know, we're going to fully exhaust our
runes, play Aurora, introduce a third
battlefield giving our opponents three
chances to score." But, you're having
success with it. So, why don't you kind
of just walk us through your thought
process with this deck?
>> Yeah, sure sure. So, like what happened
was everyone was playing an Elder Dragon
deck. Since Sydney, it was all about
Elder Dragon. It was like three dragons
flurries. And then people would would be
like, "You know, I want to play one
Baron." And it would die and then like
people would then lose cuz they had
three battlefields and three points they
could score like you said.
What you have What I had What I had to
do was I was like, "Hey, let me like
rewind my brain. I don't want to a
dragon deck. I want to build a Baron
deck."
Uh and to play Baron, you have to
protect Baron, right? So, we're So, we
have we have Baron, of course.
Um, and then with we have
our Our best way to protect him is
through Punch First.
17 is pretty tough for people to get
over, especially if it's early enough.
And then, as a fourth Punch First, I
have one Existential Dread.
Cuz usually they If they try to kill
Baron the same turn comes in, they crash
every unit in. You stand on the biggest
one, be it Hwei or
whatever the big unit is, and Baron
lives and he can live essentially.
Or what happens is
they kill Baron,
and these all resources kill Baron, and
they still have Aurora, then you get
another Baron. And second Baron is much
harder to kill than the first one.
Um, so it's basically just all about
It's It's This is all about Baron. Um,
and and we we we move with Baron. I'm
not playing Miss Fortune, still playing
Siri because the gold the gold
generation is just
very powerful over over the course of a,
you know, a long game.
So, the goal is just to have We have We
have We have Boots of Swiftness, and we
have Ride the Wind.
Um, and if you have Ride the Wind on one
unit, you can just score all three
battlefields cuz you you you move to,
let's say, the left battlefield, you
ride to the far right one, and then you
then you can gank into the pit the pit
with any any unit.
>> The Baron pit ability, yeah.
>> Exactly, yes. Um, but Dex has been
really fun.
It's
Baron is a favorite unit. Like, dragons
are cool, but Baron is just I don't
know, just It's It's It's iconic.
>> Baron It's iconic, [laughter] yeah.
>> And it's been fun to play.
>> So, I really like this list, to be
honest, cuz I was a big Miss Fortune
head back in set one. I know we talked a
lot about Aurora together back in set
one. And I love the movement aspect of
Miss Fortune because Aurora naturally is
a whole deck, right? And if the person
if your opponent has enough of an
advantage, they can just stand on the
other battlefield and not kind of worry.
That's where they get punished with
stuff like Elder Dragon in this set.
Do you prefer this list or your old list
after having to play, you know, now
you're going into your 10th round?
>> Okay, so what So, in Riftbound, what
I've noticed is you get you you get
rewarded for
changes. Um, if you are a good Like, I
feel like Aurora a lot of stuff into
play too with changing your list
updating the meta game. Aurora's in my
in my eyes like a a control deck.
>> Right.
>> You have to adapt. And people adapt to
you with Star Crossed.
It's so it's so rough. Like your dragons
get Star Crossed. Uh people then your
your Aurora's gone and you just you
lose.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh so Baron is adaptation to beat the
Star Crossed decks or decks trying to
target it.
Um
and it's been really great for really
great for for this meta. Uh
I feel like I can't even like right
right now
like if you think Camel or the
the one unit what's it called?
>> The Master Yi Unstoppable?
>> No, the unit that has hex has can be
targeted?
The Camel?
>> Yeah, Ruin Runner.
>> Ruin Runner.
>> Runner.
>> If you think that's annoying to deal
with
Baron is massive. Yeah.
And and pumps all your all your units.
And Baron with Sivir Champion in one
punch first becomes like 11. She's so
big. So
yeah, it's it's been fun. I've I've
enjoyed it.
>> I'm very excited to see how this kind of
list list evolves going into Vendetta as
well. Uh thank you for the taking the
time with us today. Uh once again, Swag
Yolo 420 uh
the resident Aurora specialist. My name
is Grenton and thank you for tuning in.
>> Thank you.
>> One of the stops here at RQ Hartford is
of course the prize wall. Now the prize
wall is always the talk of the town
because it is that place where you can
get the coveted plated legends with some
prize wall tickets once you come here.
But of course, there are many other
items that you can redeem as well. Of
course we have these commemorative pins
representing the regional qualifier that
you attend. You can always pick up some
booster boxes, booster packs with your
prize wall tickets, even sleeves, mats
of course. But you have to make sure
that if you have one of those premium
badges that you always pick up the mat
that is included for every single one of
those premium badges. Now every mat is
different at every event and so of
course we've got this wonderful over
number Kazix art [music] here for RQ
Hartford. But even if that means you
can't be here for this one, make sure
you come to the next one so you can pick
up that exclusive premium mat as well.
>> [music]
>> Hello everybody and welcome back as we
are getting ready for a top eight here
in Hartford for the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier. But before that, I know a lot
of people are probably wondering about
the update for our best of three.
>> Let's not talk about the best
>> been playing throughout the day. Why
don't you want to talk about it, Grant?
What happened in game three?
>> Cuz Super Mega Death Rocket sucks.
>> I'm just going to say I was able to
defeat LeBlanc going second into wins we
fell off.
>> Yeah.
>> That's the auto win, Grant.
>> play her on our queue next.
>> Honestly, maybe I will.
Maybe I
>> It's a tough match up.
>> It is a tough match up. Great for the
Jinx, but it it does confirm I did beat
you 1.2 times. Cuz
technically Barrett won with my first
like three turns and then he played the
rest of it to beat you in game two. Uh
you you took game one, honestly, but
there we go. So so in our little
head-to-head, slight favor for me. But
with that being said, let's start
talking about the event as a whole. The
players are still getting ready for top
eight, so we're going to talk more about
the event itself right now and take a
look at the standings. So this will see
who made it to top eight. A big
announcement for everybody waiting at
home, but then also who didn't
>> Yeah.
>> make top eight because there's a couple
of big names that will not be making it
the cut today. Break it down for me,
Grant.
>> So we have Brady Ken, top seed, and I'm
going to give him a little shoutout
again.
>> Montreal local, super happy to see him
squeezing his Not even squeezing his way
into top eight, absolutely blowing it
into top eight.
>> lose a single match.
>> Didn't drop a game game, excuse me,
intentionally drew in the last round to
obviously secure a spot in the top eight
and did a draw earlier today on on a
feature match as well. Underneath we
have Beast Whites who did did win his
win and in on the feature last round as
well to get in there as well.
>> And three Diana's back-to-back.
>> Yep. Second through fourth.
>> There's a lot of Diana's in the top
eight. It's almost half of the field. No
surprise this was kind of the boogeyman
of the Unleashed format. And also a
Master Yi.
>> A Lux made it
>> Of course. We did see Relivia take out a
Alanzq earlier, so Relivia was able to
make it in. And then Prismatizism and
Miru. So Annie, Pike, Lux, Master Yi,
Diana, and Ezreal. Five different
legends represented. And we got to talk
about Prismatizism making it another top
eight. Well done. But a lot of names did
not make it in, Breton.
>> So we see Dewalli, you know, 11-2, just
a bit short of making it in.
Doctor Snuffles, who we saw
unfortunately lose their win and in on
the broadcast last round.
>> The backup feature match, unfortunately.
We We imagine a world we could have had
Aurora Lux finals.
>> That would have been crazy for Lux.
>> Yeah, that would have That [laughter]
would have been crazy for Lux. But no
Aurora's in the top eight yet again.
It's really hard for that deck to
actually make it all the way in and
crack into that top eight. We've talked
about that a whole lot. The variance of
the deck not really playing in its
favor.
>> Yeah, I mean, like we mentioned right,
there's
an almost auto win game in that in the
Aurora matchup. So you're usually always
going to three games. We do see Bloody
there as well. I believe at 16th. But
moving on forward, Vexer at 21st,
another Montreal local who was on
Ezreal. So good showing from my
hometown. Awesome Rossom, who we saw
playing Pike, had a little bit of an
awkward matchup into that Master Yi.
Unfortunately, not able to squeeze into
that top cut. But a very respectable
10-2-1. And Alanzq, who also was, you
know, taken down by the Lux that we saw
get into top eight. But I spoke to Alanz
a little earlier after that match and he
He told me, and I quote, "This day two
is the best run I've ever played in my
life."
>> Yeah, you were talking about that
backstage. It felt like he played
everything he possibly could into the
Lux matchup. The Lux just saw the right
cards. But Alanz felt really confident
about the rest of the day overall and
how he performed. What was it he said?
He said it wasn't about misplays. it was
just about variance, right?
>> It's a variance, which is again, we're
playing a we're playing a card game,
there's always going to be some variance
in there. And like we always say, play
to your outs, and that's exactly what
Alanz was doing.
>> And I will say, when my friends and
locals give that excuse, I don't believe
them. When Alanzq does, I think maybe
they maybe he's onto something. Maybe he
actually has some insight.
>> Yeah, same same but different.
>> the variance. It wasn't any about
anything about the play, yeah. Um but
it's cool to see the top eight. There's
a lot of new names in that top eight. Is
Prismatistism is the
>> only one that would have a chance to win
another um another regional qualifier
here. No one else in the top eight has
been able to make it this far, so
opportunity as well. It's Prismatistism
kind of versus the field when you look
at the you know, beginning legacy
players. It's crazy to think legacy, you
know, the game hasn't even been out for
a full year, but Prismatistism already
has been in so many top cuts. We put out
a graphic on socials actually, and he
even interacted with it. He averages
13th place.
>> That's crazy.
>> Average in every He's been [laughter] to
every regional, and his average
placement is 13th. That is nuts.
>> That is crazy. Notable also, very
different than the
top eight we saw last weekend.
>> Yes.
>> Right? This is a very blurple heavy
>> [laughter]
>> uh top eight, right? We have half of the
field
>> term? The technical term?
>> That's the Grenton term.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Blurple.
>> Blurple. So we have three Dianas and an
Ezreal. So that's four of the uh the
eight. As we can see the bracket here.
>> Half blurple.
>> A lot of chaos as well. We have the
bracket in front of us now, so Brady Kin
is going to be going up against Miru,
right? Our first and eighth seed
fighting it out. And we have Evan Shrim
on the the Diana against Factor, who we
saw earlier today on that Master Yi.
Linsanity up against Rilivia on Lux. And
I spoke to Rilivia as well, naturally,
as I instantly went to find the Lux
player to congratulate them on their
win. And the Diana's a very tricky match
up for them, especially if they're
playing a more aggro version of the the
deck. And then we have B Swits against
Prismat. So both those players have
their work cut out for them, cuz B Swits
has been very, very impressive, as we've
seen him throughout the weekend.
>> Yeah, notable no Diana's versus each
other in the first round means that this
you know Relivia playing against a Diana
and then either Prismaticism or another
Diana. And then there's a chance that
even more Diana's on the top half of the
bracket. But that top half of the
bracket four individual unique legends
pretty cool to see there. Notable though
six out of eight have the chaos domain.
So purple definitely represented here in
the top eight. No surprise that is often
the trend.
>> Yeah, and last weekend we saw a lot of
order.
>> Yeah.
>> Now we're seeing a lot of chaos.
>> one order now and it's the Lux. That's
crazy. They're not even running like the
traditional order like cold the weights,
hidden blades, things like that.
>> True. I do want to kind of highlight
something.
Maybe you and I are a bit clairvoyant.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Because Josh and Charmer said Kha'Zix
and Sivir were going to win it out.
>> Yep.
>> I'm sensing a little lack of Kha'Zix and
Sivir in this top eight.
>> I don't I notably
difficulty reading without my glasses
but I can't spot any. There's no
Kha'Zix. There's no Sivir.
>> Okay, good. I'm happy I'm right there.
But there is a Lux which was your
prediction and there is an Annie which
was my prediction. And I will say I
predicted Annie because Prismaticism is
here. And I just said I think
Prismaticism's going to win. He won the
last regional qualifier for the Spirit
Forge format. And this is the last
regional qualifier for the Unleashed
format. In my opinion if you give a
player like Prismaticism an entire
format to solve the
the meta game, he will solve it and he
will come in hot.
>> Also, correct me if I'm wrong but you
were casting
the one that he won.
>> back in Atlanta, yeah.
>> Okay. Well, let's jump into the their
tournament run so far.
>> Sure.
>> Obviously long 13 rounds and as you can
see Brady can hear had to kind of go
through some favorable match-ups, some
not so much, right? Actually beating a
Lux in round two. Not sure if that was a
control or a Lux.
>> Interesting, yeah.
>> Getting his first win there and then
completely winning out until his feature
match that he had earlier today in round
nine where unfortunately that did go to
time and they drew out. And then three
back-to-back wins and then with him and
Factor last round, little handshake ID,
take a little break, go get some food,
and jump in there. But some notable two
wins against these Dianas.
>> Yeah, and one of them was Bishwhite's,
who's also in the top eight. So
interesting to see there. Cool run.
Speaking of Bishwhite's, the only loss
that they had this entire uh two days so
far was against Bradi Ken uh in that
Ezreal versus Diana matchup. And a big
spread of different legends that
Bishwhite's played on the way here.
>> Also, Bishwhite's beat Relivia in round
number nine.
>> Oh.
>> loss
is in the top eight with this Lux.
>> Interesting. So Relivia's matchup into
Diana was already from the interview
that we had with him. He was like,
"Yeah, that's that's that one's hit or
miss."
Uh and this is the miss that he had so
far today. Bishwhite's was able to get
that one. So already a lot of history
from Swiss leading into the bracket
between some of these players.
>> Yeah, and then if we could
if we take a look, right? There's a such
a wide spread. The Ezreal is always
going to be a hatch uh hard matchup,
excuse me, for these Diana decks because
Ezreal just controls the board and Diana
wants to play on the board for tempo. So
it's a definitely a rough match. If we
actually look at Linsanity also winning
out until round 11 where they lost a
mirror match. And again, the mirror
match is also tricky because there's
some control elements to your Diana. And
if you fall behind on tempo, it's really
hard to kind of get back up in there.
And obviously, Linsanity and Relivia
meeting in round 13,
no, you know, realistic reason to play
it out. Just draw and get into top
>> not much to
glance from that one. Let's take a look
at the next player, though.
EvansR Him
was the one that beat Linsanity earlier
on, as you see there, victory. Lost to
Bradi Ken. So pretty much all the top
eight, they really so far have only lost
to each other
>> [laughter]
>> on their way here. I think that
definitely helps out with the
tiebreakers and things like that on the
way to top seeding.
>> Yeah, and that's I'm not sure how
much of a pattern that is in the other
RQs, but I feel like we have a lot of
top eights who have, you know, had met
each other in Swiss, have lost or won
against each other.
>> yeah.
>> We saw actually our
the previous slide where they actually
beat
um
uh Anzrel as well. So, they actually
beat Anzrel. So, a little bit of
practice there and again, Evan Sheram
having to go through a gauntlet of
Dianas.
>> at all these Dianas. 1 2 [laughter] 3 4
5. I was just laughing about that cuz I
noticed it in the moment. Five Dianas,
that is
uh like
over uh a third of your total match-ups
for the weekend.
>> Yeah, we're going to jump into Factor
here.
>> Yeah.
>> Take a look.
>> Factor, our our Master Yi, our solo
Master Yi making Houses our big proud,
uh only dropping a game a match, excuse
me, to Sam D Sherman, uh drawing
obviously in the last round with Brady
Kin, uh seeing a lot of Yi as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh so, a little bit of a pattern where
you're seeing a lot of your own legend,
it seems like in these Swiss brackets,
but haven't hasn't really seen many
Luxes, right? We saw one Lux in round
six, one Annie in round eight, and
besides that it's been more of the same.
>> But, Factor also notably one of the
players that has not matched up against
the other top eight
uh in the Swiss round. So,
>> Correct.
>> lost to Sam D Sherman, but I'm not
seeing any other names. Again, Brady Kin
at the very end, we're assuming it was
just a agreed draw. Let's take a look at
the next one here.
So far it's feeling like uh I don't know
who's had the hardest run, but Relivia,
let's take a look at the Lux match-ups
here. The beginning of the tournament
against those Miss Fortunes got to feel
pretty nice, but then beating the
Aurelias pretty impressive, uh and then
losing to that Diana like you had
mentioned kind of hit or miss match.
>> Yeah, those round six through nine has
especially late in the day day one,
those are some of your worst match-ups
as uh the Lux combo deck, right? So, the
three Aurelias and then obviously Beasty
Bites able to take the only victory
against Relivia. We saw Relivia in round
11 take down Alanzq, drawing into the
top eight with uh Linsanity. So,
again, the Diana is hit or miss. We have
a 50% win rate into Diana if we look at
this, right? So, we're flipping a coin
when we
>> Yeah. when we sit at the table.
>> Also, I got to say, maybe uh the villain
of the tournament took out Alan Ziqiu
from contention and then took out the
Romanian Darius. We almost had Darius
back-to-back top eights uh week over
week here for regional qualifiers, but
no, Relivia was the wall to hold the
line and prevent Darius from breaking
through. I'll take a look at the next
player here
as it's going to be a Prismat.
And let's take a look at his run. Played
Ornn in round one. Okay, nice.
Um
Wow, a big spread of different legends.
I There's only what, one repeat in uh
Aurelia?
>> That looks about right.
>> I think so. Oh, no, two Azir. Well, we
Yeah, we had to do our win and in in
round 13 for Azir. We had round three
and round 13. So, did play against two
Azir.
>> yeah. The guy Well, besides Ornn, what
real round did he did for
>> Correct. Yeah, it was a win and in for
him.
>> Yep, yep. So, two Azir and then two
Aurelia, but a lot of different uh
legends outside of that and even one
mirror match in the Hoppy there in the
Annie versus Annie.
That's a funny mirror.
It's a great one. Take a look at the
last representative in the top eight and
see how their Swiss stage looked coming
into the top eight.
>> And again, losing to someone else who's
in the top eight, losing to Linsanity in
round number nine. Beating Collin and
DeWalt.
>> Yeah, back-to-back.
>> way here. Back-to-back two big names in
the community so far. So, very
impressive that Miru was able to uh push
through two of the uh kind of heavy
hitters.
>> Yeah, this is again, this
bracket here of what my 13 rounds look
like playing uh
on Pike is kind of crazy.
>> Wait, was that two XPEs?
>> Yeah.
>> Hampage and Blue Chuvaro. That's
awesome.
>> Yeah. I believe Varo was undefeated at
that point as well.
>> Oh.
>> I was talking to him earlier yesterday.
>> Unfortunately, um
couldn't keep up against Miru. So, Miru
taking him down and that is uh all of
our players that runs through the
tournament so far. So, now we just got
top eight and uh it is single
elimination. If you lose a round, you
are out and at the end of this we'll be
crowning another regional qualifier
champion.
>> Yeah, notably everybody in this top
eight except for Gradykin has dropped
a round at one point this weekend.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And most of them to each other.
Uh there was what? I think only one
example that wasn't uh
wasn't able to get a win or a loss
against one of the others in the top
eight.
>> Yeah. Interesting.
>> So,
where you landed in the bracket is very
important and I obviously was keeping a
look on where Lux landed and they're
kind of in the, you know, the bracket of
doom if you're a Lux player.
>> They're in the the blurple slash
repple.
With the there's Annie in there, too.
>> Purple. Purple. Yeah, fury purple.
>> Fury purple. Oh, that's better. I like
that. All right, I'm going to let you
come up with the names for these. I'm
not notoriously not great at that, but
uh between blurple and purple, uh here's
another look at the bracket here because
like you were highlighting the Lux is on
the bottom half of the bracket, has to
go through Linsanity's Diana and then
either a Diana or an Annie if they want
to go for that grand finals.
>> And there's a world where Relivia has to
beat three Dianas to win this
tournament. There is a world, uh which
is very very rough. I think if you're
Relivia, you hope the Master Yi doesn't
move on cuz cards like Sabotage, cards
like Defile are very dangerous for your
strategy. In in a picture perfect world,
if I'm Relivia and we win against
Linsanity, we probably want to play
against Prismacism if I had to guess.
And then we want to see
Yeah.
And then we want to see Bradykin in the
final.
>> Okay, yeah, the Ezreal. You were talking
about this. Ezreal does not have an
ideal match up into the Lux cuz you're
not able to play fast enough and Lux
won't really give you anything to
interact with, which is what Ezreal's
looking for.
>> Yeah, exactly. Ezreal's a full control
list. It does have a lot of ways to make
you discard cards, but as we saw, Lux
has no problem drawing cards.
>> No, not at all. And the Ezreal will have
trouble drawing cards if you're not able
to target things on the opponent's
board, [music] which they're probably
not going to have any of. So,
um it's anybody's game at this point.
Let us know in chat who you think is
likely to win. Again, I still have Rizz
Mages and I think he's going to make the
run. If you give a player like him an
entire format to figure it out and solve
it, I have confidence that he will. Um
but you're again betting on the the new
kid on the block kind of, a newer deck
that um
what was that during the interview um
they they were saying they had played
like an unreasonable amount of games on
their own of just practicing the combo.
>> hours of solitaire.
>> Yep, apparently. And then a bunch of
testing with their team, right? With
Challenger TCG.
>> And testing often mean like that's
something I want to touch on as well is
they were testing where I'm like, "Hey,
I'm giving you two to five in hand. I
have to find a way to win." So, they
were kind of doing your puzzles.
>> Okay.
>> But giving their opponents essentially
the best case scenario that you can have
in the situation and Rulio is still
trying to figure out ways to win. And we
kind of see it, right? Rulio is able to
play from behind and figure out, "Okay,
well, I have 18 cards in my deck." Like
we saw in game number one against Alanz.
We have to kind of try to play through
that first hard bargain, try [music] to
get the loop going, and it's been paying
off. So, good practice.
>> But if you notice also in the top eight,
this is something we haven't talked
about too much yet is again what what
decks did not make top eight. Still no
Aurora and no LeBlanc. LeBlanc was not
able to crack into the top eight. So,
LeBlanc has really been struggling a lot
so far in the Unleashed format much more
so than Diana. Uh but let's take a look
here at some of the format and pricing
for the event.
Constructed a reminder, it was Swiss
with eight rounds on day one. If you had
six wins, you advanced to day two, where
we saw five rounds of Swiss play into
top eight. That's where we find
ourselves right now. We're about to get
into our top eight as soon as the
players are ready.
>> Yeah, and like we saw earlier when we
were looking through the players'
journey, I always call day one the zoo.
>> Yep.
>> You never know what you're going to sit
across from. It could be your best or
worst match up. And all these players
who have made the top eight not only
made it through the zoo, but as we saw
some of those day two runs, you have to
beat previous RQ winners. You know, you
have to kind of go up against your worst
match up and someone who's very
proficient on that deck. So, hats off to
our eight uh players here who have made
the top eight. And what are they playing
for? Let's go find out to see exactly
what is on the line for these players in
terms of pricing.
Um what I do like about uh
Riftbound in general, especially these
RQs, is that we've kind of extended our
pricing. Right? We've recently changed
the pricing where we go all the way down
to 128 with that Vex playmat.
>> [music]
>> And then if you're top 64, that's the
real big, you know,
goal post for a lot of these players. We
want to get that uh regional
championship invite.
>> And also the prize wall tickets. This is
something a lot of players have been
asking for is like, "Hey, if you make it
to day two, it's exciting, but how about
some prize wall tickets?" Cuz if you
don't make it to day two, you can do a
bunch of side events and kind of uh try
and get as many of those as you can.
Maybe get a metal plated card. Um so now
awesome that anybody in top 64 is able
to get 40 prize wall tickets. They can
get the the the pins. They can get the
plated cards. A lot of options there.
>> Yeah, and then uh the way you go up, you
have some cash prizes that gets involved
there. Top eight, you have that playmat
with the Poppy promo. And then another
Poppy promo uh for our champion. Uh and
then that'll be the last time we see
her.
>> Yeah. Let alone the best ofs.
>> Yes.
>> also typically if you're able to make it
into like that top 64, you're at least
in best of contention depending on how
popular your your legend is. Um but also
then of course into the top eight, you
know, you're almost guaranteed. The
Dianas are still in contention. Three of
them. Three Dianas
>> for that best of right now. Interesting.
>> We got our best of E, our best of Lux,
Pike is all locked, and uh Annie is all
locked as well. But we have a, you know,
three-way fight for these Dianas.
>> So, here's a here's a question I'm going
to frame. Because again, we're waiting
for the players to get ready uh for our
next round feature match in top eight.
I'm going to pose a question for you,
Granton.
>> Yeah, I'll answer it.
>> We have one uh past RQ qualifier winner
in Prismaticism.
We have seven new additions to top
eight.
>> Yep.
>> Who you betting on? Is it Prismaticism
or the field?
>> I think the field.
>> You think the field? Well, you also have
Lux, but try and remove your bias for
the Lux.
>> let's forget Lux exists for a second. I
do still think I we saw Factor play, we
saw Miru play, we saw Bradykin play.
There's a lot of talent in this top
eight. I'm going to, you know, stay true
to my colors that if Lux didn't exist, I
got my money on Bradykin.
>> Okay.
>> He has
>> Well, that's the that's your local
homeboy, right?
>> Yeah, so I have an unfair understanding
of this player's journey through
Riftbound. Notably, we all attend the
same LGS.
>> Okay.
>> This LGS has been running skirmishes
since Origins.
>> That's pretty good.
>> you one guess as to who's won every
skirmish, every single one at that LGS.
>> Every skirmish? How many?
>> He has won two per set.
>> Two per set?
>> He has six wins. He's undefeated at
skirmishes to the point where the LGS
owner
>> Let me guess, you gave it away that it
was him.
>> Yeah, well, I mean, I'm excited.
>> That's impressive. That is very
impressive.
>> There's a bounty on him at our
skirmishes now. If you eliminate him,
you get extra prizes.
No one's done it.
>> eliminated him.
>> No one's done it.
>> That's crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, I love it when the hometown
heroes show up, and then I'm sure
everybody at local game store is going
to be watching as well, paying attention
to his journey, and cheering him on from
home. [music]
But, we have our match vote here for
everybody that is watching at home. Hop
into chat and spam A or B. If you want
to watch A, that's Bradykin's Ezreal,
the hometown hero from Montreal, versus
Miru on Pike. If you want to watch match
B, it's B Shwitz's Diana versus
Prismaticism's
Annie. Type A for the top match, type B
for the bottom match. Let us know what
you want to see.
>> Yeah, a lot of people wanting to see
Bradykin. I was actually watching the
stream a little bit backstage as well. A
lot of people very happy with how
Bradykin communicates and plays. He's
very clean and deliberate when he plays,
and it's something a compliment I've
given him a lot, so a very very fun to
see the the rest of the Riptide
community noticing but Prismat and Bee
Swift, this is kind of an insane match
up too. Both these players are very
exceptional and very practiced on their
decks.
>> Yeah, I mean anytime you see Diana
expert play, it's just a treat man. I
said we don't get to see Alanzq in the
top eight but you still have to be
incredibly gifted at the deck and then
at the Riptide in general to pilot this
deck. It's very complicated. Prismat is
isn't an expert at Annie at this point
but it's looking like we're not going to
watch that one. We're going to watch
feature match A, Bradical as real versus
Miru's Pike. We're going to see a lot of
pack of wonders. I'm going to imagine
it.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, we're going to be
>> I'm not going to say it. I'm a
backpacking.
>> I was about to say it.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Get your pack everybody. Get your hiking
boots on.
>> Yeah.
>> We're hitting the slopes. We're bouncing
back to hand.
>> that's skiing I guess.
>> Yeah. We're hitting the steps.
>> That's not hiking.
>> We're exploring. We're exploring. We're
going exploring everybody.
>> Yeah. Backpack, backpack. All right. Um,
was it also Miru that or not Miru,
Bradical that did the Ezreal Miru match?
>> Yes. They saw on the the feature match
B.
>> The one that
40 minutes into the match there was it
was 2-0 in game one.
>> 2-0 in game one. 40 minutes into the
match. That was a hilarious one to watch
cuz it was on the secondary feature
match. I don't even know if stream got
to see that. We got to see it backstage.
Uh, that was like yesterday around six
or something like that but uh, yeah,
very very funny that he was able to make
that journey. There's a chance that the
Pike match up is similar cuz both of
these decks are going to have a lot of
things like the star cross. I mean
Pike's going to be bouncing his own
units back to hand and that's usually
what Ezreal's trying to do but even like
the gust from Ezreal can interrupt Pike
before he gets in. It's going to get
goofy.
>> Notably too, uh, we are untimed
>> Yes.
>> in this top cut. That being said, judges
are at the table.
>> Yeah.
>> Players are expected to maintain a a
pace of play.
>> Reasonable pace of play.
>> But a control I think this Miru list is
also a control list, right? I don't know
if it's like the hybrid spell slinger
aggro control weird version, weird in a
good way, but weird version but if it's
a control Miru, even if these both
players are playing quickly, it's going
to It's going to be a fun one.
>> The last Pike that we had seen on
feature match was more of kind of like a
ramp Pike. I hadn't seen one with like
the
as deep of like the Scryer's Blooms with
the Treasure Hoard and the Pack of
Wonders. Pack of Wonders makes a lot of
sense, but then the Treasure Hoard on
top, they were really trying to go wide
with the Rune Pool, wide with their
board as well. But you can also play a
more aggro style of the Pike instead.
We'll see which one we get here.
>> Oh.
>> As voted on by chat and also now we see
the win rates. Pike with a 67%
win rate over Ezreal.
>> Yeah.
>> In this match-up, Pike has a bit of an
advantage, you could say.
>> It's a two two to one advantage,
essentially.
>> Some might say.
>> Yeah. Or two two-thirds advantage for
the Pike. Um
It's a very uphill battle here for this
Ezreal player.
>> I will say that variants in builds can
play a big part in that, though.
Very different builds of the Pike as
well as different builds of the Ezreal.
But why do you think it might be that
Pike would have an innate advantage?
>> Well, like you mentioned, right?
Ezreal's game plan is to try to
play on the board quickly, back to hand,
right? And your hand's not safe against
Pike.
>> Sure.
>> Right? That's actually a really good
point, yeah.
>> But the inverse is true as well, right?
We know that Brady Ken is running
spirits as well. We know that he has
also the Pack of Wonders, so Pike's hand
also isn't safe. So Pike bouncing stuff
back to hand also makes it a little
difficult for the Pike player to kind of
develop. So I don't know if that this
match-up spread, obviously it's just
Ezreal legend versus Pike legend, but I
don't know how many of those Ezreals are
the Pack Ezreals.
>> It's also I'm hearing from production
that it's just from this regional and
it's only a seven game sample size. So I
I I would argue that's not a big enough
sample size to truly buy in, but so far
at this event Pike has been winning.
Let's take a look at the deck list.
>> One thing I want to touch on
specifically for this match-up is Deadly
Flourish. So Pike is very good at
playing to the base and kind of staying
away from that battlefield.
>> And a lot of three might two might
stuff. Yeah, like your
is a two might unit that can get
absolutely obliterated by that deadly
flourish giving as real gold is
obviously very very good cuz it allows
him to continue to have fun with us
those treasure troves and Sprite
fountains and stuff like that.
>> And also the fact that we're running
turn to dust in the main deck will get
some [music] value in this match up
because you're able to take out the
opponent's
tool of wonders, the lists, things like
that. So turn to dust sometimes you just
immediately side it out but I think this
is one of those match ups you're
actually going to be really happy when
you do see this card. Noticing though no
two energy units are in the main deck
here for Braddock and so much more of a
kind of mid-range control style here not
going to be playing much in the way of
the early game.
>> Yeah, very much I just want to deal with
the late game is that and inversely we
actually have nine two drops on the side
of Miru right we got the tie turner
traveling merchant and treasure hunter
to give you that early game to let you
cycle cards and treasure hunter is
exceptional with Pike because you're
very power hungry deck as we can see
there is a pretty big top end and this
looks a little less like control Pike
and more like
I would I don't know I would call it
like mid-range Pike.
>> I mean the fact that we have the
blighted battle axe let's pull that one
up here I have not seen this in a Pike
list before this is not going to be the
pack of wonders shenanigans type of Pike
this is more of a get on the battlefield
and use your legend ability type of Pike
because this will help you do that for
energy for might has a pretty steep
equip cost with an energy and a red
power
but then you can if you ever aren't
going to conquer like if you hold you
can always just use your Pike to return
the unit to hand so you don't lose it
it's actually a really interesting card
to see in Pike.
>> Yeah and we're actually ready to jump
into the match right now and I'm excited
to see how this one does [music] control
versus a mid-range Pike list right we
have some early game we have good top
end with that forerunner and that mind
splitter those Kaia's survivors as well
to allow us to maintain [music] that
card advantage or try to against an
Ezreal cuz if there's
if there's a deck that can draw almost
as much as Lux, it's Ezreal.
>> Almost. Almost as much. I will
>> Top eight, game number one.
>> two piles of gold.
>> It's going to be the hometown hero from
Montreal, Brad again, on the Ezreal, the
last remaining Ezreal in the tournament
versus Miru, the last remaining Pike.
Only one can go on to the semi-finals.
We got Sigil of the Storm versus
Ripper's Bay for game number one. And
this Ezreal, again, a very late game
[music] build. No two energy units, no
two drops. So, your turn one's probably
going to be like Pack of Wonders Pass
would be your ideal start.
Uh the Pike is playing a lot of units
that Ezreal's probably happy to see and
it looks like we did get that start
essentially.
>> Yeah, we got the inverse of that start,
it looks like. Uh we have a traveling
merchant in the trash and a deadly
flourish in the trash. So, kind of the
beginning that I assumed happened. Brad
being the first seed was able to choose
to go first. Uh we're at 0-0 game. We're
in turn looks like, if my math is
correct, turn three for Miru.
>> hearing that they've played four turns
in under a minute. They were going super
fast at the start there. So, we're
jumping in slightly behind, but it's all
right. We're going to see the Ka'isa
accelerated go in for Miru. Conquer at
the Ripper's Bay
uh and then draw a card.
>> Yeah, and this is again, we're going to
bring that Ka'isa back. She is not safe
when she's out in the battlefield
against a Ezreal control player, but in
the hand also kind of not safe as well,
but maybe a bit safer than
uh than being in the Oh, we're trying to
trigger the Ripper's Bay here as well as
the um
>> Yeah, so you paid two energy. I saw the
the double exhaust. One of that's going
to be for the Pike uh legend and the
other's for the Ripper's Bay to channel
a rune.
So, Miru's trying to get uh onto the
board a little faster here. Brad has yet
to establish a unit. Had two deadly
flourishes and now a Pack of Wonders and
it looked like we did see I think we saw
the Treasure Trove as well return to
hand at one point.
>> Yeah, we did bounce the treasure trove
last turn.
>> Yeah.
And it looks like currently they're
communicating with the judges. So if we
have an update we'll let you know,
otherwise hopefully we resume play soon.
Currently it's turning into more of like
a mid-game ramp for both players. Only
one point's been scored and I think it's
yeah, we're entering like turn seven
here
for Bradiken. Or it's Bradiken's fourth
turn I should say.
>> Fourth turn.
>> Fourth Bradiken. Seventh turn overall.
Seventh turn overall, yeah.
>> So this is what we paused on.
>> Oh, they didn't get the deck list to be
able to play against first. I see.
>> Yeah, it is open deck list.
>> Okay, it might be
>> They got their own deck list.
>> Hey, do you want to know what you're
playing?
>> Just in case.
>> Okay.
>> So notably
Let's see if we can hear the judge.
>> Okay.
And maybe frenzy.
>> Not quite catching what they're
>> It's about this turn.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
Okay. So it looks like
players were so ready to get going just
hop right in, but now they're going to
take a look at the deck lists cuz this
will
inform a lot of your decisions. It
actually is a very important part
especially when you make top eight. This
is one of the benefits of having no time
on the clock is that you can really look
at your opponent's list and say okay,
what are all of the answers they could
have? What's the
statistical probability that they have
those cuz you can see the play rate of
the cards. Like are they a one of or
they a four
Um very important part of the match. So
a little tough to see it happen like
right now, but it is important. So I'm
happy that both players are taking the
time now to review these.
>> Yeah, both players just kind of looking
over the deck list and
>> There may be there may be a case where
we can continue game one.
>> I exactly cuz I don't think this
information would have changed anything
I did.
>> Probably not, but that is how my day is.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, maybe some confusion on the fact
that we're supposed to look at these
lists before the game started
>> Yeah.
>> Um and not afterwards. So it looks like
we're going to take a little little
pause to properly review these deck
lists. Usually the rule of thumb here is
we're going to review the the list at
the beginning before we start the match.
We give players about 2 minutes to look
at the list.
>> Yeah, you've done this before as a head
judge. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So we'll usually put the this face
down in front of the players when the
game is ready to kind of get started.
We'll let the players take a look at
those lists, give them a couple minutes
to do so, take the list back and let
them take their notes that they need to
take before the game starts and then
they'll be good to go. So
Okay, looks like we're getting rid of
the notes. Notably you're not allowed to
take notes while you have the deck list.
>> Interesting.
>> little bit of a miscommunication it
looks like with the with the staff so
they took the paper it looks like that
he was taking the notes on with the deck
list just to make sure.
>> So you can review, take your notes
without reading the paper from memory
and then proceed to match.
>> All right, looks like the players are
ready to go.
Okay, and we're back into the game.
Thank you for bearing with us everybody.
Happy that the players were able to get
that information that
is going to be very beneficial going
into this.
>> Yeah, knowing like what tech pieces
might be in that deck. Obviously Miro
knowing that there's a main deck turns
to dust, that Blighted Battle Axe needs
to kind of be protected a little bit as
well. With the
1.3 rules update notably if we apply
temporary to a gear that is attached,
that is appended rules text that is
active. Back in spirit forge if you add
a temporary to a gear that was attached,
nothing would really happen on my
beginning phase but now with the
unleashed rules updates, if it's
attached and I add temporary to it, it
will kill on the beginning step.
>> Very important update there and also
very important because you know now for
Brad like oh, not Pack of Wonders, not
going to be doing all that stuff but
there is still a gear to target. Miro's
going to have the play now as the uh
uh spear came down and got rid of a
Cleave from Miro's hand.
>> Yeah, not very useful in this match up.
>> Yeah.
>> Still has the Kaisa, we know that. Could
just go for the same type of Ripper's
Bane play, but this time has the gold
gear to pay for the accelerate cost. So,
we know that's an option.
And then you would still have two energy
to play something else afterwards. If
you did like the full line with the uh
>> Oh, this works, too.
Yeah, Bradigan has four up. Uh going to
let it just go. Probably had some sort
of answer maybe in hand. Obviously, you
can't star cross here cuz you did kill
their unit on the previous turn, so uh
good sequencing by Mira to not deploy
the
traveling merchant, then falling star to
potentially get blown out by a star
cross. So, obviously, one of the many
reasons we're seeing him in the top
eight.
>> And it's one of those moments that you
you usually want to take that
opportunity. Just go and clear, so that
way you they can't keep Pack of Wonders
in and uh ripping more cards.
>> Um
Has Mira almost equipped the Blade of
Axe and realized, "Wait a minute. I did
not conquer. That would be a bad call."
>> Yeah, I was uh I had question marks in
my eyes when I saw that that rune get
exhausted.
>> There ain't okay.
Um
>> Lot of runes. That's a full ramp, isn't
it?
>> Tap two.
>> Look at the 12 runes available.
>> bellows on the guy.
>> Okay.
>> Uh trigger as legend.
>> Yep.
>> I understand that's why Mira would
probably want to equip, so that way the
traveling merchant can't be sniped so
easily, but uh you don't want to kill
your own unit. And the Bewitching Spirit
after this is pretty good for Bradigan.
>> Tap
>> So, we had five cards in hand, I think,
at the beginning.
>> Play Sprite Fountain.
>> Yep.
>> And this is where we're going to try to
get some early points. Early in air
quotes for control decks, but
>> Yep. I go to one.
>> Notably, uh still returned to the
Bewitching Spirit instead of the Sprite
Fountain. This is something you can do.
Play the Sprite Fountain, then return it
back to hand with the
uh Pack of Wonders in case you want to
just keep looping that uh Sprite
Fountain itself, but Sprite Fountain
will uh trigger the temporary most
likely at the start of Bradykin's turn.
>> Yeah, Bradykin trying to play Vexer
>> Decide. Yeah, there's the Vexers are a
really good play here. We know there's
obviously the Pike in the champion zone.
We know there's Kaisa that we bounced
back to hand earlier. This essentially
says, "Hey, your accelerate doesn't mean
anything."
You can still do it. You can still pay
for it, but you can't move.
>> Yeah. And still one up for something
like a Gust.
>> Yep.
>> Something like a Stupefy if you just
want to get an extra draw.
But good efficient turn from Bradykin.
Let's see what Mirror's able to do here.
Can always just develop a board if you
just want to play the Kaisa play. I you
really don't want to play the Pike, I
guess, cuz then it's just a two-mic
going in on the next turn.
>> We do have a it looks like a Forerunner
and a Kaisa in hand.
>> pretty good.
>> The issue here is if you develop a
Forerunner and you get it Star Crossed
next turn, it's really rough.
>> Yeah, they can only have one, so I
understand it hurts, but I still don't
hate the idea of it.
>> Yeah, you got to get something on the
board here, so I'm imagining the Kaisa
as well. There it is. Two bodies hit the
board. Mirror is going to pass.
>> temporary trigger.
Um so, awaken.
Um
>> Looks like a Star Crossed, probably.
Yep.
>> Cycle one
to Star Crossed the Sprite and the
Forerunner.
>> Very nice.
>> Pay one for the Rippers Bay.
>> This is here. This is gone.
>> So, even though you don't return the
Sprite to hand technically or
mechanically.
So, this was fascinating. Brady
purposely used
>> a rune to recycle for the Star Crossed
because he knew he was going to trigger
Rippers Bay, and he knew he was going to
awaken for turn. So, he wanted to get
maximum value of still having that
golden play.
>> Interesting.
>> Um
Pay three, recycle one,
playing Ez.
>> Okay, we're going to
>> I will discard Trove.
>> Develop slightly, draw more cards. Trove
gone. Doesn't really need it at this
point. Full ramp, essentially.
>> Um
How many guys in hand?
>> Two.
>> Only two in hand is actually pretty low.
Bradykin's definitely winning the
resource game.
He's looking for maybe another Star
Crossed or something to deal with that
Kaiza. I did see a list get picked up in
that stack deck. That could be a list
into a Bellossom or something along
those lines. If there is a Bellossom in
hand, not sure what Brady took.
But we're going to go into that sigil.
And again, rune economy, the rune
management has been stellar by Bradykin.
Recycling again one for that Ezreal.
This sigil is going to cause him to
recycle another one, which means next
turn he's going to channel those two
runes again. So, he's not kind of
missing out on resources and he still
has that gold ready to go.
Very efficient plays from Bradykin.
Still four runes up as well. So,
Mirror's not going to have a free
conquer here. He's going to have to be
aware of what could Bradykin have as a
response. Mirror is still though almost
full ramp here.
>> Yep.
>> Still has that forerunner in hand cuz it
was returned back from the Star Crossed,
but this Kaiza with the Blighted Axe can
punch really hard.
>> Notably do though when you try to equip
the axe to a unit, it does create a
trigger.
>> Okay. So, a Star Crossed potentially
could be
held up
>> Yeah.
>> to try to make you D ramp a little bit,
commit to some sort of play and then put
that Kaiza back in your hand.
A lot of cards in Brady's hands as we
can see there in the player cam. Looks
like probably seven or six cards in
their hand.
>> Already one Star Crossed used, so let's
see it it it won't be like super likely
for him to have another one, but not
outside a question.
Moving into that sigil.
Not trying to fight the Vex.
>> Yeah, very interesting. I would have
expected
>> use the gold.
>> Said pay two, but he flipped three. So,
I'm assuming that the exhaust three in
the gold will be star crossed. Oh, no.
Taking it back.
>> I'm
>> Looks like a stupefy perhaps.
>> an option for one.
>> Oh, stack deck.
Yeah, I mean you might as well. You
still have another four action window
here if you want to star cross still.
>> And you're
>> Quick stack deck actually.
>> Oh, just lets it go.
>> I did see a fizz and a watcher in that
stack deck. If I'm assuming probably
we're taking the fizz here. That allows
us to star cross again and bring that
fizz back to hand if we really want to.
>> I floated the power.
>> But con green adds sigil storm means
that mirror has to recycle a rune now
floating the energy here. So, mirror
does still have one energy to spend
there.
Should also be floating a a power as
well. Oh, actually no, no cuz
>> No, he used it to Oh.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Sure, I will discard.
>> Bewitching spirit.
>> Gust.
>> Nice.
>> Yep.
Now bouncing it back to hand.
>> Like legend, I assume that this is just
going to come straight back to the
field. Of course, yeah. Naturally.
Probably the base.
>> Yeah.
>> Then he can equip the four runner.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Go ahead.
>> So, Brady can have three runes that were
not used on the turn. Was not able to
fully maximize the energy usage over the
two turns, but still full ramp
and still ahead in points. This vex
apathetic is still at the battlefield
slowing down mirror's plays.
I think I saw a stupefy in the hand.
Didn't notice
>> Stupefy and bellows I saw.
>> Okay.
>> Pretty good combo.
>> We do have access to the entire If If we
did take that fizz, I'm not sure if we
did take the fizz, but I mean Brady's
looking through his trash. So, I'm
assuming we did take the fizz. Uh star
crossing that four runner again would be
kind of crazy.
>> One
>> Looks like we're playing four.
>> Accelerate a thousand tail.
>> Oh, yeah. Watcher is good.
>> you down down to five. Swing here seven
to five.
>> Nice. It's one way to deal with the
>> And notably four runes available.
We can star crossed. We can even bring
that watcher back to our hand if we want
to.
That's kind of filthy.
>> Chap
three
>> Yep.
>> cycle one
to play Fizz
>> Yep, there he is.
>> star crossed and sell
>> This time spend the gold, yep. So now
it's going to be at full 12 rune ramp at
Beritkin's next turn. There are three
that have been recycled this turn, but
still very good sequence of plays. There
are no units on field for Miru and with
that Vex hypothetical very low chance of
Miru actually getting onto the board and
doing anything else. And packing Ezreal
putting him in the backpack. Uh Ezreal,
notably, is a you know
looting card, right? Draw him, discard a
card, draw two, very good. He also makes
your optional additional cost cheaper,
so stuff like Bella's breath uh do get
reduced by that.
>> hard bargain
>> [laughter]
>> It definitely did. Five to two and
you're the controllers. Yeah.
Very, very well played from Beritkin.
Very impressed with the decisions he's
made so far.
>> Uh let me see your discard. I have
another star crossed.
>> Yeah, that was a star crossed used once
from hand and then once from graveyard
>> I shouldn't have another star crossed in
trash. Yeah.
>> Uh uh does he?
He played one from hand and one from
trash, which was the one he played from
hand. I don't think there's another one
in the trash.
>> there's another one in him.
>> We just develop again.
This is the brutal part about playing
against this Ezreal list is that we've
now played this forerunner three times
and we've yet to awaken it.
>> Yep. It used to be the league of
forerunner.
Yeah. Not as much anymore into these
control lists, these uh chaos control
lists.
>> And Miru actually talked about that in
his winner's interview uh that Berit was
doing with him
that uh it's brutal against star
crossed. And you're seeing it here.
>> flourish Kai'Sa
>> Wow.
Stupefy and deadly flourish will do four
total mights worth of damage and that
will kill the Kai'Sa. Now, just one more
star crossed on this forerunner again.
That would probably just be game.
That looks like a star crossed.
>> star crossed spirit first.
>> Wow.
Wow.
>> going game two.
>> Wow.
Miru is going to scoop it up there. GG
game one goes to Bradykin expert control
gameplay from the Ezreal pilot with all
these star crossed on the Ferris
forerunner. You never actually get that
death nil value and Miru is going to
have to find a different avenue to
approach here as we head to side
boarding for game number two.
>> It's a little less frustrating watching
Bradykin do this to someone and not
having him do it to [laughter] me.
>> Yeah, you've been on the receiving end
of this one before?
>> Uh yeah, once or twice.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I've also watched
watched him do this quite a few times
and the general consensus is it's a very
frustrating deck to play against as most
control lists are.
>> Yeah, some decks will have natural
strengths against it but you can see
that Pike kind of plays into the range.
It's it's something that gets punished
by the Vex epic.
>> Because you do have some of these
accelerate units like the chosen Pike
champion and the Kai'Sas and then also
your death nil triggers are just not
going to go off with these star crossed.
So it is an ideal match up for the
Ezreal I'd say which is interesting to
think that the Pike had the positive win
rate in the one V ones so far in
Hartford. Again, it was only seven game
sample size, pretty small.
>> I just I love watching Miru shuffle
through his deck and take out all the
forerunners.
>> Yep.
>> Yep, they are dead card in this match
up.
>> Great into certain color combinations,
not great into the chaos color
combinations. If you're against an order
match up, yep, those probably stay in.
>> Yep, that is for sure. Anything that
wants to kill your unit is great but
anything that puts it back to your hand.
>> on the back of this card.
Um I don't know if it can be rubbed off.
>> Okay.
Yeah.
>> We just use a side board sleeve maybe?
>> I mean it's just a sleeve.
Um I can't see it anymore.
>> [laughter]
>> It's good though. I like you said,
anytime a player sees something like
this, point it out to the judges, let
them fix it.
>> I think you're good, but I just want to
double-check.
>> Yeah, put two cards side by side, see if
you can tell the difference. If you
can't, then you're probably good.
>> Oh, we got to tell the difference too.
Nice shot there.
>> Yeah, no, I think it's good.
>> I'm also not going to inform myself what
card that was.
Just to be safe.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Attaboy, Brady.
I mean, like you said, he's been playing
pretty clean so far.
>> stopped me that one.
>> Yeah, I I mean, I started with the Pack
Trove combo in hand and the double
flurry. It was It was an unreasonable
opening hand.
>> [laughter]
>> And again, you know, the Pike plays into
that range Flurry of Feathers Sorry,
Deadly Flourish, I should say.
Um very, very good into these uh kind of
uh two-drop heavy lists, cuz they commit
a a body for one turn. You just play a
spell, clear that body, get a gold gear
really efficient.
>> I was like, "Please to get rid of this
Fex."
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Not only I was watching Miru shuffle and
I saw a Thermal Beam get added
naturally, it would also a Hard Bargain.
So, we had some Hard Bargains in the
sideboard to try to deal with the
spell-slingy aspect of this control
list. So, Miru I mean, now getting to go
first, which is obviously better with
nine two-drops in your deck, but also um
Frozen Fortress and Forbidden Waste
on a deck that plays the list, that
Frozen Fortress could be tricky.
>> Very, very good for the Azariel.
>> And uh this Pike was not on the similar
list. It's not like a Pack of Wonders
list Pike build, so
Miru theoretically will not get the same
value, but players have
put back two cards each, drawn their
cards to replace, and now Miru is
starting his turn. Let's get a look at
that top-down view, so we can see what's
happening here in game number two.
>> Trove pass.
>> Oh, and we have the Trove open again.
Pretty good. Do we have the Pack? Oh, we
have a Gust up as well.
>> Woah. Yeah, that is
>> Going second, never punished.
>> quite strong. Again, this Pike list
plays into the range of what a control
Ezreal will want to do.
>> Move trigger, yeah?
>> Move trigger will happen. Attempt to
conquer will Bradykin
>> Oh, letting it conquer. Okay. Argument
that you hold it so that way you can
trigger your Ezreal ability, the legends
on a future turn.
>> Discard a gust.
>> We discard the gust.
>> Oh.
Very interesting.
>> Chump.
Shump two.
>> I always love it when you see really
good players do something and you're
like, I don't think I would have done
that.
>> Yeah, why are they doing that? Yeah.
>> Clearly, they know more.
>> That's why they're doing that.
>> That would make sense.
Okay.
But, the
Bewitching Spirit was looped so Miru has
the access that again. Probably won't
get it to a battlefield unless you
commit your Pike
to the play.
Ooh, good hand. That's a Rengar, that's
a Void Seeker. We saw a
>> This is
>> And I think a second Bewitching Spirit
with a stacked deck, very solid hand.
>> Much better hand than what we saw
previously. We are looking at another
Fizz, Treasure Hunter, and a Rengar. We
took I think the Rengar.
>> Actually.
>> I'm curious what he was digging for,
yeah. It looks like Fizz was not picked
for whatever it was.
Uh could have just gone for a double
Bewitching Spirit. Had the energy up for
it. That's what I also expected, but
just one Bewitching Spirit pass,
Bellows' Breath is gone.
>> Two.
>> Yeah, and this is kind of where it's
going to get a little tricky for
Bradykin is that we have two spirits and
we can potentially be playing, you know,
a 1.3 Oh, hold on. Ready to see
something wild, he said.
>> Pause.
>> Okay.
>> Draw two.
Pay
two, recycle one, repeat Bellows.
>> That's three Bellows that we saw.
[laughter]
And that's also a reason why you don't
want to play the second Bewitching
Spirit is if you read Bellows' Breath,
they would both die. All Bellows'
Breaths have now been accounted for.
They're all out of there. Fizz could
copy one. Fizz could copy one.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh notably why uh
we had that cost reduced as well by
Ezreal for the repeat, so a cheaper
Bellows' Breath. So, for Twitch chat
who's saying he didn't pay his costs, he
definitely paid his costs.
>> That was wild though. I'm happy he gave
us a a warning for that one.
>> Yeah, he's like, "Hey, tune in.
Check this out."
>> Check this out.
>> Stack deck
from the Fizz getting played.
And there's
>> Hey,
that looks familiar. We're both on
Ezreal. Look at this, some dapper
gentlemen on the field right now.
>> Yeah, this is a sideboard Ezreal. I
don't remember seeing one in the main
deck.
Understandable if you're siding into
very impactful uh counters to the
opponent. Ezreal will also help you find
those, some of those ones. [laughter]
>> As a player, you find a real dangerous
>> [gasps]
>> I'm going [laughter] to float one
energy.
>> So, we've been told to use like these
before.
Uh I know how a die works.
Uh
>> [laughter]
>> recycle this to sack trove.
>> Yep.
>> Channel
draw.
>> Not having the Pack Wonders yet, it
would appear.
>> I can
use the floating
Stupefy Ezreal.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, I'm going to go for a draw here.
No, Ezreal there if there's a one of
Ezreal in the main deck.
>> There wasn't one of Ezreal in the main,
okay.
>> Mhm.
>> Play Pack
>> Ooh, does have the Pack of Wonders.
Probably got that off of the Stupefy, I
would imagine.
>> Fizz here.
Pay three, recycle one.
Play Fizz.
>> Okay, here comes the Bellows'. Quite
funny.
>> Repeater, two damage to each of them.
>> Yep.
>> Oh, and if you have another Stupefy,
that can get rid of the Fizzes as well.
Or list.
>> Yeah.
>> What are Fizz's tags, I wonder?
I would guess
Fizz, Bilgewater, and Yordle. I was
going to say Bilgewater, I was going to
say Yordle, and then you got it out
before I did.
There is the list. Calls one of them. It
wipes all three units. What a play from
Bradiken.
>> Do you ever see a deck and you're like,
this is really cool, and then you try to
play it in your head and you're like,
yeah, this is too much.
>> Yeah, I I this is cool for people with a
large enough brain.
>> Not us.
>> Falling stars are a great answer though.
Mirr's able to also clear. There are no
units on either [laughter] board right
now, and one point has been scored in
game two of our top eight feature match.
Bradiken though does that have those two
gears in play? Notably Mirr did
sideboard in those thermo beams and that
can completely wipe
the back line of Bradiken.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, cool.
Want to make sure that we recycled for
that Fizz earlier.
And now Mirr having some some options
here.
Considerably more cards in hand than the
last game.
>> Yes, last time it was already by this
point, like down to two in hand and just
He's always got it.
Hoping you would whiff one turn, the one
time.
>> Yeah, I'll accelerate this guy here.
>> Okay.
Will be exhausted as it moves, but will
get the point.
Did I miss a point? Did I miss the two
conquer?
>> Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. I did it on the
wrong one. I'm at two.
>> All good.
>> [laughter]
>> A good reason as to why both players
should track the score.
>> Yep.
>> Judges had it right on the overlay as
well, so I'm sure it would have been
rectified if there was a disagreement.
Bouncing the pike back to hand. Maybe we
>> Is the pike unit a Bilgewater unit?
>> Uh probably.
>> I believe it would be.
>> We can keep playing. I'm just curious to
know.
>> I'm I'm going to say yes.
>> We'll we'll we'll check.
>> It is a Bilgewater unit. It's in the
Bilgewater lore in League of Legends.
>> Starcross.
>> And here's the Bewitching Spirit that
will discard a Starcross for Bradicken.
Pretty high value spell there to get rid
of, but not into this board. You don't
really want to return that
Bewitching Spirit back to hand.
>> Flesh.
>> Did we Yeah, Bilgewater and Pike. That's
what he is.
>> He is in fact Pike.
>> True.
>> Uh I do believe we packed our Fizz if
I'm not mistaken a couple turns ago.
>> Oh, okay.
>> So, putting stuff into our trash is like
a second hand.
>> For the trove back in the past.
>> It's my favorite way to play with the
second hand.
But more of a development of uh draw and
energy ramp for Bradicken on this turn.
No units played.
So, Rek'Sai will get a draw from Meerum
and another point.
So, Bradicken's falling behind
significantly in points currently, but
is still playing very patient because
it's a control list. You're just trying
to out resource your opponent and so far
Bradicken is doing that.
>> And a really good Again, this Kaisa not
staying on the board is best case
scenario for Meerum, right? We know that
list is I believe why Brady asked about
Bilgewater cuz he named Bilgewater when
he was trying to get rid of that Fizz
earlier.
>> And funnily enough, I believe Tide
Turner is also Bilgewater. Actually, no,
no, I think he's Ionian. No, he's Yeah,
I I'm pretty sure he's not Bilgewater.
>> No, he is.
Yeah.
>> Wow, okay. Bilgewater.deck. Bilge
>> I am floating one energy, one power.
Um
and packing the trove.
>> Packing the trove.
>> Draw.
>> Surprised that a treasure trove would
fit in a backpack.
>> Doesn't seem, you know,
>> What if you like open the contents of it
and put it in the backpack then?
>> Maybe the backpack's like bigger on the
inside, one of those like magic
backpacks.
>> I returned it with the Pack of Wonders,
yeah.
>> They just called it Pack of Wonders.
>> Yeah, hold on.
>> Wow.
dude. [laughter]
>> Flame.
>> why they pay you the big bucks.
>> I am then going to sack it.
>> Oh, now we're sacking it. All right,
yep,
going to go for the sack again. Channel
the ruin draw card.
Quite obvious in hindsight.
>> Yep.
>> Playing Vex.
>> There she is.
>> goes wild. Vex Apathetic has hit the
board.
>> Spirit discard a card.
>> My turn, says Bradigan.
>> [snorts]
>> Still three runes available.
Ooh, discarding one of the outs to the
Vex Apathetic.
>> Pack.
Pack the spirit.
>> Another pack. Double pack. This is going
to get goofy. If we can find a thermal
beam though on Miro side, this would be
our window we need to get back into it.
>> Very true. No runes up or not enough up
for a hard bargain on Bradigan's side.
So, this would be the turn to do it.
>> Can accelerate that Kaisa to try to get
more draw.
Dig a little bit deeper for that thermal
beam, but getting rid of a list and two
pack of wonders is
>> That would feel real juicy.
>> A-okay. You would only have enough to do
the accelerated Kaisa and then draw and
that would be five more energy
available. You're de-ramping two cuz you
have the gold here you can spend on the
Kaisa accelerate.
>> Mhm.
>> Might be worth it either way just to
play the Kaisa.
>> Looks like that's what we're mathing out
probably on the side of Miro. We're
splitting our runes up.
Making sure we have enough if we do find
that thermal beam or maybe calculating a
line that I don't even know.
>> Yeah.
I just love how calm Bradigan is. If I'm
staring down
somebody who's like three points up,
probably going to go to five and I
haven't scored one yet, I start to
panic, you know, I'm like, I got to get
in this game. I got to start playing,
but Bradigan cool as a cucumber over
here.
>> Yep.
>> Zero points, zero problems. Kaisa goes
in, conquers on Forbidden Wastes, will
draw a card and get a point for Miro.
>> Wondering what was drawn. Bouncing back
to hand. Oh, yeah, well, now he can't
play a thermobeam. Obviously, he didn't
draw it or else he wouldn't have done
this.
>> Yep.
>> But now we're Oh, okay. Now you play the
Kai'Sa because it's no longer as safe in
the hand.
>> I think it was five cards in hand for
Miro.
>> I believe so, yeah.
>> Bradykin could get rid of three of them.
>> This turn.
>> Is that enough?
>> Um
>> We do need to put that Kai'Sa back in
the hand somehow.
>> Cuz it does just currently trade with
the Vex.
>> Yeah.
>> Or you just don't commit the Vex to the
board.
Or you pack the list and
name Kai'Sa or
what if what if the void?
Is that her tag?
I would Yeah, it should be the void.
>> That's so good.
>> I'm going to move here. Pass the turn.
>> [laughter]
>> Go to one.
>> [snorts]
>> All right, first point for Bradykin.
>> Did you know the Bag of Wonders is a
reference to a limitless bag?
>> Hang two.
>> I'm a Lux enjoyer, so I did know that.
>> Or Sprite Fountain.
>> And there's a fountain. Now we're going
to try to get some point tempo here.
Obviously, putting that one on the
Forbidden Wastes cuz we don't really
care if it dies.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Vex taking one damage every turn. Not
the end of the world, especially when
our opponent plays Void Seeker. And
we're going to see the spirit come down,
discarding a traveling merchant on the
side of Miro. Still seven runes
available, looks like, for Bradykin. So,
a lot of room to work with if he wants
to pack that spirit and replay it. Or if
he's going to try to deal with that
Kai'Sa.
>> can also return the uh double pack.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, you get the Sprite
Fountain back to hand.
>> This is a
>> who had it before. You don't have to
play it right now. You can just hold it
in hand and then use it again next turn.
And then still play the Unyielding
Spirit. But not going to play the
spirit, actually. Looks like we're just
passing turn. So, how many runes is that
up for Bradykin?
>> Seven, I believe.
>> That's a double hard bargain and a uh
star-crossed.
>> Yeah, I'm just looking at his list.
>> Thinking of the likely tools, I feel
like those would be the two that you
have to watch out for right now for
Miro.
Cuz like the the Void Seeker would be an
obvious out to this uh
>> Oh.
>> Boadicea Thunder Song.
>> I am going to
>> Star crossed the recycle one.
>> Kaisa most likely.
>> Star crossed Sprite Kaisa.
>> Yep, makes sense.
So Boadicea Thunder Song once it hits
the field will activate its trigger
ability. Your opponent can no longer
play cards for the rest of this turn.
You do have a reactions. Star crossed a
great reaction and now the void seeker
can come down. No ability for Bradigan
to interact with that card.
Boadicea Thunder Song incredible card
[snorts] for fury decks to play.
Especially into these control match ups.
The I Miro that was such an efficient
turn to do it. Seven runes up on
Bradigan's side.
You get a non ideal star crossed and
then four wasted runes. Like Bradigan
will not be able to use these runes on
this turn. Really big for Miro. And here
comes Pike.
>> Yep.
>> Now that Vex is no longer in play we can
move that Pike in the same turn. We're
going to do a little short cut here. Go
to six. So threatening lethal on our
next turn. Obviously Bradigan is
probably more than capable of clearing
this board. But without that Vex that
Kaisa is going to come in from from hand
and start working.
>> You would imagine but still Miro is
putting the pressure on Bradigan to stop
Miro's advance.
In the tank.
Lot of cards, lot of choices.
Miro is on the stack deck has made this
selection.
Let's see what Bradigan can do here.
You need to clear at least two units.
I'll go again. Sure.
Uh mind splitter, uh stupefy. I couldn't
see the third one.
Thank you for just missing the time
there, yeah.
He's too quick.
Too fast. I mean these guys finish what?
Two turns a piece in a minute in game
one?
>> Oh yeah, they were flying.
>> Yeah.
>> We were almost at the end of game
we'll
>> find it eventually.
>> [laughter]
>> We do we have a fizz as well so we could
do a fourth stack deck.
>> Oh, let's do it. Come on.
>> Let's give the people what they want as
well.
>> True.
>> Yeah, not a no-brainer here. Definitely
want to think we know there's a kaisa in
hand.
>> You could also fizz in I believe there's
a deadly flourish in the trash.
>> It's too expensive.
>> Well, if you fizz into the deadly
flourish then you can pack of wonders to
fizz back fizz again. Oh yes, it is a
four energy you're right. Yeah, too
expensive for the fizz. Too expensive,
yeah.
>> Replay it naming that is Freljord,
right?
>> It is Freljord.
>> Who knows?
>> Can't confirm.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm pretty sure I'm naming whatever it
is which is the
>> Yeah, he's good. He's got it. Freljord.
>> How do you pronounce it? Freljord, yeah.
>> How did you think it was?
>> I don't know. I never tried pronouncing
it.
>> Freljord.
>> Nope.
>> I am attacking to
>> Definitely not that.
>> recycling
for a sprite fountain.
>> We go again. Kill that Oh, we're pretty
much clearing the board.
>> And you can clear the tie turner. You
can pack of wonders. Yeah, yeah, here we
go.
>> Oh, beautiful here showing the
versatility of pack of wonders. It's not
just for the list. It's not just for
your
uh your spirits but it's also for the
sprite fountain and I'm actually going
to look to hold.
>> And I will pass to you.
>> Yeah, you have to be careful.
Oh, so you double kaisa and cleave,
yeah.
>> I was trying to play around double kaisa
cleave. I couldn't play around.
>> There it is. GG's.
Well done. Mirror was able to get it at
the end showed that he had enough to go
on with the kaisa and the cleave
Bradicken.
>> If only all my bellows hadn't ended up
in the trash.
>> [laughter]
>> They might have been helpful at various
points there.
>> Maybe.
Perhaps. He did discard one of them
himself.
>> [sighs]
>> He did discard one to the Ezreal,
correct? Yeah.
And I believe he discarded another one
from the
bewitching spirit. Bewitching spirit, I
think, yeah.
I mean when you have a hand that's full
of gas, at one point you have to discard
one of those.
>> Yeah, true.
>> Going to game three. Bradykin on the
Ezreal.
>> Thank you.
>> Human time, yeah.
>> Human time, not round time.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, I think we've been pretty quick.
We've been pretty
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, they've been very fast.
>> Yeah, they've done two games in 30
minutes.
>> No, no, no, no. Especially not with this
kind of version of Pyke.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> No, that match up was
I can't relive it right now. I can't
[laughter] I can't go through that.
>> Talking about the Ezreal mirror that he
played yesterday.
>> Yeah.
>> Makes it more fun at least.
>> Where's that other manage match up
manage to find the answer of what if
there is no beat down?
>> [laughter]
>> ever incentivized ever to do it.
>> Uh I like Mirror's assessment there. He
is the beat down. He's playing the the
deck with more units in it. Kind of the
one pressured to make things happen, or
at least start the action.
What if he just didn't though? What if
Mirror just never went in?
Think about it.
>> It'll be a big problem for Mirror.
>> Probably.
>> Yeah.
You ever seen a game end with just
Bewitching Spirits going green?
>> Uh reveal battlefields.
>> It's deja vu for Bradykin.
>> Aspirants climb and Aspirants climb!
>> Both
for game three in your
>> top eight feature match. We're going at
10 points in the control Ezreal versus
the Pyke.
>> The smile on Bradykin's face when he saw
both those Aspirants get flipped.
Incredible.
Well, strap in everybody. Get ready.
Could be a long one.
>> Yeah, we got a pack on turn one. Pack of
what, by the way?
>> A wonders.
>> Thank you.
>> Yes.
>> Sure. We got a little two drop there,
but dies to Abyssal, dies to a Deadly
Flourish.
>> Kind of dies to a Cool Breeze. Um
perhaps.
Treasure Hunter known for not being the
most sturdy of two drops, but that's a
pass.
>> Yeah, I we saw the Deadly Flourish off
the stack deck, unfortunately, so too
late to play.
>> Only three runes, yep.
>> Maybe a Gust, but you would still get
the movement of the Treasure Hunter,
which will generate a gold for you. So,
Miro is in a pretty good spot here.
>> Yeah, you won't get a point, but I mean
you probably want the Treasure Hunter
back in your hand anyway.
>> Yeah, right.
I imagine it was going to go there off
of the pike anyway.
>> I will wage.
>> That's a little better, yep.
>> a little better.
>> It's gotten richer.
>> [laughter]
>> Another one.
Oh, déjà vu.
>> Okay.
Let's see if this one survives longer.
Pass. So, three energy up for Miro.
>> Two.
>> Bradykin's looking for things to get
value from the Spacewanderer. The
Treasure Trove would be great. There it
is.
>> Here we go.
>> Very big combo here.
>> Flourish.
>> I'm sorry. Play Pactrove.
>> Oh, no.
>> Oh.
>> Draw. Pass to you.
>> Hit him with the I'm sorry. Going to be
at 10 runes on the next turn. What a
ramp for Bradykin. Miro will get a point
here. I mean, there's no energy up for
Bradykin, so
>> I you're on the board.
>> This is rough.
>> I'll splitter.
>> There's the Mind Splitter going to get
maybe get one of them.
>> Okay, that's actually pretty nice. Oh,
double Star Crossed and a Fizz.
>> Yeah, getting rid of the trove is
natural here.
>> Yeah, but still with double list, double
Star Crossed and Fizz, this is an
incredible hand for Bradykin. Now,
bouncing back the Mind Splitter not
always ideal cuz then they get use of
it, but
in a pinch.
>> Oh, two Star Crossed.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, go for it.
>> Can I also grab you the wages of pain?
And then clear out the
uh
>> Treasure hunter.
>> Treasure hunter and then just get
another gold. That's not bad uh use of
the fizz either.
It replaces the gold, right? You can use
the gold to play the fizz.
>> Yep, exactly.
>> And then replace it with that uh wages
of pain, get rid of the treasure hunter.
Mind splitter is a little bit of
trickier to deal with.
Because you do need to either use two
lists on it to kind of get it down and
that's exactly what Bradykin's going to
do. Replace the gold, probably pack the
fizz back and uh you know, live to fight
another day.
Your tapped out right is never something
I want my opponent to And there's the
double He knows what's going to happen.
Yeah, he
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, yeah. I mean, he saw the double
list.
Did you know that a mind splitter is a
dragon?
Yeah, it's also a from Mount Targon.
Shrink.
You just made the list.
Um I will bounce that list back to hand.
>> Ooh, okay.
>> Just set something more nicely neutral
like Bilgewater.
>> Nice. Sure. Just efficient. Use your
runes. There's nothing else that you're
going to be saving them for and there's
a lot of Bilgewater in Miru's deck.
>> Yeah, that is a good one. I'm curious.
We didn't obviously bounce our our fizz,
but we've kind of noticed that units
contrarily to Bradykin's deck, when
you're playing against Miru, your units
are actually safer on the back line.
We have void seekers and we have
bewitching spirits, but we don't really
have much ways to deal with the back
line.
>> except for the falling star.
>> But you a falling star on one fizz
doesn't feel great.
>> Right.
>> So, I think it's going to be relatively
safe back there and also I think
Bradykin's realizing I'm so far ahead in
card advantage at this point just from
the pack of wonders and the list uh
looping. Maybe you can actually start to
be the beat down. Eventually, the
control deck has to actually commit to
win the game to the board and win the
game.
>> What I am a little worried about if I'm
Bradykin, you've seen the deck list. You
know there's a thermo beam. It's a 10
point game. The longer we wait, the more
cards we're letting Miru draw,
especially when we're fist stack
decking.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh and potentially finding a thermo
beam.
>> He is digging for that thermo. Was it
one or two thermo beams sided?
>> Do do you have
>> I can pull up the list and pull it up.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm very curious cuz he didn't
see any game two.
>> We have two thermo beams.
>> Two thermo beams.
>> Go for it.
>> Thank you.
>> If he brought both of them, which I
assume he would have.
>> I don't remember and I don't remember.
>> Yeah, I know the feeling.
Good sportsmanship from Bradigan.
All right. Two energy up, two units on
the field. 12 runes it looks like.
>> Channel two.
>> 12 runes for Bradigan, yeah.
This is where I think it's 10 or 12
runes where it gets very scary to play
against an Ezreal.
>> I think he might have that list already
called Bilgewater, so he can hit the
fish and hit the traveling merchant.
>> That's pretty good. Please discard a
card.
>> Bounce replay.
>> Please discard a card.
>> I don't think you have to say please. I
think you can just kind of demand it.
>> He's from Canada.
Yeah.
>> Bounce replay.
>> He's a polite lad.
>> [snorts]
>> Please discard one
>> That is a third bewitching spirit.
And welcome to playing against Pack of
Wonders Ezreal, everybody.
>> One card in hand it looks like.
>> [laughter]
>> You can't play it again. Can't play it a
fourth time.
>> Now we're in top deck mode.
>> I feel like that was psychological
damage.
More than anything.
>> Yep.
Two Well, two or three cards in hand it
looks like actually.
We know one's a merchant.
>> Man, if Miru had just found that thermo
beam off of either the stack decks, this
game would be completely different.
Imagine if Miru can actually get his
hands on that.
>> Yep. Bounce it back.
What do we have to play for our Fizz
here in the trash, I wonder? Another
mind splitter is great. Pass him the
spirit.
Yep.
>> Yeah, get that out of there.
>> [laughter]
>> Um oh, sorry. There you go.
>> Ooh, Turn to Dust. Not super useful
until we see that Blighted Battleaxe
come down, but
>> Nice that Brad Ekin actually kept it in
the list though, cuz I feel like
Blighted Battleaxe is maybe one that
comes out if you're not like needing to
punch very hard.
>> Perhaps.
>> I feel like Miru probably doesn't need
that.
We don't have any other gears in the
deck, it looks like.
>> Channel.
Draw.
>> Two units for Miru again. Let's see if
they survive this time.
Mind Splitter's harder for Ezreal to
deal with, but with two lists, not
impossible.
>> Yep.
>> Discard Fodder for Ezreal.
>> At the very least.
>> And I love this type of sequencing. Brad
Ekin awaited very long to play the
Ezreal because he had good plays before.
You don't need to dig for cards if you
already have plays you're happy with.
Now going to start digging for cards.
>> We get to go again.
Dig some more.
>> Discarding.
>> I am an Ezreal and I'm digging into my
deck.
Two.
>> Trove an interesting discard here.
Especially with two packs in play.
>> Yeah, I mean you're already kind of
ramped.
>> It is. So, this Ezreal's probably a
better draw engine at this point than
the the Treasure Trove.
>> There's Vex.
>> Okay, not even going to play the Ezreal
next. It's just the Vex.
>> Play the list naming dragon.
>> Yep.
>> We have two lists. So, no, we have one
naming Bilgewater and one naming dragon.
>> Yep. And pass.
>> So, one of those lists can hit the Mind
Splitter. I imagine that's just setting
up for a double list or a triple list
rather dragon play on the next turn.
>> Could be quadruple. Yeah, wow. You can
make that thing negative one before
Bella's breath even hits.
>> [laughter]
>> Triple's enough.
>> Yeah, it should be.
>> I I can't hear you. I'm sorry.
Sure. How about I put them all the way
over here?
>> All right, judges looking to confirm
just the board state currently as Miru
will move the merchant in discarding the
Blighted Battleaxe did stay in the main
deck. It's Sorry, stay in the deck after
siding.
>> Mhm.
>> And then drawing a card with the
merchant.
>> Notably, Brady's units that he uses to
close out the game are stuff like
Watcher.
And if he does get established on a
battlefield, that Blighted Battleaxe can
definitely help to get over top of it.
Same thing with Cleaves. Uh we need We
needed the Cleave last game, right? We
saw it, right? You needed double Caustic
Cleave to win because he double stacked
the Sprites on the uh on the
battlefield, so
don't hate it. And there is the
Thermobeam.
>> Massive.
You got me.
>> What a valuable spell. Six gears gone,
two of them gold gears, two lists, two
Pack of Wonders. Bradykin's going to
have to find a different way to deal
with that Mind Splitter.
>> Thinking.
>> And that's the downside of playing those
lists preemptively. Yes, it saves you
some runes on the next turn, but it
makes them fodder for the Thermobeam.
All right, so the merchant's going to go
back to hand, play it safely in our
base.
>> Pass.
>> I thought about maybe uh you go Mind
Splitter in and then return the Mind
Splitter back to hand to try and loop
that a few times, but the Mind Splitter
on field currently checks the Vex. So I
think that's the bigger threat for Miru
currently.
>> And the issue here is if you Mind
Splitter back to hand, you leave one
battlefield open for that Vex.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> So you turns off uh another Caustic if
you were to draw her. It turns off your
uh Chosen Champion as well.
So developing in the base is definitely
pretty safe here for Miru. Three to zero
right now, but it is a 10-point game,
let me remind you. And here comes Ezreal
again that we did bounce back to hand.
Sprite Fountain's going to get pitched
for two brand new cards.
>> Two.
>> Two cards in hand for Miru. And that
Pack of Wonders is a three of. There's a
chance that Brady can just draws into
another one. And then you just start
looping your Ezreals and your Fizzes as
opposed to the list.
But trying to deal with this Mind
Splitter without two lists is going to
be a much, much harder. I'm trying to
think like cuz this this type of Ezreal
list isn't really on the singularities.
It's not on like the bigger snipes. It'd
be like Deadly Flourish, Deadly
Flourish, Bellows Breath at that point,
you know, like combos like that.
Or if it goes to battlefield then like
Fizz can just swing in with some extra
damage, but we'll see what they do here.
Mind Splitter looks like
You know what? This is also a good check
for the Mind Splitter. You just play
your own.
>> I think we deck I'm interesting.
>> I kind of feel like checking the same
thing. Can I look at your trash?
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, you take the Falling Star and he
just plays the Fizz and plays the
Falling Star. You take the Fizz, he has
a Falling Star.
>> the Fizz.
>> Fizz makes sense cuz then you at least
deny the body on the board. Otherwise,
it'd be a unit and the spell as opposed
to just the spell.
>> Um
>> Bredikins is a funny guy. I like I like
listening to his uh his thoughts while
he plays.
Deciding what we're trying to do with
that Fizz here.
>> I'm going to stack deck.
>> Bredikins has scored his first point, by
the way, in game three. It's Aspirants'
Climb times two. We're going to 10
points and Bredikins at 10% of the way
there.
>> I think that
>> We're four turns away even if Miru
scores two points a turn.
So, we need eight more turns.
>> Four turn cycles. That's a normal game
of Riptide. Yeah.
That's if he's able to score twice a
turn.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay, let's see what Miru's able to do
here.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> It was a Falling Star in hand.
Something drawn for turn. The Merchant
can loop cards, especially if you have
no cards in hand, it can just be a plus
one, which feels really good. And then
the Pike Chosen Champion. So, Falling
Star is going to be the first one.
Really clean clears there.
>> Yep.
>> Very high efficiency.
So, we know there is a Oh, there's
another merchant. So now we have no
cards in hand. We're going to discard
zero, draw one.
>> Yeah.
Now the tough thing is this mind
splitter can go in and crash with the
mind splitter or it can go in and crash
with the vex, but then the mind splitter
is alive and nothing else checks
the mind splitter. So
>> be careful though. There is one rune up
for Bradykin and a card like stupify
does exist.
>> True.
>> So if you're trying to get rid of that
mind splitter, it is dangerous. If
you're trying to get rid of the vex,
yeah, you can run that mind splitter in,
right? I don't really think there's any
one rune ability that Bradykin can do to
bring that below four might.
>> Yeah.
Oh.
Counting energy.
Might have been a big draw there.
Looks like seven up seven energy up. So
you not enough to send the mind splitter
in return it to hand with the pike
legend and then replay the mind
splitter.
>> So I think we drew another merchant.
>> Okay.
>> Which isn't great in this spot, but I
mean if you develop it, you can start
cycling a lot of cards.
>> It actually is a lot of draw power
because then you do a one for turn play
that card, move a merchant, play the
card you drew at the merchant, move the
next merchant. Like it's actually kind
of draw engine at this point, which will
give you more a card advantage over
Bradykin who currently controls more
board advantage with the vex and the
mind splitter.
>> You do have to be a bit careful though
about developing this uh traveling
merchant because bellows breath does
exist. So if you kind of just leave them
all,
you know, in your base, then one
repeated bellows breath gets rid of your
three merchants.
>> And did opt to return and just not going
to play either. Okay.
Respecting the bellows breath.
But that means less units to play the
ball game.
>> Looking through our trash.
Trying to figure out exactly what the
best line is here. Looks like a fizz
maybe.
Fizz. There he is.
>> Okay. Bradykin's going to
>> dig a little deeper. Why shouldn't I
draw more cards?
>> [laughter]
>> How many cards do I have?
>> Two.
>> We know one of them. Well, Brady knows
one of them. We know both of them.
They're both traveling merchants, now.
>> On them.
>> How many cards does Bradykin have in
hand at this point? I feel like he's run
pretty low on resources. Three?
>> Oh, that's much more than three. That's
>> There is a Bella's Breath, I believe.
>> Stupe the merchant.
>> Nice. More draws, and then Bella's
Breath will just clear it with a single
cast, and then you get the legend
ability to draw cards.
>> Yep.
Trigger as legend.
Does the damage.
>> Um
>> Hm. Bradykin's back to, I believe, five
cards in hand cuz the Stupefy replaced
itself and the Bella's Breath, plus the
legend replaced the Bella's Breath.
Pack of Wonders is big. That's the third
Pack of Wonders.
>> Has to be.
>> Found it eventually. Not going to
trigger it yet. Could have returned the
Fizz and then played the Fizz.
>> So, we do have enough for Starcrossed.
Now, Starcrossing the Mind Splitter
isn't ideal. However, if it keeps your
Vex alive,
then you're just trading a card in your
hand to make sure they can't accelerate
into the into the game. And this is kind
of where you want to be. You're down by
two points. Both players are on even
points, but Bradykin's only getting 1.8
turn so far because they are just
hanging out there. And we're going to
have a Miro who tries to go somewhere
else, and I think this might be a
Starcross. Or that's what we're
debating.
>> Ooh, no, he says sure.
>> Again, being on odd points is not the
end of the world.
>> Yeah.
>> That's your Vex is still safe.
>> We're on the the world's slowest clock
because if Miro can just hold for five
turns, or, you know what, just bounce
that back, get another use of it, get
information on Bradykin's hand. He's
drawn a lot of cards since the last time
you were saw that, so
going to get some information and then
reestablish
>> I'm debating a response to the trigger.
>> Okay, trigger on the chain.
Trying to figure out what the best
course here is for
Brady.
>> Not going to use have a Star-Crossed,
has a Watcher in hand as well, Gust,
another Fizz, and
>> a Stupefy.
>> Got a Stupefy hiding in the back.
>> I believe so. Very solid hand from Brady
Ken.
>> I mean, I guess it's Thousand-Tailed
that you hit.
>> If you take the Star-Crossed, Fizz plays
the Star-Crossed. If you take the Fizz,
Star-Crossed is live. So, I think it's
definitely a Watcher.
>> Thousand-Tailed or Fizz would be the the
two I think. But, the problem is like
there's already a Fizz out there. So,
Star-Crossed is going to get that. Like,
I think you're just kind of accepting
there's going to be a lot of Fizz
Star-Crossed shenanigans happening. We
have a Pack out as well, so that Fizz is
back to your hand for free. So, I don't
know that Fizz is probably your best
play. I think it's
Stupefy. Opting to try to keep him from
drawing.
>> Also, Stupefy is a really clean check
indeed. The Mind Splitter
>> Splitter crash. So, so you had
highlighted that before. That is always
an option.
If you just make the enemy seven might a
six might, then it will not crash with
your own Mind Splitter.
>> Mhm.
>> Not the call I would have expected
though. That Thousand-Tailed is looking
like a big threat. But, I guess when you
have your own
Star-Crossed and such, it's maybe not as
scary.
>> Yeah, but at this point I feel like if
I'm Brady Ken, I can accelerate that
Watcher, take control of the other
Aspirants climb, and still have enough
to hold up a Star-Crossed.
But, I don't even need to do that. I
have the Fizz, yeah.
>> And then you can Pack of Wonders the
Fizz back. You can Fizz for the Stupefy,
get a draw.
>> You can play something. If you draw
another unit that isn't a Watcher, you
can play that to the Aspirants.
>> Two.
>> And then bounce the Fizz back to your
hand as well. Retain control of those
battlefields cuz you're on even points.
Scoring two a turn here would be three
more turns for Brady Ken to close out
here if he's able to maintain that? Pair
is the other Fizz.
>> repeat. Bellows breath.
Oh.
Okay. He's going to try to get rid of
the Mind Splitter Five damage more on
the Mind Splitter and it's gone.
Or just looking for another draw, I'm
not sure. Can still Pack of Wonders the
Fizz into
Uh, I guess the Bellows Breath again to
do two more damage. Oh, that works.
Okay, yeah, just put it back to your
hand. Sure. Yeah, I was just doing the
damage to clear the the merchant. I was
wondering if maybe there was some line
in there, but Oh, the second of Vex
Apothecary. This is wonderful for
Bradykin.
Do we bring the Mind Splitter home?
Oh, boy.
Uh, good luck Miru. For all the Pike
enthusiasts out there, he's going to
need a miracle here.
Bradykin has established or
reestablished control of the board after
the Thermo Beam. Very impressive.
Two Fizzes. So, it doesn't matter if you
take one.
Oh, this is such a good hand for
Bradykin. It's so well protected. Yeah.
Um, again, you can play the Fizz, bounce
the Mind Splitter, leave the Fizz in
play so it dodges the next Mind Splitter
being played. And then he can Pack of
Wonders later.
Wow. I Fizzed. Oh, no, I Fizzed the
Bellows. Never mind. Okay, now we're
good.
I saw three different lines at the same
time and I got confused in my head.
We're we're able to get if we Falling
Star here, we're able to get rid of one
Vex. But this is expensive.
Double Deflect Hold. So, we're only
deramping two.
The honest cost of the Falling Star. And
again, we are back to the same field of
Merchant plus Mind Splitter.
So, holding to five.
One card in hand.
Ideally, we want to get rid of this
merchant because that thing will let you
draw cards and we are
pushing Miru up against the ropes right
now. One card in hand, which I think is
another merchant.
I'm not entirely sure.
But Bradykin
in the tank here as we approach the
1-hour mark on this match.
>> I was just noting that. Um
I mean, it is a no time limit on
quarterfinals and beyond, but
approaching an hour, the fatigue sets
in. Decision-making fatigue. It's been a
long weekend. Already a long day. Five
rounds of Swiss into this top eight, and
this is not an easy head-to-head match.
A very complex decision-making trees
here for both players.
>> Looking at that StarCross putting it to
the top.
>> one there.
>> There comes Fizz.
Yes, the Bellows Breath.
Or
>> StarCross itself in the Mind Splitter.
>> Oh.
Okay. Interesting.
>> Trigger as legend from in the stoop.
>> So, Mind Splitter will get another
activation now. I wonder if Bradykin now
plays the Fizz again. There is the
Bellows.
>> Bellows, the merchant.
>> Or just play the
>> The Bellows, okay.
>> So clean.
>> It's really not how I expected to play
the game. Just play the Mind [laughter]
Splitter here?
>> Going up to six now.
>> Six.
>> I can
>> Zac deck?
>> Okay. Nice fish.
>> So, even with that Thermal Beam, just
finding that one last pack.
>> That one.
>> And able to continue get value from it.
>> Very, very good card in this deck.
Imagine if he had three. Like if that
Thermal Beam was never seen, then this
game would probably would have been over
by this point. Miru has done a great job
of fighting back into it, but it just
feels
like uh
Who's that Who's the guy pushing the the
boulder? That's Sis- Sisyphus?
No, that's not it. That doesn't sound
right. Whoever was pushing the boulder.
Going up the hill, and then it keeps
falling down. The Greek myth. Okay,
well, that's what this feels like when I
watch this. Thank you, production,
confirming it was Sisyphus.
>> Many many it's
>> Uh Mind Splitter's going to see the hand
again.
>> Now, is it the the Fizz? Yeah, I mean,
finally the Fizzes are gone. Miro has
gotten through Is that all three?
On my turn for a Fizz, says Miro.
I guess yeah, if you Fizz for the
Star-Crossed or Falling Star, then
Falling Star the Vex. Yep. Yep, that's
painful. But finally the Vex Epiphany
has been dealt with and much more
simplified board state. Still, I would
favor Brady again.
Untap the Aspirant's Climb.
>> [laughter]
>> Um I did channel already.
>> That battlefield is awake.
>> Yeah.
>> But we're into the late game now. I
mean, Brady can if you can get another
point.
>> [laughter]
>> Keep in mind though
Uh we have a watcher.
We still have a watcher. We have not
touched this watcher with four different
Mind Splitters coming into play or the
same Mind Splitter four times, I should
say.
But a very expensive turn for Miro. Now
able to use that Dark Side Butcher from
the Champion Zone to kind of speed in
there, but
>> One.
>> Bewitching Spirit?
>> Spirit.
>> Oh yeah.
The last guard is gone and it was a good
one. That's a Rengar.
The smile for Miro.
Still has the Chosen Champion Pike in a
pinch. So has at least that on the next
turn.
Star-Crossed.
>> Star-Crossed and Spirit Mind Splitter.
>> Mind Splitter cannot come out the next
turn.
So this is nice because if you do choose
to use that Pike, your chance trading
with the Mind Splitter.
>> Yeah.
Unless we top deck a Cleave or a
Blighted Battleaxe.
>> Blited Battleaxe is
really good.
>> Yeah, cuz
otherwise you don't have enough energy
for it.
Okay.
I'm going to read Gust in Brady's hand.
If you're saying let me look at your
your trash, you're trying to conquer
with a Fizz, maybe Gust it, but then if
there's good spells for you to copy.
>> It's going to bounce back to hand
anyways, right? If you let it conquer.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you want to keep your opponent on
odd points on a 10-point game. So, I
think Brady is debating gusting and he's
going to opt not to.
>> Yeah, it's a good point.
So, now Miru back on the even number of
points and Bradykin was not able to
score a second point on their turn, so
>> It'll be two turns for Brady to win.
>> That's probably why he didn't mind.
That's probably why he didn't mind.
>> Uh we do have a deadly flourish in the
hand, but I think we're going to star
cross the fizz.
>> Which means a mind
>> Splitter's going to come down for Brady
next turn and take a peek at the one
remaining card in hand for Miru, if I
had to guess.
>> And it also de-ramped.
Uh
>> A ton.
>> did did Miru recycle the star cross?
Yeah, there we go.
>> Yeah, there we go.
>> Draw.
>> We do have the watcher. What an
interesting match up, man. This is
This is something. Oh, we could just
Spirit Pack spirit.
>> Spirit?
>> Yeah.
There are three cards in hands.
>> Yeah, and I don't think that mind
splitter's coming out anytime soon.
>> Hard hard again.
>> Pass. Again, this Dockside Butcher can
get us a point.
>> Yeah.
It's not going to do much. Getting one
point's not great. I think
Like a I know it's expensive, but even
like a falling star here would feel
good. Just
>> get one from here.
>> Oh, and he calls it. Bradykin taking it
two to one.
>> Good luck in the rest of it.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Great.
Great play for both players. Victory to
Bradykin.
And yeah, I mean Miru said it. Good luck
in the rest of the games.
>> down as this deck on double aspirants
before.
That was That was a truly unique play
pattern that I was coming up with in
real time.
>> [laughter]
>> And I think I'm going to be very
disappointed with myself when I watch
this match back. I don't think I played
it very well.
>> [laughter]
>> I I just hoping to draw something. I had
such a rough hand.
>> Yeah, I mean I I think realistically
there was significant draw luck
throughout the entire match.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, if you got the thermobeam a little
earlier for Miru, maybe that would have
been the difference maker, but Bradykin
did get like two big turns with like the
double packs into the and into the list
and stuff like that. So, I mean we saw
Miru was digging for that thermobeam the
entire time, finally saw one, then saw
the second one when it wasn't really
going to be useful anymore, but he hung
in there for quite a while.
>> Yeah, that last game felt like it took a
long time to get going.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we had a crazy middle game.
>> Mhm.
>> And even after that thermobeam came out,
like Bradykin was saying, he was trying
to figure out a strategy in real time.
>> How do I beat beat down in double
Aspirins as control Ezreal? I don't
think many players have been in that
position, but that's why I love decks
like Ezreal and I love watching people
play it at the top level cuz it kind of
feels like jazz, you know, you never
know what the board state's going to be
and you got to figure out the puzzle in
real time, like you said, and find the
way in for the victory. And he was able
to do it, so well done.
>> I'm curious to see how Bradykin would do
on one of your puzzles.
>> Oh, I he would probably smash it. I mean
I'm not going to lie. Again, did you see
Prismat how quickly he solved my
puzzles?
>> Yeah.
>> He was speed running it.
>> I mean again, it took me quite a while
to come up with some of those ones. My
roommate can attest, he saw me in the
kitchen just like staring at a table for
about an hour
and then Prismat shows up, he's like,
"Oh, it's just this." I'm like, "Yeah,
okay." But yeah,
uh solving puzzles is part of a card
game. So, I think that was a very
intricate puzzle into the Pike matchup,
very funny interactions, all these
things bouncing back to the hand from
the Star Cross on both sides and a lot
of hand ripping as well, but at the end
of the day, Ezreal control, really
strong deck and your boy from Montreal,
how many skirmishes was it that he's
won?
>> Six.
>> Six skirmishes.
>> Two per set at the same store.
>> Very, very impressive. Good track
record. Now top eight, now top four here
in Hartford.
>> I don't think we've done the last one
for Oh, no, we we must have done the
last six. Yeah, we just did the last one
for Unleashed, yeah.
>> All right. Well, there we go. He's right
now he's in top four. The titles, yeah.
>> Do you think he could do it? Think he
can go all the way?
I don't want to jinx it. I don't want to
jinx it. We have another Well, this is
cool.
This is one of our top eight games that
are currently in progress here. Uh it
looks like it's uh Factor versus
Um who's Factor playing against?
>> Uh I'm not recognizing it right now.
>> It's a Diana uh I think it's Evan versus
a Diana.
>> Arhem.
>> Evan Arhem, okay.
>> Uh currently 1-1. And we have, you know,
It looks like we're deep in the tank
both players. I can't call it right now.
It's from here.
>> Yeah, I was going to say this would be a
challenge, but it is cool to see them.
Right now body language-wise, I would
say Factor. Okay, no no no, he's he's he
made a sigh. Oh, I was going to say he
looked better body language-wise, but
now
not so sure.
>> Here and ole ole's from the crowd.
Montreal chants.
>> okay.
>> We also have Prismat.
>> On our feature match
uh backup stream, we have Prismat.
And we're going to be hopping in and
taking a look at that in a moment here,
but for now uh we're just checking out
the venue. All the top eight matches
very very close. And again, it's kind of
Prismat versus a lot of players that are
hungry to prove themselves, hungry to
add their names to the history books
here as a regional qualifier winner.
>> Yeah, and Bishwhite's the Diana.
It's going to be a fun match. That is
probably a very fun match to not only
watch play, but probably also judge.
>> Yeah, oh yeah? [laughter] You you you
miss it now there? You want to hop out?
>> No no, I'm having a blast here.
>> Okay, yeah. I'm having fun with you.
>> You're a good guy.
>> We might have had our differences
earlier in the weekend, you know, but
once I beat you in a best of three, I
felt a lot better. So, uh
>> Speaking of people beating each other,
>> Yes.
>> let's take a look at the bracket.
>> The people that actually matter here,
Brady Ken advancing on to the
semi-finals. And uh it looks like we do
have Alinsanity advancing to the
semi-finals as well.
>> Ending
>> in top eight.
>> Lux not quite getting it and it was a
2-0. So, Diana proving that it can take
down the limitless Lux, proving that
sometimes there are in fact limits.
>> There are limits to everything. And
Relivia,
really good showing. Obviously, securing
themselves the best of luck, securing
themselves a top eight finish here at
Hartford.
>> But, this top eight is very rough for
Lux. I think the only the only one you
want to see is Ezreal.
>> And I think a big part of it, we did see
Linsanity on feature match at the end of
day one uh playing the Baron. It's one
of those ways where if you can find ways
to cheat points against the Lux, it
really helps you out. So, I I'm curious.
I don't know, but I would I would
imagine that that did come up at some
point. It was like, "Oh yeah, you just
scored an extra point or two if you're
able to hold as well." But, I'm hearing
that we have an interview ready with
Brady Ken. So, let's throw it over to
that to hear from the winner of our top
eight feature match.
>> Not just our winner, but our Swiss champ
coming out of the all those rounds.
Brady Ken,
how do you feel right now? Not just
being in top eight as the only Ezreal,
but being the only now top four Ezreal
moving forward after that rigorous match
up there.
>> Um I I feel like I'm supposed to say
something else, but the answer is
overwhelmed.
Um I did not come into this tournament
with anywhere near the expectation of
getting here. The goal was day two.
Um this has been amazing and exhausting
and gratifying and many other adjectives
I can't form right now.
>> I want you to know that we started the
day with a graphic. And what maybe while
I vamp for this, maybe we'll pull it up
for us. Do you happen to maybe know the
win percentage of Ezreal into Diana
right now across this weekend?
>> I'd guess in the 70% range.
>> 84% win rate when we touched on it this
morning. And I've got to ask you, that
must be why you're having so much
success on this deck right now because
Diana to me is everywhere. A heavy
favorite. Look at the top eight bracket
right now. There's three of them across
this entire time. But, you're just
you're Wait, you're playing out of your
mind. I have I've I've watched you now
across three matches, one of which
being, you know, your draw that you had
in Swiss, of course we saw you. We even
had you actually picked for a feature
match earlier during the weekend,
remember? But we didn't show that
footage, but you've been playing so well
with this this like control-oriented
play style. And when you saw double
Aspirants Climb come out, that's got to
feel good, right? You already have the
decklist info. Here's that graphic if
you want to see it.
>> Oh, wow. Yeah.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, I mean, you've been
playing this deck for a long time now,
as from what I've been told.
>> Yeah, so I started playing it right
after the end of the spoiler season for
Spirit Forge. I did a big period of like
doing online testing there, and I've
played Azirel basically non-stop since.
>> And it's it's showing. It very much is.
Again, Swiss champ, you were first seed
coming into all of this. There's
potentially a world where you have to go
against more Dianas on your way there. I
I would imagine that's what you're
looking to go
>> Oh, yeah, no, that's what I was hoping
to see in in the pairings here. Um it is
definitely my best match-up of the
remaining decks.
>> Yeah, and you've now also got a best-of,
so congratulations on that.
>> very much.
>> So, I mean, as my last question for you
as I, you know, you must prepare for
your top four game that you must get
ready for. Um you've got a lot of fans
here cheering for you. Gritten has been
uh luckily telling us all about you back
at home. This is even your Swiss run as
well. Um of course that draw against
Mom's spaghetti, and then at the end of
course against Factor you were able to.
But I've noticed, you know, you didn't
finally run into those Dianas until the
end, two of which are the two that are
in top cut.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you think you have what it takes to
take down the whole thing?
>> I think it's possible. It depends on the
match-ups. I'm not familiar with what's
been going on in the other three
match-ups. There is a terrifying
match-up in this bracket, and I think
everyone knows what it is. In case for
the record, it is the Lux. Um not to
sugarcoat it, if I face it, I lose.
Um so there's a little bit of lottery
there. I have no idea how the bracket is
structured. I don't know who's won or
lost or what games are still going.
Against all the other decks in the
bracket, I think it's possible. I mean,
facing someone like Prismat's Annie is
terrifying.
Facing Master Yi is a daunting match-up
with this deck. The Dianas, they're all
great players, but the match-up just
doesn't work very well for them. So, my
hope certainly is that I can play
against them, and then I think I have a
shot.
>> And the hope is what we want right now
because again, you're playing so well,
Bradykin. Congratulations on that top
eight win. You've got a little bit of a
break before you get into your top four.
And speaking of, we want to see some
more action in this top eight. So, we're
going to send it back.
>> What a character. I love that interview.
He was fun on the table during the
match. He was fun talking. He's like, I
think there's a lot of adjectives that
come to mind, but uh I can't say all of
them, but uh you got a few [laughter]
out. That was good.
>> Yeah, he got a few out. I mean, that's
just how he is. His personality is the
same on the desk as it is on the on in
the match as it is when you're just
talking to him in the hall, right? So,
super happy for Bradykin. Hopefully, he
can continue that run into the finals,
perhaps. And he doesn't know, but we
know the Lux is gone.
>> It's gone.
>> But he did also mention Prismatism would
be terrifying. I mean, I think I feel
like a lot of these players would
probably agree. Like, Prismat is kind of
the boss of the top eight right now.
He's the only one that's won a regional
qualifier in the top eight so far,
and would be looking for another title.
But if anybody else able to take it,
we'd have a new first-timer.
>> Yeah, and luckily, Bradykin is at the
top of that bracket, right? Being in the
top seed. So, he's going to play the
winner of Factor and
uh Adventurer, I believe. So, if Factor
does lose this to the Diana, that's a
really good match-up for Bradykin,
right? And if Beischwitz, who is our
other top eight our back-up feature
match that we had playing against
Prismat, if he manages to win out
against Prismat, the only big bad that's
left really for Bradykin is that Master
Yi. If he manages to win in his top
eight.
>> Yeah, otherwise, it's a lot of Dianas
still swimming in the pond.
>> favorable for Azrael.
>> Very favorable. 86% win rate we saw on
>> That's a lot of percent.
>> That's a lot of percent. It's a lot of
percent.
Um but I hope that we're able to hop in
cuz I know that we're going to be taking
a look at Prismat's uh match and what's
going on there uh here shortly. So, we
can actually get a look at that. But,
here's that match up.
Very close. Almost a coin flip. 54 to 46
for the Diana into the Annie, or rather
Annie into the Diana.
>> And this is interesting because in
Riftbound, obviously,
almost every single deck wants to go
first, right? So, I wonder of this
matrix, how much of it is did I win
because I went first?
>> Sure. Yeah, and
even more so than things like the Ezreal
list, which was even having like a
two-drop unit. Annie and Diana
definitely
utilize those more often.
So, yeah, we'll have to see.
Although, that can come down to skill
expression as well. Here's Bee
Bee Swarm's
list for it Diana. Pretty standard
overall. Is running the one Eclipse,
and no smoke screen, actually. That's
kind of like the one thing that I've
noticed in Diana lists is how many
Eclipse or smoke screen ratios are you
running?
>> Also, notably, this is the list that
does run the one does run the one of
Rebukes, excuse me. I should mention.
>> Yes, we did notice that, as well. One of
Rebuke can really mess with a lot of
people. Cannot be defied, so it's good
against the Master Yis in the in the
list. So, Bee Swarm matches up against
MSG at any point can come up. But, also,
just a lot of people just don't expect
it anymore. One of Kazix, as well.
Always like to highlight that. And only
two of the Hweis, but is running the
Sprite Fountains. So, we've seen some
Diana lists that don't run the gears
with Hwei, and they're just you're
looking to discard spells and units, but
Bee Swarm does have all of the options
available.
>> A very diverse and sort of adaptable
deck here with the Diana. And again, the
Sprite Fountain, like we saw Brady can
doing, can be used to get you some
points. Or, you can just pitch it to get
those runes ready with that
Hwei. Moving on to Prismat, though.
Prismat running that one main deck of
Bandle, which if he does face our
control Ezreal, that's going to come
into play. That one main deck Hard
Bargain, as well. So, before I said,
"I'm not sure how much counter spells
that Prismat is running."
At least two.
>> At least two. And this is a very
different list than what we would
typically see from an Annie. There's no
ride the winds in the main deck. There's
three flashes. So, you typically you
think of like the Annie legend, you
ready two runes at the end of your turn,
uh you think, "Oh, yeah. Oh, the the two
energy spells are going to be really
valuable." Well, this build there's
actually a lot of three energies.
There's the Grimapaws Carry, there's the
Rengar, there's the Star Cross. So,
that's actually what uh a lot of times
Prismaticism is going to look for. So,
you always need to make sure you leave
one up so that when you're ready the
two, you have three to activate on your
opponent's turn as opposed to
traditional Annies which would only
looking for the two.
>> And let's find out who's going to be
advancing from this second feature match
as we jump into the game here between
Bee Swarm and Prismaticism as they fight
for their top four spot.
>> All right. Winner continues on to the
semi-finals.
Loser will be heading home. And
reminder, Diana Best of is still on the
line here. So, we're into game three. It
looks like it was a game one win for
Prismat, game two win for Bee Swarm, and
now game three
uh going first for Prismaticism. Just
based on what the Arena's Greatest are.
Typically, you can kind of decipher from
that. But, here we go. Game three. Let's
see what happens.
>> All right. Do we have that early two
drop here for Prismat on the Arena's
game?
Uh no, we do not.
>> That's uh yeah, only eight in the deck.
It can happen that you uh aren't able to
see it. I typically like the nine. I
know most pros say, "Nah, eight's
enough." But, then this can happen
sometimes.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Well, let's see what else
Prismaticism is able to do though.
>> It all depends how you play from here
now. Obviously, being able to develop
that Diana uh on our first turn if we're
Bee Swarm here, three runes, and then
passing it back over to Prismat uh could
be a good way to get point tempo stolen
away from the player who goes first.
But, you know, Prismat having one more
rune, are we going to use another Stack
Deck perhaps? No, we're just going to un
uh we're just going to ready our rune
that we used. Three runes being
channeled here for Bee Swarm as he draws
his first card of the game, and Diana's
going to hit the board like most Dianas
do.
>> It's such a strong deck going second
because of Diana Lunari.
>> Always have just an ideal
setup here.
>> Prismatism now draws the two drop with
the merchant into the Noxus hopeful
readying two runes.
>> Yeah, with the
uh
two runes up, right? This is now a
little bit dangerous for Diana.
Obviously, moving to the abandoned halls
probably your best course of action if
I'm Beischwicht here because
that Noxus hopeful is just four
currently.
You're able to kind of fight over that
abandoned hall, but Prismat also has
some spells in his deck that will allow
him to push the might up on that
battlefield as well.
>> Or even gears, like the long swords. We
saw three of them there. I know Prismat
recently tweeted out that like, yeah,
long swords just kind of worse spinning
axe and Annie, but it's still basically
spinning axe and Annie.
>> Correct, yeah.
>> So, it's still really good card. Three
of them feels great. Diana's not going
to move into the battlefield. Instead,
Beischwicht will just develop more of
the board with the Ravenbloom student
and the traveling merchant on his side.
>> Again, an arena's game where we're just,
you know, taking time to develop a
little
>> Yeah.
>> little unique, so to speak.
>> What's the rush?
>> Yeah, we're here to have a good time.
>> I imagine Prismatism could send the
merchant in just to cycle a card, get
that even number of points, and then
save the Noxus hopeful.
>> Oh, early Annie.
>> Yeah, very early Annie. So, digging for
something, you have to imagine.
>> Hopeful.
>> All right.
>> pass.
>> Cuz that's a lot of might.
>> All right.
Saving resources, playing the game of
chicken. Prismat loves this type of
game. Anytime I cast a Prismat game, I'm
a
When I predict what he's going to do,
I'm right about 10% of the time. Just
because of how patient he is and how
controlled he likes to play Rift Bound.
>> Yeah.
Just Prismat's very notorious for just
creating a bunch of, you know, might in
the back line and then saying,
"I have all this stuff that you have to
deal with, and then I will engage on my
terms."
>> It's Again, I've referenced this a few
times now, but it's the difference of do
you try and complicate the board state
or simplify the board state? I'm almost
always a fan of simplify, but Prismatism
loves complex board states. I think
that's why his hair is as curly as it
is.
>> [laughter]
>> Cuz he's just always twirling it
thinking about all these different
lines. Now there's some action coming
through here from Bishwitz.
>> Yeah, that resolves.
>> We're resolving the Diana trigger.
Looks like a Ravenbloom on the top, so
that's going to go to the bottom. Let's
see if there's a spell, and it's a gust.
>> Yes.
Conqueror to two.
>> We go to two.
>> Conqueror's good.
>> See if Bishwitz wants to develop
[snorts] more.
Vex. Sympathetic. That's a pretty good
development.
>> Go.
>> And three still up.
We know he has a gust in hand. We just
saw it from the Diana Lunari trigger.
Still 10 might, sorry, 13 might. I
forgot Annie's in play. 13 might
available for some uh combat on the side
of Prismatism.
>> And notably the Noxious Hopefuls cannot
be gusted.
>> So it'd have to be like a stupefy plus a
gust combination.
And there it is. Prismat's signature.
Hands through the hair as he starts to
think. Yeah, here we go.
He's got to watch it. He's going to end
up like us.
>> Yeah.
We got to do a
you know,
we got to have a talk with him.
>> Yeah, I'll talk to him after this.
>> Okay, cool.
>> We do have a Rengar in hand as well,
notably.
Cuz we're still hearing the oh a's back
in the background there. Now the Noxious
Hopeful is going in. Bishwitz.
Not doing the Diana trigger, trigger,
excuse me.
>> Attack and defend trigger's what
happened before an action window. So
Prismatism passes. Bishwitz has the
action window.
One energy spent. I'm guessing a
stupefy. Yep, there it is. Stupefy and
then gust can now return this Noxious
Hopeful back to hand.
>> The Rengar can come off the top as well
though.
>> Yes.
>> I'll pump my Vex.
>> Vex at five.
>> Vex will go to six if this gust goes out
and then Rengar would not be enough to
clear the Vex and also would be stunned
anyway.
>> Oh, very true. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> I always forget about the
>> Right. It's kind of funny. All right,
just trade with the Diana.
>> No gust from Bee Shwaits. Okay.
>> Send hopeful.
Play stack deck with my action.
>> Now we're going to go five to five.
Yeah.
Do we have anything that we can play? We
obviously can't gust. There's no legal
targets for it.
>> Yep.
This is a very efficient clear for
Prismatism.
>> Knocks his hopeful. I think part of the
reason it's one of the top five most
represented cards in the entire
tournament is because of Vex Apathetic
and how cleanly this answers Vex.
>> Another Origin staple.
>> Yeah.
>> Plus one on hopeful.
>> Mhm.
>> Um I'll pass for this.
>> Looks like we're trading.
Unless Prismat has something else up his
sleeve.
>> Could play the Rengar. It's stunned but
you could still conquer.
And then get the point but not really
necessary.
Prismat really likes that Rengar
defensively.
>> Five cards in hand for Bee Shwaits.
Prismat thinking through the lines. I
believe six cards in hand if I see that
correct.
>> Yes.
>> I like counting their cards when they're
hand shuffling.
>> That is actually how I do it as well.
>> I audibly count their cards.
>> Yep. Mhm.
>> It's a very tactile way to do it.
>> Yep.
>> We're trading. We are currently trading,
yeah. I'm trading.
>> [laughter]
>> All right.
All right, bet.
Trade complete.
Prismatism did in fact take that trade
deal. Again, could move the merchant
into a go to even points, but if I know
Prismat, I'm actually going to guess
he's not going to do it.
>> All right, so you're usually right 10%
of the time here. Let's see if that
checks out.
>> So, this is again where I would want to
move it in, but because I would want to,
I'm going to assume he's not going to.
So, I'm betting on the 90% right now.
>> Okay.
Sunday arena?
>> It was Annie that won it.
>> Yeah. Go to two.
Pay three. Grim Apothecary, put it back
in my hand.
>> That makes a lot of sense. Very
effective play. Saving the Annie,
getting to the even number of points,
and I imagine it's just a pass at this
moment, unless you want to try and
redevelop another unit.
>> Inferno?
>> Inferno makes sense.
>> fine.
>> Ready to ruins and pass.
>> Three up for a star crossed, three up
for the Rengar, three up for another
Grim Apothecary.
Um, not that you'd be able to play the
Grim Apothecary from hand at reaction
speed. Uh, you don't have a battlefield,
but still a lot of options for
Prismatism, yeah.
>> And playing the Rengar, we've seen
Prismat do it in many top cuts, where
he'll play that Rengar in response to a
trigger. Just into the base, right?
Which kind of throws off your math of
what you were trying to do. He'll wait
until your last action of the turn, and
then go, "Oh, by the way, I had this
extra card that you know, forgot to
account Well, not forgot, but couldn't
account for all the entire turn, and now
you have to deal with that on the
following."
>> It's one of the things Annie can do very
uniquely.
Annie Huwei has now hit the board, one
of the strongest units in the Diana
list.
>> Development turn here as well for
Beishuoites, it looks like.
>> Not going to commit any units. Could
have gone for four points, but
Beishuoites is playing the
uh the long con here. Going to try and
look to trade with Prismatism, and
again, the game of chicken continues.
Two very patient players.
The sigh from Prismata.
>> Four in hand?
>> Yep.
>> So we know there is an Annie.
An Annie can get the stack deck, so we
can play the same stack deck for the
third time if we really want to.
>> Notably not Fizz.
>> Notably not Fizz, so it doesn't cycle,
it just adds a spell back to hand and
you can replay it.
>> Yeah, the Rengar in hand is
uh
Again, he didn't do it on the last turn,
it wasn't given a reaction window, so
I'm not sure if he would have wanted to,
um but it's still hidden information in
hand. Now Prismata says in things, will
I send a unit in?
Cuz again, somebody's got to be the beat
down eventually.
>> Yeah, and gusting the merchant isn't
terrible here. I probably Out of the
three here, it's the one you want to
gust.
>> Sure, yeah, it doesn't have ambush.
>> Yeah, it doesn't have ambush and it
doesn't you know, it's not it's not that
scary on attack, right?
>> Discard a Rengar.
>> Rengar hits the graveyard.
>> the graveyard, okay.
>> I think that might have answered my
conundrum.
>> Conquer is good.
>> Conquer is good, going to three.
Now, if you're going to send one of
these units for another point and sack
it, it's probably the inferno.
>> Yeah.
Unless I If you send the apothecary, you
kind of force Bishwadj to use a card.
>> Use something, but again, the inferno is
just a lower value card overall.
>> And oh, wow.
>> Proactively flashing.
>> When he moves.
>> Trigger again, this is nice.
>> Have you got
>> Sitting on her discard.
>> Have you got a look at the hand for
Prismata here?
>> Not really. I know there's a forerunner
in hand. Oh, Annie getting discarded,
interesting. I did see a forerunner
previously.
Obviously the Inferno Grenade There it
is.
>> Okay.
>> And the Inferno Grenade Apothecary got
played as well, which were the hand
cards that I knew in hand. So now
Prismata's hand is a mystery to me as
well.
>> Well, pass turn and ready to runes.
That's back to three, which could be a
Rengar, could be a Starcrossed. Speaking
of Starcrossed, that's probably what
Beischwitz is going to be looking for.
It's kind of the classic out to the
Forerunner.
Really, really good answer.
>> 10 runes looks like for Beischwitz.
>> With four cards in hand, I believe, and
four units on the board. Merchant and
Huwei can represent even more draws.
>> Yeah, Beischwitz not on Baron in his
list, notably.
>> Mhm.
Move trigger is good.
>> Moving to Abandoned Hall, Huwei will
draw and then discard.
Probably looking for a spell, a
low-value spell here just to draw an
additional card.
>> Okay.
>> This one makes sense.
>> Conqueror is good.
Conqueror to three.
>> Very back and forth here. Both players
timid to move into the battlefield,
right? Prismata?
>> Conqueror to four.
>> As Prismata does, wants to get in there
and get back out.
>> So funny how they you really conserve
resources until about the mid game, and
then they're like, "Okay, now I'll send
my stuff in."
>> This is Oh my. This is terrifying.
>> Yeah, looks 10.
>> So two Raven Bloom students and the
Huwei is at the Abandoned Hall. So
anytime a spell is played by Beischwitz,
all of these units are going to get
pumped.
All runes up as well. So Beischwitz is
saying, "Bet. Come in. Try and clear me
off of one of these."
>> I'm looking at the list for Beischwitz,
and I don't know that I see any sort of
interaction in terms of counters.
It's mainly just stuff like Stupefy,
Eclipse, the Rebukes, the Moonfalls. Oh,
there There is two Hard Bargains, excuse
me.
>> Okay, there we go.
It would have surprised me if
>> Yeah, I was kind of surprised.
>> All right, there's 10 runes available
for Prismatistism.
>> Six.
>> Okay.
>> Six cards in hand, 10 runes available.
>> And we got Prismat
>> in the tank.
As is known when he puts his hands in
his hair.
>> That's his uh his mind palace.
>> Yes, his mind palace.
>> like Sherlock Holmes going in there.
Never know what he's uh what he's
thinking about.
Now we know that just on board the
Ferrous Warlord is the biggest threat
for Prismatistism.
Sending that in, trying to clear
something, even if it dies, it'll make
more mech tokens. You can overload a
bunch of things on a one battlefield and
just try and force your way through.
Uh and then you're still winning the
clock, you'll go to five and the Beast
Whites would hold for five. Um clearing
both of these is going to be a much
harder issue. With all these runes up, I
mean Annie can do it, but you have to
have the right sequence of cards.
There's a Flash in hand, I'm trying to
see
>> Hard Bargain. Rengar, Hard Bargain.
So actually I mean if there is a Rengar
that is a better uh tool to punch with
for Annie, one of the premier ones, and
Hard Bargain can come up clutch here.
Although there's just so many runes
available for Beast Whites that even
through Hard Bargain like a Star Cross,
they will have enough uh runes to pay
the energy costs.
>> A really long decision here for Prismat,
trying to figure out the optimal line. A
lot of these pro players, right, they'll
take a lot of time at the beginning and
then will chain actions back to back cuz
they've kind of mapped out their line.
>> Yeah.
>> As long as you know, some new
information doesn't get introduced along
the way.
>> Counting up the runes again, taking a
sip of water. Oh, Prismat is really in
the tank right now. The uh judge
nudging Prismat along to take a game
action.
>> Yep.
>> There is no time limit, but again, a
reasonable pace of play is expected for
both these players, and Prismat has not
made a decision in over a minute.
>> Yeah. Is he
>> counted his runes three times now.
>> It's okay, I do that, too. Consistently.
[laughter]
>> How many you want? Okay, yeah. But to
put Is it Is it really?
>> Looks like we're getting ready to move
the Forerunner. Maybe time to go duel
this um play.
>> This is what I call let the fireworks go
off. Both players have full runes up,
and one controls the battlefield, the
other's got a big army. Someone's got to
go down. Let's see the fireworks fly.
And there it is. Going to fight the
Ravenbloom students.
>> Arguably the scarier one to go into
because every spell will pump twice as
opposed to once, but not going to lose.
>> trigger merchant.
>> Eight might will attack in. Merchant
will trigger discarding another merchant
to draw, and now it's eight might onto
four might.
>> Pass merchant.
Two spells from Bee Swarm's will make
this a trade.
>> If one of them's a stupify, then it's a
really good uh trade up.
>> A star cross to bounce the merchant back
to hand or uh sorry, to bounce the
Forerunner back to hand would just
completely uh lock it in here. Prismat
can repeat a hard bargain, but
even if we do that, we have seven runes
available after we use that star cross
with Bee Swarm, so Eclipse
>> out. That's pretty good, too.
>> Using the Diana legend as well, so still
eight runes ready for Bee Swarm.
>> Minus four might means it's now four
might attacking six might. The spell
will resolve, so those Ravenbloom
students both get one might a piece. Six
defending, four attacking.
>> I'll pass.
I think it's pretty obvious.
>> Predict trigger, yeah.
>> Top that.
>> He's going to leave it on top.
>> I pass.
>> Focus is passed back to Beischwitz now.
It is currently six
to four.
We will get two max if this combat
finishes. Going to stack deck as well.
>> Stack deck's good.
>> Okay, that'll give
>> Maybe trying to get both students out of
lethal range.
>> Yeah.
If you play one more spell then neither
will go down.
>> Thank you for updating the dice.
>> Prismat helping his opponent with his
triggers. There's good sportsmanship.
Beischwitz was
>> just saying thank you for helping with
him. So, sportsmanship on both sides.
>> Yeah, one more spell from Beischwitz. He
is just going to look to hold here.
>> Hold gust here, forerunner.
>> Oh.
>> I like this.
>> with against the odds.
>> Oh, very nice.
>> Fancy. That'll turn the forerunner back
up to six might.
>> This is on the chain.
>> It's on the chain.
>> Plus two per unit at that enemy unit at
that battlefield. So, plus four
currently on the chain targeting that
forerunner.
>> This would move it out of a gust range
>> again. So, gust will not work. And then
it's back to eight might attacking, but
it will still be 10 might defending now
because these
students just keep getting pumped more
and more.
>> Currently.
>> And notably, the gust doesn't get
countered. It just resolves to no
effect.
>> Yes.
>> So, we will be pumping up our students.
We will be pumping up the abandoned hall
with way.
So, it is still a trade where we're only
able to really kill one of these
students.
>> Mhm, okay.
>> Six turns ready for Beischwitz. I think
Prismat is doing the math here of like
you know, star-crossed could be double
hard bargained, but if Prismat is also
running out of power right now, or
rather energy.
Again, eight attacking 10.
A long sword would make this a honest
crash, but then Beischwitz just needs to
play one more spell and suddenly these
rain blooms get pumped again. This is
why I was thinking it's scary to attack
these two.
>> Yeah.
>> Double the value off of each spell.
Cuz not
There's the Rengar. So, now we're above,
right? With that Rengar has the assault
as well. So, five more, that's 13
attacking, 10 defending. So, a spell
would not be enough. Be Shwetz would
need to play two spells now.
Unless one of those is a star cross.
Prismat does have a flash as well.
>> Good point.
>> So, just in case things turn south for
Prismatism here, he's able to flash back
those units.
>> Stupefy a Rengar.
>> Stupefy will swing this back to being
even now.
>> Yeah. So, Stupefy is a delta of three on
the overall math.
>> This is crazy. You were right. This is
where the fireworks are going to pop
off.
>> We are going to see some fireworks and
this is again why it's scary to attack
the double Ravenbloom as opposed to the
Huwei.
>> Focus getting past the Be Shwetz now.
Prismatism says, "Hey, I'm okay with
this trade cuz I'm going to make two
Mechs."
>> Yeah.
>> It's worth it.
>> Ravenbloom is such a high value unit in
these types of lists. My goodness. A two
energy that's now a six might. And we're
trading.
>> I've got two Mechs.
>> That Huwei, meanwhile, is now nine might
on the other battlefield. So,
which still they're six might attacking.
If there's another Rengar, maybe there's
a world Prismatism can clear that one,
too.
And that's might maybe what Be Shwetz is
thinking about.
>> Yeah.
>> Saying, "Hey, I don't want to invest too
too much to save these students because
that Huwei is really is going to let me
claw back into this game."
>> The Huwei is more valuable, I would
argue.
>> Yeah, three cards used, if I'm not
mistaken, for Be Shwetz. He had six
cards in hand, one of those being a
Stupefy, drawing back up to
four cards.
So, I think I see a Grimoire Apothecary,
a flash,
maybe a merchant
in hand.
>> I feel like if if I know Prismatist, he
maybe just passes here.
>> Yeah, there's not really a big point on
throwing away a unit to go to five.
>> Yeah.
>> Especially one that has assault and
inferno.
>> But you do have the flash to save it, so
okay, he will go
>> That's correct, yeah.
>> But then you have to commit that flash
to save it.
>> Mhm.
Letting the conquer go.
>> to five.
>> Go.
>> Yep, passes ready. Seven runes up, I
don't know how valuable they're going to
be for Prismatist. And Bee Whites in a
really good spot right now.
Will hold for a fifth point, can look to
go take that Grim Apothecary for a
sixth, is on the even numbers, one turn
away from winning if he can conquer the
arena's greatest. And Wei will help you
get there.
Gets the extra draws, can make himself
quite large. You're looking for
something like a ride the wind at that
point cuz it currently the Yep, merchant
is not enough, so there's a stack deck.
>> Now we have a moonfall, that works too.
That works too.
And it brings him into the abandoned
hall, but again, we know Prismatist has
that flash. So if we do have a ride the
wind, we can actually go over with ride
the wind, try to bait out that flash,
and then pull it back in afterwards.
>> Sure.
>> You could also move the merchant into
the arena's greatest and then moonfall
in the inferno. And then trade cuz I
believe then with the minus two to all
units there, it'd be a two one my units
on your two my unit, so
>> Mhm.
>> If you're just trying to like clear the
board, that's another option for Bee
Whites. You got a lot of angles here.
The Wei will move though.
>> Discard.
>> Gets the draw, discards acceptable
losses to draw an extra card.
>> So it looks like 11 runes available now
for Bee Whites. Prismatist, like we
mentioned earlier, seven runes up. We
know there's a flash in hand. I'm 87%
sure there's a Grim Apothecary in hand.
And then there's a third mystery card,
which
if I had to guess, I think is a
merchant.
Here comes the merchant on the side of
Be Shwaits though.
Going to go fight this Grim Apothecary
perhaps.
>> Feeling the pressure to score this
point. Going to try and go in.
Move trigger will discard and draw.
See what Be Shwaits wants to discard. As
you can see at the bottom of your
screen, currently Be Shwaits not winning
this combat.
>> Ooh, Vex getting discarded is
interesting. Pretty good card.
Moonfall.
Like you mentioned. So you're going to
pull on the inferno. Moonfall is going
to attempt to just have a clean trade.
>> Resolves.
>> This is a going to be a flash here from
Prismatism.
>> Most likely.
>> Yep. O3 though. This looks like a Grim
Apothecary.
Yep. Saving the inferno.
>> Yep.
>> This now makes it four to two.
>> Sure.
>> That resolves.
>> So now Be Shwaits has more than one.
>> And the ride the wind. But again, the
flash hasn't been baited out yet, so
going to be able to keep these Grim
Apothecary safe. Though Hue will be
ready.
So if we we see that flash come out, we
can kind of bring Hue home.
>> flash on both of my Grims.
>> Okay.
And now a repeated hard bargain would go
absolutely crazy here.
>> Yeah, doing it preemptively. I guess
Prismatism is saying if I'm going to do
it, I'm going to do it now and prevent
Be Shwaits from
drawing into a hard bargain.
>> Give one option.
>> He has it. He's got it. Double hard
bargain.
Flash is canceled.
>> Okay.
>> Prismatism
has one inferno in hand and I don't know
what the other one is, but I don't think
it's going to be enough with two runes
up. This is a huge swing for Be Shwaits.
>> Yeah, this might be the turning point of
the game here for Be Shwaits if he's
able to maintain that point tempo and
again, more importantly, if this
showdown resolves in in favor, keep
himself on even points, which means he
just need one more to win.
>> Yeah.
>> So, four not enough to kill the way
either. Debating if he wanted to pitch a
unit, right? So, he can actually go look
for another card instead because
>> Discard Sprite Fountain and Ready to
Rumble.
>> There it is. We see it happen.
Way is five. Merchants two. A longsword
would be big here.
>> Play Inferno.
>> Or the Inferna.
So, we did, I believe, miss
our trigger earlier where we stack
decked when the way was at the Abandon
Hall. Way should be six, but it looks
like we might have missed that trigger.
>> Sorry, I should have self to five,
right?
>> Yeah, you're at five.
>> That's a good point. Yeah. Cuz that was
before he moved. Well, or did he move
first? I'm trying to think now the
order. I thought he stack decked and
then moved, but I could be wrong. But,
it doesn't matter. We have another way.
Oh, look at that.
>> in hand now?
>> There's no way. He scores the point. No
way. No way. He's got another one.
>> a way there.
>> There is one way.
>> Yeah, way.
>> Yeah, way, baby.
>> All right. Prismacism, can you make
magic happen? Still has the mech tokens.
Will score two points. Goes to seven.
Has to hold one to win.
>> Yeah.
>> All runes up. Two cards in hand. We've
seen Prismacism come back and hold in
positions just like this in top eights
before.
>> We have a Tide Turner though, notably.
Um, if there's any other way for us to
move around.
I don't know if we have a Ride the Wind,
trigger on the chain.
Gods, look.
>> Discard Tide Turner.
How come?
>> Tide Turner again, discard making this
way big. So, must we must have another
way to do something or else I think
we're digging for more. We're trying to
pitch a spell here.
Fizz is going to give us the Ride the
Wind. Is there anything for Prismacism
to stop this monstrous way? It will get
plus one because it's landing on Abandon
Hall as well. So, that's going to be a
nine might way. Let alone his movement,
he could make it even bigger.
>> I wish I had abandoned.
>> Oh, the hard bargain.
>> Can't find a star cross.
>> And that's the game.
>> Yeah, I was afraid of that one.
>> This is like, I don't know.
>> Prismacism eliminated.
In the quarterfinals, Bishwhite's is
going on to the semis.
>> So much.
>> And if you're Brady Ken, I think you're
breathing a sigh of relief.
>> Yeah.
Do not have to go up against the Annie.
A Diana continues on.
>> Now, what a great What a great series
from both We just jumped in the game
three and that was
>> in the other ones.
>> super, super entertaining.
And yeah, I mean, I don't know. Again,
seeing this top eight just makes me
realize
why I'm on the desk and judging.
>> I know, right? There's [laughter] so
many especially when you watch
Prismacism. There's so many times I'm
like, I would have played that turn
differently and I have never been in top
eight of a regional qualifier. So,
there's probably a reason for that.
>> you beat me.
>> I did beat you in the best of three.
>> that home.
>> But, Prismacism was not able to pick up
the win. So, the juggernaut of the top
eight has been eliminated. It is
guaranteed we will have a new winner, a
new champion at this regional qualifier
in Hartford. Very exciting time to be
watching competitive Riftbound right now
and very exciting time for your buddy
Brady Ken who again is going to have a
lot of Diana's presumably in this top
four. Now, at least one Diana is on the
other side of the bracket.
>> Well, we've pretty much guaranteed, I
believe, that we're going to have one
Diana in the finals, right? Cuz
Linsanity beat out Relivian in the lower
end of that bracket.
>> going to be a Diana mirror on the semi's
side.
>> Uh Diana mirror on the bottom side of
the bracket and then Brady's going to be
playing whoever wins the Diana Yi match
up. Obviously, if you're Brady, you're
really hoping that Yi doesn't make it
through because then all you got to do
is beat two Diana's and you're going to
lift the trophy.
>> What a great showing from Diana. We've
been kind of waiting for when Diana
would really step up and make a push for
you know, a championship run here and
two
in the semi-finals on the same side
guarantees a Diana in the finals.
>> Yeah.
>> The crazy thing is the 86% win rate
Ezreal is on the other half of that
bracket. So, if you're the Diana's if
you're like Linsanity here, you're
probably like, "Please win Master Yi and
then take out the Ezreal so that
[laughter] you get the Diana into Master
Yi in the finals." But hey, we'll know
all of that soon enough cuz we're going
to send you a short break before we are
back for our top four feature match.
Stick with us. We'll be right back after
this.
>> Hi, I'm Relivio with Challenger TCG. I
just made it into the top eight and I'm
playing Lux.
>> I'm Evan Esram with Aspirants Climb. I'm
playing Diana and I just made top eight.
>> [music]
>> My name is Brady Kenan and I just made
top eight with Ezreal.
>> [music]
>> Hello, my name is Factor and I just made
top eight playing Master Yi Wuju
Bladesman.
>> Hi, I'm Linsanity. I just made top eight
at Hartford with Diana.
>> I'm Prismatism. I just won the sixth
best of Annie, my sixth best of Annie.
I'm the best Annie in the world. I'll
see you in top eight.
>> Hey, I'm Miru with Team PBG and I just
top eighted the Hartford Regional with
Pike.
>> Hi, I'm BS Wyatts. I tested with a group
of my friends in Aspirants Climb and I
just made top eight with Diana.
>> All right, here we are. Look at this
bracket charmer top four
here in Hartford. We've got Ezreal
versus Master Yi up at the top side of
the bracket and
>> [music]
>> Diana
mirror match there at the bottom side
Lin Sanity
BS Whites and then we've got the
Bradykin versus Factor.
What a top four here and kind of mind
and chaos really showing up here in
Hartford.
>> Yeah, if you're a fan of mind and chaos
as domains then you're a big fan of this
top four but also if you're a fan of
fresh faces becoming regional champions,
you are very excited with prismaticism
dropping to BS Whites. We have
guaranteed
a first ever regional champion here in
Hartford. The other thing that is still
on the table is perhaps the first ever
regional champion Master Yi Factor being
the lone player on a legend that has yet
to win one of these events.
>> Yeah, that is absolutely right. Master
Yi has been so close so many times.
Could this be the tournament that Master
Yi finally climbs the top of the
mountain of a regional qualifier but
Diana has been super consistent showing
up here in Hartford and it's going to be
tough to stop but Ezreal
very good win percentage into Diana. So
if Ezreal gets through could be trouble
for Diana.
>> Yeah, as just legend match-ups across
this event we we know it's in the 80%,
right? We've seen the graphic, we've had
the discussion, we know that Ezreal is
incredibly favored into Diana. It's
probably exacerbated by the fact that
Bradykin has played phenomenally every
time we've seen them on the broadcast.
Came in as the number one seed for a
reason, so naturally I think that's our
game to watch because we're going to be
seeing whether it's Bradykin moving on
against a Diana or again Factor
potentially carrying on the hopes of
Master Yi winning the first regional. I
am excited to see the outcome one way or
the other.
>> Absolutely.
Here we go. We've got Master Yi versus
Ezreal. You can see the percentages
slightly favoring Master Yi.
And we know that Ruin Runner is going to
be a major part of this particular
match, Charmer.
>> Absolutely. Ruin Runner is
a vital card typically from the
sideboard. I haven't even seen [music]
some Yi lists running it in the main
just to deal with the Dianas or in this
case with the Ezreal. That is the one
thing working in Factor's favor. A lot
of the sideboard tech or a lot of the
options you're including because you
expect Dianas are just as potent into
Ezreal. On the other side though, again,
>> [music]
>> these percentages represent all of these
legends match-ups throughout the event.
We still have Bradykin, right? That
counts for a couple of percentage points
[music] in my mind, and I think that
this is going to be as close to 50/50 as
possible. So, with that [music] in mind,
let's take a look at this Bradykin list.
>> Now, again, this is a control Ezreal
deck. We've seen the Bewitching Spirits
absolutely wreak havoc on opponents all
weekend long. You've got the list, which
you and I have highlighted several
times. The list really coming into play
with the three copies of Pack of
Wonders. And you're able to really
double dip on the list being able to
rename the different tags if you need
to, and potentially give up to minus
four might with one list and one pack of
wonders.
>> Yeah, obviously with that pack of pack
of wonders, you've got cards like
treasure trove, Fizz, Bewitching Spirit
as well. So many options, even Sprite
Fountain being able to be played and
replayed if you want to kind of generate
accelerated units onto the board.
Meanwhile, on the other side, Wisp
Factor, this is a lot of might early and
often. Of course, here we do see the
main deck copies of Ruin Runner, and
that might be the story of this series.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We saw Factor be able
to get those Ruin Runners online earlier
in the day
versus Pike, a more [music]
control-oriented Pike, and
this is definitely going to be the story
here. Can't be chosen by enemy spells
and abilities, and a lot of the removal
for Ezreal will be targeting or
choosing, and you cannot do that with
Ruin Runner. So, going to be interesting
to see how this Ruin Runner is navigated
here in this match. Now, we are ready to
get down to the feature [music] area
for the semi-finals here in Hartford.
>> I am so excited for this match-up
because [music] one, we're in the top
four. We are so close to crowning our
new regional champion for Hartford.
[music] Again, all fresh faces. But, I'm
also excited because there is an ebb and
flow to this match-up. That's why I
think it's so close to being even in the
match-up [music] percentages because
you've got cards like Defy that you have
to play around [music] on the Master Yi
side, cards like Punch First that you
have to play around. But, Master Yi is
not known for drawing a ton of cards.
Yes, there are [music] some new options
that were made available in Unleashed.
Brady can with the spirits, [music] and
potentially being able to loop them with
Pack of Wonders could use that to an
advantage, play a nutrition game. It's
really going to come down to what is
available to players early on and as we
jump into this game, it looks like
there's already been a flurry of units
played and then killed.
We see the deadly flourish in the trash
there and a mastery coming from the
champion zone.
>> All right, so moving right along here in
game number one of the semi-finals.
And both chosen champs
finding their way onto the board rather
quickly. It's a prodigy going to get
some cards for Bradykin.
And there is that early bewitching
spirit here.
Targeting Factor's hand. There goes the
single copy of primal strength
in the main deck.
>> Yes, if you are Bradykin, you're very
happy to see this early bewitching
spirit. You don't have the pack of
wonders yet, but you want to strip cards
from Factor's hand as soon as possible.
What you don't want to see is something
like a conquer followed by a charm to
get run of get rid of excuse me one of
these key units that are in the base
right now, the spirit. Typically
you want to protect it if at all
possible. It's not really representing
might, it's more about the on
playability. Asriel with the cost
reduction is sometimes kind of coveted,
kind of protected as well.
And first Factor wants to get some
information.
>> Take a look here at this hand for
Bradykin.
>> All right, so there's a lot of choices
here. Only two cards that cannot be
chosen are thousand tail watcher and
Vex. We have another deadly flourish,
the stupefy, the list, and a bellows
breath. As I look at this, I might
consider something like the bellows
breath because that combos so well with
the thousand tail watcher or I might
consider something like the list just
because it's so reusable in this match
up especially post pack of wonders.
We'll wait and see what Factor does.
Two very valid targets.
And this is not an easy decision.
If you're Factor, and I think that's why
so much thought is going into it. Also
kind of comparing
the hand of Factor.
I see some options that are available to
maybe
play around some of these.
And he actually going to choose the
Stupefy. Maybe more scared of whatever
it's going to draw than anything else.
It is also a cheap activator to get that
Azrael legend online. So Stupefy plus
something like flourish represents
really drawing two cards.
And Factor says, "Okay, I want to make
sure that you don't have three damage
plus the might reduction for my Yi."
So now I move forward here in the turn.
We have that little Scuttle Crab. There
it is.
Oh, placing itself. What a pick up
there. He found a Ruin Runner. That's
what the crab drew. So exactly what we
want to find.
Sigil of the Storm and Seed of Power,
the two Battlefields
for game number one.
As Master Yi going into that southern
Battlefield, Factor getting on the
board.
I'll pass.
Uh your experience. Oh, yes. Deal. XP
And the look at that Braedy Ken here.
Being a great player saying, "You gained
experience from that hunt keyword. Do
not forget it." There's a not a lot of
players that will remind you of your own
triggers. So shout out to Braedy for
being a great guy.
Absolutely. Now here comes that Bellows
Breath.
This would be dealing one damage, not
being repeated.
>> Uh I believe it was Oh, I guess not.
It's just the one energy. I was going to
say I believe it was potentially
repeated uh because of the cost
reduction on the Ezreal.
I thought he said one and one.
>> Crap.
>> Sure.
Draw.
>> May I check something about crap?
>> Yes, yeah.
>> So, the discipline in response here is
going to buff up the Skuttle Crab.
>> Um so, this resolves.
Trigger as legend.
>> Okay, so he did repeat.
>> Yeah. I was going to say I'm pretty sure
he pointed and said one and one and it
was just from the cost reduction of the
Ezreal, so
>> I was listening
>> rune that was recycled and then one that
was just paid as energy and then
cost reduced.
>> Use the list to finish off the crab here
giving it minus two might had the one
damage on.
>> I'll attempt to Flourish Yi.
>> And Flourish looking to clear out the
board for Factor. That is going to
resolve and
Master Yi being taken down as well.
>> Swing here.
Yeah, good one.
>> Yep, I recycle a rune.
>> All right, Bewitching Spirit getting on
a battlefield.
>> Okay.
>> Getting Brady some points and then we're
going to see Ezreal go to the seat. Not
only is this a double conquer, but it
also does trigger Seat of Power, so more
cards drawn and it looks like Brady is
already working well into this attrition
game plan spending cards but getting
them immediately back.
>> Very solid start for Bradykin so far
here in game number one.
And for Factor, we do know that he found
that Ruin Runner. We'll see if those end
up getting developed in the near future.
Try and put some real pressure on
Bradykin with the
very difficult to get through five might
unit.
>> So, the downside to developing Ruin
Runner is you are also essentially
taking that turn off.
I like this play of going with the
orange Rengar.
You get to get on a location and try to
keep point tempo while also potentially
removing something. There is a known
Gust in hand and that's going to go on
the Ezreal to try to save it.
>> Yeah, that's good.
>> And it does resolve. So, Ezreal back to
Brady Kin's hand and Factor going up to
two points.
Evening things up in game one.
Still has three runes
ready.
>> And so, the question here if you're
Factor is do you just develop more
might?
>> Oh, excuse me. Sorry. My phone keeps
buzzing. Can I hand it to you to turn
off? I know I can't [laughter] look at
my phone.
All right. My phone My leg will be
shaking.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh.
Uh Brady with a buzzing phone. Probably
everybody who's been watching the stream
is trying to well wish and say good
luck, etc. But, unfortunately also
interrupting things.
>> All right. It's that guy.
>> And Fiora coming out there.
Fiora Peerless.
Interesting unit here.
>> Channel two.
>> Yeah, this is Oh, I was just going to
say this is a staple in Master Yi
because of the when I attack or defend
alone you double my might this combat
and obviously Master Yi wants units to
be alone when defending anyway. So, it's
been a natural inclusion
>> Okay.
>> for as long as the Fiora has been
around.
>> Yeah, when defending
a one-on-one combat Fiora would become
an eight might unit
in this Master Yi build.
Brady Kin holding up to three with the
Bewitching Spirit.
>> The one thing working against Brady thus
far is we've seen no copies of pack of
wonders. So while the bewitching spirit
has landed, while the list has landed,
there's not the easy way to reuse them
yet. The gust had to be used on saving
the Azrael. It would not surprise me if
that's the way to start this just to dig
a little bit deeper.
>> Play Azrael?
>> And there it is.
>> I'm going to discard.
>> Well, got to find these pieces.
What better way to do it than the
prodigy himself?
>> Starcross? Okay.
One.
Two.
>> Getting rid of the Starcross there.
Yeah, I think current board state and
known information for Brady that makes
sense. The biggest unit on the board is
not one you typically want to Starcross
unless you have to because it can be
ambushed again anyway.
>> Vex and I will pass.
>> And now developing the Vex hoping to get
that on a battlefield in the future to
prevent any other ambushes or
accelerates.
>> And now Factor will also hold the three.
Strong back line there for Brady Ken.
You've got the two units that you want
to continue recycling.
If we can get that pack of wonders in
place, start trying to shred Factor's
hand.
>> Yeah, on the side of Factor your game
plan now is to try to put your gas or
excuse me, your foot on the gas as fast
as possible. Sorry, I'm really excited.
So my brain is going faster than my
mouth. Uh the reason for doing so
obviously is the more points you can
score before that loop comes online, the
better position you will be. You also
would like to develop something in the
back line here because you expect Vex to
try to get on a battlefield the
following turn. And you'll want to be
able to go over the top. This could be
the turn
where Ruin Runner is considered as a
development, but now we have to respond
to the Gust.
>> And the Gust would certainly set Factor
back here.
>> There is options
in the hand. We see the On Guard. That
is a reaction speed way to pump the
might, which would make the Gust
essentially fizzle. It would not
resolve.
Hesitancy on Factor's side is likely
caused by the fact that if you do that
and develop something like a Ruin
Runner, then you have no other
interactive options on
Bradykin's turn.
Whereas if you leave it and you let that
go back, you could still develop the
Ruin Runner and save something like the
punch first in hand for whatever's
coming at the Rengar.
>> He does decide to play the On Guard.
>> Yeah, I think Factor is correct here. I
think getting the points and more
specifically getting on even points at
four is the way to go.
I also don't hate bringing this Rengar
back if I'm being honest. I I saw the
consideration. The reason I think Rengar
coming back is fine is it allows you to
reconquer Seat of Power the next turn.
The only downside to doing so is you
give a free battlefield for that Vex to
land on, but you have to trust in your
ability to generate enough might to go
over the top. So, I would strongly
consider moving this Rengar back just to
get the draw on a reconquer.
>> I mean, you would be putting 11 might
back in the base.
Plenty of pump spells in this deck.
>> Good.
>> And they absolutely sure to get over the
top. Yeah.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Not
to
draw.
>> And again, keep in mind that Fiora will
be an eight might when defending if it's
one-on-one combat.
So, Bradykin will have to keep that in
mind.
Yeah, we did see earlier
the gust attempted. We did also see a
star crossed that was discarded
uh to the Azrael.
>> Three, correct?
>> So, if we're looking for ways to bounce
or
remove the Fiora in that regard, you're
low on options.
Uh also, I'm
I'm looking at the runes on the side and
perhaps I just miscounted earlier, but
it's looking like Factor actually does
have one rune still available for the
punch first.
>> May I look?
>> Yep.
>> Pay two, recycle one.
Repeat Bellows on Fiora.
>> Ooh, Bellows breath
going to be repeated once again.
Two damage going on to Fiora.
>> Pack.
>> And the pack is found.
Pack plus list, we've seen this multiple
times this weekend.
Demacia
is the tag named.
And that's a minus two might for Fiora.
And Fiora will fall. Battlefields back
open here.
Pack of Wonders is such a big pick up
here for Bradykin
because now that Bewitching Spirit is
even more devastating if it can start
the loop, but it is going to be going to
a battlefield, so that tells me there's
likely
some other bounce coming and it is the
star crossed.
>> Star crossed going to
attempt to put the bewitching spirit and
the ring are back in their owner's
hands. Let's see if we possibly have a
defy from Factor.
It's got that one rune.
>> Yeah, I did not see a defy earlier.
Should be a punched first, a challenge,
and I believe the last one was another
unit. And now of course the ring are
that just went back to hand plus the
draw for the turn.
>> So now just left with the ruin runner.
>> Now if you're Factor, one of the things
that you
kind of get as a piece of information is
that Bradykin is kind of out of
defensive options at the moment. If
Bradykin felt strong in their ability to
hold, you have to assume Vex Apathetic
would have moved to one of these
battlefields, especially since the ring
are was returned to hand. And that's
also signaling that next turn Vex is
likely to end up on a battlefield
because you want to make it so that the
person has to either play ring are now
or lose value in the future.
Uh it also
means that
Factor is not able to conquer both
battlefields so no draw, which is what
they were trying to get when they
retreated the ring are earlier. On the
side of Factor, I might consider just
developing that second ruin runner here
and then saving the rest of your energy
for responses.
>> Another thing about Vex not going on the
battlefield, you love
for Bradykin not leaving it available
for ruin runner to potentially go into.
As we do see that second ruin runner
come down.
Exactly what Factor needs in this
match-up. We found two of them.
Now, the other option here because you
could just leave the one Rune up for a
Punch-First. You could develop the Pit
Rookie and place a buff.
Going to buff the one in the base.
Again, they can't be chosen. So, the
only way that Bradykin can go over the
top of one of these is with Might. I
love buffing the one in the base here
because you're kind of inviting Bradykin
to try to go over the top of Ruin Runner
on the Seat of Power with Might. And
then, we know that that Punch-First is
in hand. So, baiting Bradykin maybe into
a misplay. We'll have to see if he falls
for it.
>> Bradykin has been playing so well this
entire weekend.
Very likely has a read on
a possible Punch-First. We'll see if he
tries to act on this.
>> And Seeing Seven tells me this is going
to be a Watcher Accelerated.
Watcher does not target. So, the minus
Might does impact all of the units
including the Ruin Runners.
>> All right. So, that's minus three Might
across Factor's board.
And it's Ezreal and the Watcher moving
into that southern battlefield.
>> And this is very important because even
with the Punch-First, it would not be
enough.
I know it says minus one, but that
that should be minus three. Oh, it's
going to be minus one because they're
already factoring in the mastery then
re-triggering. And the minus one on the
Pit Rookie is because it's to a minimum
of one.
Specifically on Thousand-Tailed Watcher.
So,
>> it is now currently 10 to 4, but if
Brady can was doing the math to play
around punch first, that is still good
enough.
>> Yeah, it just doesn't get there.
Seat of power should be going to Brady
can here.
And the Ruin Runner not quite large
enough to deal with that very big threat
the Thousand Tailed Watcher.
>> Also, the unfortunate piece here is if
that buff that was placed on the one in
the base was actually on the one on Seat
of Power, it would at least be a trade
here.
But you would lose the Ruin Runner
either way.
>> Oh.
It's eight and two blue, but he used the
>> discounted energy with the
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, judge must have been asking about
>> turn I was like, "Asriel, yep."
>> Why?
>> I should have said that more explicitly.
>> Of course.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Of course.
>> Additional cost being reduced by Asriel.
Additional cost on the accelerate.
>> Um yes, so I'm at four.
I'll just kill the Asriel.
>> So here we go. Ruin Runner does fall,
Asriel as well, but Brady can going up
to five. We're tied up in game one.
And now Vex can get on a battlefield if
Brady can wishes to do so.
Three runes up.
>> There is a consideration for I was going
to say just double stacking on the seat.
The question now is is this Bewitching
Spirit again just a strip a card or do
you leave the energy open
whether you have it or not just a fake
reactions.
The answer appears to be no. So, it's
going to be the spirit into the base.
Yeah, and now only what a few cards in
hand. I was going to go down to two
cards in hand after this. One is still
known to Brady Ken because it was the
Rengar that went back to hand with the
star crossed.
>> Sure.
So, the first mate being discarded here.
>> I will pass the list.
And I will pass to you.
>> Okay, so the list going back to Brady
Ken's turn and we go back over to
Factor.
Has the backline here a total of eight
might. We see 11 might sitting on the
seat of power for Brady Ken.
>> Yes, and that's why the first mate was
the chosen discard because we know in
hand is a punch first and a Rengar. A
punch first would allow the ruin runner
to get over the top very easily.
And then with Vex gone, Rengar becomes
active again, but Factor wants all the
information before moving forward, plays
the Scuttle Crab. I like it. This is
what good players do. You want to have
more information before you commit to a
play.
>> That Scuttle Crab has been just so good
in this Master Yi deck.
Big piece to the puzzle here for Master
Yi getting the extra cards. It becomes
so much better in the early game for
Master Yi as well.
As it does get might when defending.
>> I do think that Factor was hoping to
find something else to go over top so
that the punch first didn't have to be
committed here.
It is an important card in this match up
and using it to save a ruin runner in
case there is another thousand tail
watcher coming at you is important. We
have to remember that though it's not
often what we think of with Pack of
Wonders, we think of the cheaper things,
you theoretically in this match-up get a
lot of benefit from using Pack of
Wonders on the Thousand Tail Watcher and
replaying it because the might reduction
still works on Ruin Runners.
And that is critical.
>> Yeah, that's such an excellent point.
One of the few ways that Brady can can
deal with the Ruin Runner.
Factor taking here a little bit.
Important turn.
>> Oh, and now we know what the card was
that was picked up. It's a Challenge.
Challenge, of course, allows you to
uh potentially deal with the unit, but
the problem is
the damage from the Challenge would stay
on whatever's doing the challenging
until a combat resolves.
So, if you use a Challenge on the Ruin
Runner to take out the Vex, for example,
you're not in a better spot. You'd still
die in combat to
uh the Thousand Tail Watcher. Also,
you'd have to pay through the deflect.
Maybe you consider challenging the
Bewitching Spirit, but the problem there
is with two damage on with your punch
first, it would only take
nine damage to kill you.
>> Yeah, the Challenge certainly changes
things here.
And it makes that decision point even
more difficult for Factor.
>> I think ultimately Factor was really
just looking for one more might
somewhere so that the Ruin Runner didn't
have to die in this trade.
There are several ways to get on this
Seat of Power,
but the issue is
almost all of them involve
this Ruin Runner
also dying.
>> All right, so we do see the challenge
here.
And Vex will be killed.
So, Vex and Ruin Runner dealing damage
to one another.
>> The option now is you can send to the
Pit Rookie in with the
And now that will leave the Ruin Runner
available to still go to the Sigil or
even just stay in the backline, but you
don't have to sacrifice it.
>> So, Ruin Runner moving up to Sigil, up
to six points goes Factor.
Does have to recycle a rune.
>> I do think
Yeah, I was going to say I do think that
no matter what happens, there has to be
a uh
trade into this Watcher somehow. Oh,
interesting. This might be a
consideration of just playing Ring Guard
and then Punch Firsting.
Although I would rather see the Punch
First be saved.
And Factor, I think is going to agree
with me.
>> I'm going to go Ring Guard to five,
recycle one.
>> Oh.
>> Going to turn around and make me a liar.
>> to Punch First anyways.
Ring Guard onto the Seat of Power, Punch
First giving Ring Guard plus five might,
Thousand-Tailed Watcher down. Up to
seven points goes Factor.
He just needs to hold one battlefield to
take the opening game here in the semis.
>> That's
such a tough decision to make, but
ultimately Factor does get the win off
of it. You could argue for Pit Rookie so
that you save the Punch First. Factor
instead wants to use the Punch First,
and I think the decision was
made because that represents not just
the Ruin Runner on one side, but a
six-might unit on the other, and that's
going to be hard to overcome being at
seven points. Bradykin had to have an
answer for both, ultimately did not.
>> Can you catch him?
The Ruin Runner says, "Catch me if you
can." And that's what Factor has been
saying to his opponents.
Each of these control-oriented decks
falling to the wayside with that Ruin
Runner.
Once again, the MVP in that game number
one.
>> And we talked about it before this
series began, that Ruin Runner is likely
going to be the story, whether it shows
up or not, whether there are answers.
Brady did have an answer for the first
one.
Unfortunately,
did not have an answer for the second
one, and once it got on a battlefield,
it was going to be too little, too late.
Players going into the sideboard now
potentially looking for options.
It is open deck list at this stage of
the event as well, so players will know
what is open to come in
as we look at the options that are
available. I'm not sure that Bradykin
has many things specifically in the
sideboard to deal with the Ruin Runner.
Typically, these purple mind lists might
have something like Kha'Zix. So, if it's
not a buffed Ruin Runner, or they don't
have the punch first, or they don't have
the discipline, and again, that's a lot
of ifs, but if they don't have those,
and it's left alone, something like the
Kha'Zix mutating horror would come in
and then be six-might attacking into
that five, so perhaps those will be the
choice for Bradykin.
>> As far as Factor is concerned here,
does have in the sideboard
another Ruin Runner, so it looks like it
was two in the main board and one in the
side, so I'm sure that will be coming in
in quite a hurry.
>> Yeah, I believe when we saw Brady Ken
playing earlier, we saw multiple Sprite
Fountains available. There was one in
the main, so one more in the sideboard,
and
those could be a consideration if you're
just looking for ways to loop a Might
and throw it at units. Again, you can
kind of loop it again with Pack of
Wonders bouncing the Sprite Fountain,
allowing you to replay it. It represents
three Might every time you do it. The
problem is this,
unless you're also still pairing that
with another unit, it still doesn't deal
with a Ruin Runner on its own.
>> Now, I've got a question for you here,
Charmer. So, we know how good the Pack
of Wonders has been for this Azrael
deck. And obviously, Factor doesn't want
to really change his game plan and
reduce some of that aggression. He is
the aggressor in this match-up, but I'm
just looking at the sideboard and I'm
seeing this Disarming Drake. Do you
think there's any room for that moving
forward in this match to potentially hit
a Pack of Wonders in the right spot?
>> I think that's actually a fair question.
My answer to that would be only if you
think that it is better than the card
that you're pulling out. And I know that
seems super obvious
to say, but what I mean when I say that
is
Disarming Drake just for the Pack of
Wonders isn't necessarily a ton of
value. You just won game one without
Drakes, and there was a Pack of Wonders
out. So, the question is instead to me,
are there cards in the main deck that I
just naturally want out cuz they're bad
in this match-up, and it could be
something like the challenge that we
saw. It could be the primal strength
that was discarded if you don't think
you'll need the money. It could be
the Fae or peerless that we saw because
that's susceptible to Gust and it's only
good for decks that want to get into
combat. And if you think but based on
your testing that any of those are just
not great here, changing those for a
Disarming Wrick would be fine, but I
don't think that you bring them in just
for the pack.
>> So, here we go. Game number two is
underway.
The early Scuttle Crab for Factor. It is
a nine-point game here with Aspirant's
Climb.
Emperor's Dais, the battlefield of
choice for Factor, which is very good
with Master Yi.
As we see the Bellows Breath coming
down.
>> But, it's also really good for Bradykin.
>> Yeah, that was all
>> This might be a situation where Bradykin
with the Bewitching Spirits, even if
they don't have a pack, will be able to
cycle them and hey, I was just talking
about Kha'Zix potentially coming in from
the sideboard and we see the Mutating
Horror in the hand.
>> There is Kha'Zix, certainly an option.
Could be extra might and help Bradykin
in the showdowns. Treasure Trove comes
down.
And speak pass back over to Factor.
>> Speaking of utilizing Emperor's Dais or
Pack of Wonders, Kha'Zix is another good
one because again, it has ambush. So, if
you're worried about it being stuck on a
battlefield and potentially perishing to
a counterattack,
using a Pack of Wonders or if you're
attacking into the Dais and just
returning it to your hand can also
prolong the longevity.
>> two
Master Yi tempered being played for
Factor.
Really like that early Bellow's Breath
to get the crab out of there because
it would have set up a possible turn
where that Scuttle Crab goes in, use
Emperor Jaece, bounce it back, get the
token.
So, that early Bellow's Breath really
stops the tempo for Factor early
as Bradykin is able to develop Vex in
the backline.
>> Yeah, meanwhile on the other side
Factor
is likely going to score the first
points of the game, but probably wants
to find something like a charm or a
charm plus a buff, whether that's a
discipline or an on guard to deal with
this Vex.
The fact that it came down so early this
game is uh an issue of sorts. We saw how
good Rengar was for Factor during the
last game. You kind of want to turn that
off if you can help it.
>> Got a one.
>> Yeah, I'll check a emphasis.
Spend one. Back to my hand, make a Sand
Soldier.
>> Sure.
>> All right, so up to a point for Factor
and Master Yi being bounced back to hand
off of that Jaece trigger. Sand Soldier
created and up to three XP
for Factor. Got one off the crab earlier
and now two from Master Yi's hunt
trigger.
>> Uh hand's back.
>> And there it is, the camel, the Ruin
Runner is here for Factor in game number
two.
>> It's wrong.
Stack deck?
>> Yeah.
>> The Ruin Runner comes down early. Both
players kind of finding key cards.
Bradykin with the Vex Apathetic, Factor
with the Ruin Runner.
Bradykin does
have enough runes and is at that
critical point where once the Ruin
Runner ends up on a battlefield,
something like a Watcher could still get
the job done.
Just have to find it. The good news is
Azriel is perhaps the best deck in the
game outside of the limitless locks at
drawing cards.
>> Stupid sand soldier?
>> Yeah, that was awesome.
>> Oh, and look at the hand. There is
another ruin runner already in the hand
of Factor. This might just be a repeat
of game one.
>> Trigger Azriel legend?
>> Yep.
>> And we do see the gust getting rid of
the token
on Emperor's dais.
Stupefy was able to draw another card
for Bradykin as well.
But yeah, these ruin runners, this is
the key to the match up. Factor has
>> Three, recycling one.
>> Man, he has drawn so well. He has drawn
these ruin runners when he needs them.
>> I'll discard.
>> And as I was saying, if you don't have
the watcher, you've got ways to find it.
We're seeing that on display. The
Stupefy drew a card. The Azriel legend
drew a card. The Azriel chosen champion
comes in, draws two cards. That turns
into a stacked deck that will net a
card.
And then, if all else fails, I was going
to say there is also the treasure trove
in a pinch, if you really want to go
that deep, but I assume Bradykin wants
to save that for when Pack eventually
shows up.
>> You get a card, and you get a card. You
get a card. Cards for everyone. Bradykin
stacking up that hand, looking for the
answers
as Factor has the ruin runner ready to
go.
>> And Factor also has
a lot of other actions in the hand. I
think that's a pair of alpha strikes
that may have come in from the sideboard
as well that I'm seeing at the bottom
side. I do also see the punch first, the
discipline.
But I think that might be two alpha
strikes.
>> Could be a very interesting way to deal
with a Vex Apathetic if it lands at a
battlefield.
>> Uh I was, I think, incorrect. Those look
like two Zonias hourglasses.
>> Okay.
The glare from the hourglass kind of
looks like the blade from Alpha Strike
when you're just looking at the side.
>> point.
>> Oh, they got it.
>> Factor up to two points and here is the
second Ruin Runner. Bradykin says not
again.
But unfortunately, it has happened
And Factor will further develop with the
lonely poro as well.
>> I was going to say there's going to be a
hidden Zonyas here for sure.
>> On top
>> I am not sure what Brady is going to be
able to pull out of his bag of tricks,
out of his trove of treasures to answer
two Ruin Runners backed up by two Zonyas
Hourglasses.
>> Pack the trove?
>> But Pack of Wonders is going to be the
start of whatever the answer is.
>> We are digging Charmer.
Pack of Wonders plus the Treasure Trove
combo. So, the Treasure Trove
going back to Bradykin's hand, he draws
one, gets to channel one
exhausted.
>> A two, recycle one.
>> You have to be careful with all this
digging though. The dwarves notoriously
dug too deep and they found a demon
under the mountain. Uh right now,
Bradykin is finding demons in the form
of Ruin Runners on the other side of the
board and the bellows cleaning up the
other options, but still so far not
finding any answer for the Ruin Runners.
>> The repeated bellows does allow Bradykin
to draw yet another card with that
Ezreal legend.
As now the spirit is going to force
Factor to discard one. It is going to be
the Chosen Champion.
>> Pass to you.
>> Now, we know Bradykin does have that
Kha'Zix in hand. If you're at home and
you're wondering why that was not
attempted to ambush on the location
where the Ruin Runner sits, even one
energy available to factor is enough to
be very scary. It represents punch
first, represents on guard. So, you're
going to need to make sure that you
either have your own bonus might or
reduction effects in the form of
something like watcher before you
attempt to send that Khazix in.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. Be careful
to not get blown out in that type of
showdown.
As Factor holds up to three. Three to
zero here early in game number two.
>> This might be I was going to say just a
played on Factor's turn hourglass
because that frees up the ability to
hide the second one.
There was I was going to say there was
also the option if you were going to go
to the dais to just play the other one
there and say pick your poison.
>> Was it a sand soldier?
>> Sure.
>> Up to four and bouncing the Ruin Runner
back to get that sand soldier token.
And the Ruin Runner at Aspirant's Climb
will be retreated back to base.
So, both Ruin Runners going to end up in
the back line for Factor now as the one
gets replayed. Three runes left open
>> Shallow
>> to interact with as we go back over to
Bradykin.
>> All right. I love what Factor just did
for a couple of reasons. The first,
retreating saves you from any sort of
watcher play because they won't be able
to go over the top.
The other thing that's happening, it
might seem weird to bounce the Ruin
Runner with the dais and simply replay
it, but what's actually happening is
Factor is spending no additional cards
to generate additional might on the
board. And since you know Bradykin has
Pack of Wonders and has Bewitching Spear
online, your cards in hand are now at a
premium. So, using something like dais,
even if it's expensive, even if it's
replaying the Ruin Runner, just means
that Bradykin still has to deal with the
Sand Soldier somehow or else he'll give
up a hold point while keeping the number
of cards in hand the same.
>> Bradykin attempting to Bellows Breath
repeated here to take out that Sand
Soldier, but Discipline
will buff the soldier up. That's a four
might Sand Soldier.
>> So, does this resolve to confirm after
that or
>> That was in response. It had to be in
response to the bellows. So, that's
still on the stack.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, just deciding if the Bellows Breath
will resolve.
>> Yeah, that was awesome.
>> And it will, so that's two damage on the
soldier.
>> And the reason that that
had to be resolved and the reason Brady
was asking is specifically for the
Azrael Legend. Brady clearly wanted to
draw the card, but there was still
theoretically a window for something
like a Defy.
Yes, when your opponent plays Discipline
in response, it's almost assumed that
that's the only thing they're going to
do, but again, Brady being a very kind
competitor throughout this entire
tournament, just double-
>> Yeah, Bradykin has been
a joy to watch.
>> Channel.
Draw.
>> Pact Trove once again getting an extra
card and an extra rune.
>> That is one heavy pack of wonders
to be carrying around a literal treasure
trove and all of these cards in hand.
So, I do see a watcher now.
I see a number of things that target,
which is unfortunate for Brady.
>> Yeah, that is the key.
Ruin Runner just shutting all of it
down.
And it's very hard when you can't target
the Ruin Runners, it's hard to fight
them
in the might game.
>> Now, it is worth noting that with many
of the Dianas that we've seen in this
tournament,
one of the cards that's often included
in the list somewhere, whether it's in
the main or in the sideboard, is Baron
Nashor. Just a giant thing that's hard
to get rid of. Brady can does not run
that in the list. The largest unit is
the Watchers, and then there's a one-of
Mind Splitter that we know sometimes
comes in from the board. And that is
also potentially problematic because
that means anytime you end up on a
battlefield, Factor is threatening more
might to reconquer. You don't have that
big sticky option to just come in and
try to bail you out.
>> So, we do see that Zhonya's Hourglass
popped here as Ezreal goes in for the
trade.
>> Play a pack.
>> A second pack of wonders now for
Bradykin.
>> Move here.
>> Yep.
>> And Bradykin is going to get on the
board here.
>> Replay the spirit.
It's got Unguard.
>> And the discarding continues.
As the Bewitching Spirit is replayed
after being bounced by the Pack of
Wonders. Unguard is discarded, and we go
back over to Factor.
>> Now, there was a lot done by Brady that
turn.
There was cards that were discarded on
Factor's side. You popped the Zhonya's
Hourglass on a Sand Soldier, which is
typically not the unit you want to save
with that. You scored your first point,
and yet Factor is still threatening to
conquer to six, still has two Ruin
Runners.
Six is not within threatening range
because of Aspirant's Climb, but still,
Brady has to be worried about the number
of points that Factor has accumulated
and continues to do so at this stage of
the game.
>> Definitely the position that Factor
wants to be in.
Inching ever closer to
>> Time to go to five?
>> Yep.
a spot in the finals. Going up to five
here with the Sand Soldier at Aspirants'
Climb.
>> And again, knowing that the spirit combo
is online.
>> Emperor's Dais.
>> I I was about to say I expect this to
still be returned and then still be
replayed because you just want to have
them safely in the base. You want to
force Brady to spend resources to get
rid of the Sand Soldiers.
>> On top.
Channel the
>> to protect your cards in hand for as
long as possible. If Brady wants, they
can easily make Factor discard three
here. But again, all of this discarding
doesn't answer the Rune Runners on the
board. That is the biggest issue for
Brady can at the moment.
>> And now two Sand Soldier tokens in play
for Factor. One holding at each
battlefield. That Emperor's Dais just
has been so good
in these Master Yi builds. I love what
Factor is doing with it here in the
semifinals.
>> These two.
Mind Splitter?
>> Ooh, Mind Splitter coming down for
Bradykin.
Now let's see if Factor
has any reactions, anything he wants to
play out of his hand before Bradykin
takes a look.
>> Yeah, there's not
a ton of options here
that you want to play just for the sake
of playing outside of maybe the Rengar.
You could play the Rengar
for five just to get it on the board.
But then you're also just giving an open
window and it does look like this is
going to be the case. So Factor going to
be playing the Rengar.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, so adding six more might to the
southern battlefield.
>> Oh, dear.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, the rest of the hand defy defy
punch first hourglass all things that
you are not happy to see.
>> Not at all.
Double counter spell punch first so you
can't go over the ruin runner. And if
you do we have Azonia's hourglass for
good measure.
>> We'll take the punch first.
>> Punch first will be discarded.
>> Discard yeah.
>> Yeah, yeah I'll discard it.
>> Yeah, and that is I think the correct
call.
Because you know that your best chance
at getting rid of cards like ruin runner
is again typically through watcher
interactions and so if you're minusing
might you don't want to give factor the
ability to increase that might. The
counter spells aren't super relevant in
terms of the ruin runner because they're
already untargetable and the Azonia's
while annoying is still something that
you can forcefully burn through so I I
do like Bradykin's selection there but
again
all of these resources all of these
cards played impressive turns
each time but still falling so far
behind in the points game factor holding
to eight now within striking distance
and still has two ruin runners. This is
going to be a tough one for Bradykin to
pull out.
>> And now a second copy of Vex was
developed for Bradykin but those Vex
they've been unable to get to the
battlefield here in game two
and create any disruption.
>> This just shows you how polarizing ruin
runner is in certain matchups because if
these are almost any other units that
factor has been developing these games
Bradykin has a wealth of answers a
wealth of options to deal with them.
But, because it's specifically Ruin
Runner, and because Factor has very
wisely
kept them in base as much as possible to
avoid the Watcher play that Brady sprung
on him in game one, it's been near
impossible for Brady to have any sort of
answer to the camels.
>> Both of the Sand Soldiers being
retreated back to base.
Eight to one the score here. It has been
a dominant game number two and a
dominant match up to this point for
Factor.
And it's really all been on the back of
the Ruin Runner.
Creating a massive problem for Bradykin.
Hiding at the Southern Battlefield. We
know there was another Zonya's Hourglass
in hand.
>> Yeah, and that's exactly why the Sand
Soldiers were retreated because you want
to make Bradykin have to burn through
this Rengar,
and then have the Zonya's pop in
response to the Rengar. You don't want
to have the Zonya's trigger on a Sand
Soldier.
So,
by leaving them in the base, but keeping
the Rengar on the battlefield,
even if Bradykin has an answer for the
Sand Soldiers, something like a Bellows
Breath, you don't have to pop your
Zonya's in response there.
>> Shrink Rengar?
All right, here comes the list.
Cat's the name. The cat is Rengar, and
he is going to be shrunk by a couple
might.
>> The big knife kitty has become
>> [laughter]
>> a small kitty.
>> A double pack of wonders can certainly
reduce this might further. So, there it
is, the list being bounced and replayed.
Down to two might.
Goes Ringar.
>> I will
attack my seven to your four.
>> And properly identifying that there
would still be the plus two from the
Yisu, saying seven to four when Brady
sends it in.
>> Um
>> And here is the punch first from Factor.
Plus five might up to nine might goes
Ringar.
>> Nine.
>> Two might up here.
>> Yes. Nine, yep.
>> Plus three.
>> And Brady can cannot be happy to see
that punch first. You played the mind
splitter, you got rid of one, thought it
might be safe to go in and have a simple
math problem be solved by might over
might and instead
punch first comes in. Kazak's ambushing
in does get the plus two because Ringar
is alone.
>> Um in response
a lot of us.
Yeah, with my focus.
Um
>> There is the Zonyas Hourglass.
>> I pass focus back.
>> So much on the line for these players.
We are in the top four.
Both of them trying to secure their
first ever birth to a regional qualifier
finals.
>> Um
>> Ringar back to base saved by Zonyas
Hourglass. Kazak's remains at Emperor's
dais.
Brady can up to two points. It's eight
to two, but what a back line that Factor
has here.
A double conquer on this next turn and
he heads to the finals.
10 might still available in the back
line for Bradykin.
And he's going to have to hold one of
these battlefields.
Yeah, the big predicament for Brady here
is even if you just go all in on one of
these battlefields. You say, "Hey, I've
got you off of them. You're not holding
to nine currently. I will turbo stack
one to prevent your double conquer." The
issue then becomes
all of the other units for Factor will
end up on the opposing battlefield,
right? On Aspirant's Climb. And they
don't even have to send them all. You
could send everything but still leave
one Ruin Runner. And then that's going
to make it incredibly difficult to deal
with everything.
>> Everyone here?
>> On top of
having the Ruin Runner in the back, but
that is going to be the play. So, we're
going to see the turbo stack on
Emperor's Dais.
>> And a card hidden as well.
Let's see what Factor has for us. We
have a total
of 20 might in the back line.
And it is 14 might total showing right
now at Emperor's Dais for Bradykin.
>> It's also worth noting that Bradykin
does have four energy available, but is
playing with known information into two
more Defies.
>> Sand Soldier comp procuring
the Aspirant's Climb Factor
drawing a card
off that conquer.
>> The current math problem, if you're
counting the might, is 14 [snorts]
on that Emperor's Dais. So, just in base
alone
Factor has enough. But again, you're
playing around the unknown.
What can Bradykin Yeah, what can
Bradykin play from hand?
>> That lone Sand Soldier in the base now
four might. Factor able to pick up
another card.
I'm very curious to see what kind of
reaction Brady can have.
When Factor moves in, here's a pit
rookie that's going to buff one of the
ruin runners up to six might.
The might continues to grow in base.
>> I think the real question is going to be
whether Factor sends everything all at
once or just tries to daisy chain these
in one at a time and get these favorable
trades. It's a looking like there's a
consideration to go one at a time just
deal with the vexes. That might be why
the discipline was on the sand soldier
cuz that trades cleanly with a vex four
might to four might.
And for now it might be a bit of a a
combo look where you're going to send 10
and try to get rid of maybe both vexes
and the spirit.
>> Sand soldier plus Ringard 10 might for
Factor into 14 for Bradykin.
Bradykin has focus here.
>> Has focus but is knowingly playing into
two defies.
>> You got it. I have no line here.
>> GGs.
>> Oh, he doesn't have a line. There is no
fist bump. Factor to the finals
here
in Hartford.
>> So the four energy that was saved is
shown to have been saved for another
Kazak but because Factor attacked with
two units instead of going with the
daisy chain one at a time, two units
means that the Kazak as well not trigger
get the bonus might.
>> Yeah, the Kazak was so scary.
Wow, incredible.
Factor heading to the finals, Master Yi
in the finals.
Can Master Yi potentially get there here
in Hartford? We're going to be finding
out shortly, but let's take a look at
the bracket now.
As we have just one more match to play
in Hartford. Master Yi, Factor advancing
on, and it's BS White with Diana. BS
White's taking down the mirror match
over Linsanity. And it'll be Master Yi
versus Diana
for the trophy here in Hartford.
>> Yes, this guarantees that we're going to
crown a new regional champion here in
Hartford. Both of these players, it's
their first time advancing to the
finals. We have the opportunity to
potentially crown our first [music]
ever Master Yi winner of a regional
qualifier. And in my mind, these players
are already winners, but of course, we
have to crown one big winner at the end.
>> [music]
>> Absolutely. Just one more match remains.
One player will lift the trophy. We're
going to step away for a short break,
and then we will be back for the finals
here in Hartford.
>> Bear Bryant here, and I have the
absolute pleasure to be joined by one of
our special best of winners across this
weekend here in Hartford. Zam Berserker,
congratulations on winning this coveted
trophy here for your wall. And I've got
to ask you because people at home are
going to ask, how old are you again?
>> Uh 15.
>> 15 playing Rift Bound, and this is your
first ever regional. Is that correct?
>> Yes, it is.
>> Now, I hear you have a lot of support at
home where you get to play a bunch of
games, but um I also have heard that you
might have been getting a little bit of
support from some other Volibear players
out there. Is that correct?
>> Yeah.
>> So, I think I've got a guest for you
right here that um
Villionaire, our four-time Volibear
winner,
um tell me cuz I've heard you two have
already met.
>> Yeah, we met in uh RQ Vancouver.
Um his dad had come up to me, told me he
was a big fan, and he loves playing
Voli, and I had kind of inspired him to
play. We sat down and played a game, and
he smoked me, and I was like, "Man, you
should be doing what I'm doing." And uh
yeah, then he told me he was going to be
at Hartford, and uh he was updating me
all day yesterday. I unfortunately got
knocked out, but he ended up taking it
all the way with my U Trek list, and
that's so sick. I'm so happy for him.
>> No, that's incredible. So, Zamberzerker,
I've got to ask you the question then,
do you feel like, you know,
with the extra help in the
communication, do you think that you
could maybe become the new best of
Volibear four-time player to take the
take the crown from Villionaire himself?
>> Uh definitely.
>> I mean, now of course, this being the
last Origins claim, I'm excited to see
what you might shift to, and maybe
there's maybe some uh tag team working
together, seeing if we can take some
best ofs in the meta format.
Yeah?
>> Could be.
>> Hoping.
>> Awesome. First of many best ofs.
Zamberzerker, congratulations.
Villionaire, great teaching opportunity,
but always still showing that if you put
in the hard work with a legend since the
beginning, you can take home a coveted
prize such as this best of. But we're
going to go ahead and send it back.
>> And we're ready. Grant, it is time for
the grand finals of the Rift Bound
regional qualifier in Hartford. We're
going to have a new champion crowned
today, and it's going to be Master Yi
taking on Diana in the finals as
Beishuwang will take on Factor.
>> Yeah, so a lot of players kind of
discounting the Yi, right? Saying, you
know, it's a popular deck.
>> Yeah.
>> It It can't put results up, can't find
the top eight. I've seen posts on social
media, all kinds. Factor saying,
>> "Watch me. Watch me. Watch me make it to
the finals, and I actually go through uh
you know, one of the favorites in the
tournament. I mean, he's taken out uh
your buddy unfortunately there. Um but
uh yeah, I don't think a lot of people
expected Master Yi to make this deep of
a run. Diana, if you said eventually
towards the end of Unleashed, will make
a run for the finals, I'd be like, yeah,
people will figure out the deck. It'll
make sense by that point. Maybe it
struggled a little bit at the beginning,
but once you kind of solve the format,
it makes sense. It's there. But Master
Yi is a bit of more of a surprise for
me, but Ruin Runner is putting in a lot
of work
>> in these matches as you can see in that
semi-finals. We saw Factor kind of use
that Ruin Runner, both Ruin Runners.
Remember we saw him play a Pike earlier
where he had two Ruin Runners in game
one, two Ruin Runners in game two, and
like we saw in this Azirelia matchup,
two Ruin Runners as well in game two.
And having, you know, the Punch First,
the Rengar, the Sand Soldiers, or the
Emperor's Dais, very hard for any purple
deck, let alone a blue purple deck to
deal with.
>> It It's almost reminiscent of like all
the Vex apathetics that we were seeing.
It's like, oh, the first one you can
deal with, but then the second one's
really tough. Well, Vex apathetics
doesn't do much when the second Ruin
Runner hits the board. So, that is
definitely the bigger threat going into
this finals. And I got to say, I'm
liking Factor's chances against the
Diana list. This is Yi's bread and
butter. It's taking on these chaos lists
um that have the Star Cross, that don't
have as much uh you know, uh might to
beat over your units, especially when
you factor the Punch First. And there is
a slight win rate for Master Yi versus
Diana so far this weekend.
>> Yeah, and it's very interesting cuz
there's a lot of different Diana lists
that we've seen, right? We saw some
Diana lists that were running Sprite
Fountain, some that weren't, some that
were running Baron in the sideboard,
some that weren't. Obviously, if you
drop a Baron down, it's kind of
difficult for the Master Yi to deal with
it.
>> Yeah.
>> But looking at this list, we're not
really seeing a Baron for
playing good old Blurple Diana.
>> [laughter]
>> Good old Blurple Diana. We look at the
records of both of [music] these
players. 11-1-1 for both of them. As you
can look at recent achievements, nothing
[music] on either of the resumes. New
hero is a great tag and a new champion
will be added to that list based on
whoever wins this match today. It's
awesome to see new legacies being born.
It's still within the first year of
competitive Riftbound, so we have so
many players that are, you know, putting
their stamp on that first year, saying,
"I'm in the conversation as one of the
early best players
>> in the card game. Yeah, and it's more so
very impressive when we're seeing We saw
two time in in Utrecht, right? We saw
two time previously with Alanzq lifting
that trophy as well for the second time.
So, maybe this is a, you know, breath of
inspiration for people at home and other
players to be like, "Hey, these top guys
are at the tournament. They're playing,
you know, I'm going to have to play into
them, but we see Bschwitz, we see
Factor.
They're in the finals now, and they'll
One of these players will lift the
trophy.
>> One of them will lift the trophy. You
see again how Bschwitz got into the top
eight, only dropping a single game,
tying with TheVex. And then Factor on
their way last lost earlier to Sam D.
Sherman, but has been on a tear ever
since. The only draw was an intentional
draw as they both knew that they were
going to be making it into the top
eight. And so, essentially just a win
streak since that loss to Sam D.
Sherman.
>> And notably the Bschwitz didn't see a Yi
from what I saw in the entire Swiss
bracket.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> So, this is the list that we're looking
at, right? We were mentioning it
earlier. No Baron in the sideboard. We
got some, you know, interaction with the
hard bargain in the main as well, but
once those camels hit the board,
>> Yep.
>> a lot of these spells get turned off.
>> And one of the best tools Diana has to
deal with [music]
the Ruin Runner, plus the punch first in
these giant camels, is the Huwei, which
only two of in Bschwitz's list. Not a
three of, and there's not an extra one
in the sideboard that we're seeing. So,
it's going to be a a of dig to find the
Huwei cuz that is
>> [music]
>> your biggest unit that you have to
actually deal with the threat of the
Master Yi. He doesn't even have things
like the mind splitter, which would be
that big seven might unit. It's kind of
Kazix and Yi is is the high end of this
Diana list.
>> Yeah, and looking at the entire list,
there is no spell in this list that can
affect a Ruin Runner. However, Yi wants
to isolate their battlefield, right?
They want to have one unit there and one
unit somewhere else.
>> A creative thing that Beets Switched can
maybe leverage is using something like a
Moonfall to attack into that Ruin
Runner's battlefield, bring another one
of Factor's units there to not only turn
off the Yi passive, but swing to a delta
of four technically as we're going to do
a minus two on both those units because
that given enemy units there minus two
is not choosing, it is just blanket
applying to that battlefield.
>> Exactly. I'm happy you highlight that
interaction cuz it is one of the best
tools Diana has. We're looking for the
Ways, we're looking for the Moonfalls.
It's only a two-of for Moonfalls as
well, though. There is a third in the
sideboard. I would fully expect [music]
that third to come in for Beets Switched
going into a game two and a game three.
>> [music]
>> But, we've seen this list before. We've
also highlighted things like the rebuke
as well. Cannot be defied. That's like
the only spell in the entire deck that
cannot be defied by the Master Yi. You
have to be ready for defies in this
match up.
>> And I was talking to some friends of you
know Beets Switched earlier while with
the top four was going on. Their testing
group really focused on having an
Arena's Greatest in this list of
battlefield. Kind of unique for some of
these Dianas, right? You usually will
see the Rockfall Path or something along
those lines, but that Arena's Greatest
really allows you to go quicker when
you're going first, especially into the
mirror. And we just see that Beets
Switched did manage to win 2-1 in the
top four where he did end up winning his
his Arena's Greatest game. So, this is
something that is going to be something
to look forward to to see how it kind of
interacts with this
with this Master Yi, excuse me.
>> Yes. And speaking of Factor's list,
you're very clean, very streamlined,
running the one primal strength, the one
challenge, everything else pretty much
play sets.
And again, on the Fiora's, which is
something that I wasn't sure if we would
see as many of in the Unleashed format
as the deck continued to evolve, but
it's proven it's worth. But the big
heavy hitter is that Ruin Runner. Let's
pull it up here cuz this is why we saw
Factor have such a good match up in the
semi-finals.
>> It's such a clean unit. Six energy, five
might, can't be chosen by spells and
abilities. A lot of the chaos spells,
chaos domain spells do end up targeting.
>> Same with the column as well, yeah.
>> Exactly, yeah. Ruin Runner is going to
be very safe on that in play, but also
notably, we see two battlefield
crossovers.
>> True.
>> Between both of them. Seed of Power and
Arena Greatest run in both
the Diana and the Master Yi list, with
the only difference [music] being
obviously Abandoned Hall for Diana,
which is their bread and butter, and the
Emperor's Diadem for Master Yi, as we
saw in game two [music]
of that match on against Ezreal putting
a lot of work with those sand soldiers
into creating problems for Brady getting
to deal with.
>> There's a chance, depending on what they
choose for their first battlefield,
there's a chance that we get like the
same battlefield two games in a row if
we end up going for three. But I'm
hearing that the players are ready, so
let's not waste any more time. It is
time to begin our grand finals of the
Riftbound Regional Qualifier here in
Hartford. One [music]
player will leave as a brand new
champion, beginning their own resume as
a pro player here in Riftbound. [music]
>> You can't be more excited if you're a
Riftbound fan at home, in the hall, all
over the world. It shows you that, you
know, you can pick up the game whenever.
You know, we have a fun set coming out
next set with the enemy color pairings
out in Vendetta. We have [music] some
great Riftbound, a best of three here
that we're going to play out between
Beastwitch and Factor, so a good day for
Riftbound fans.
>> And [music] often times I feel that the
last regional qualifier in a given
format is usually the mark of the true
masters of the game because the format
has had so much time for you to
practice, so much time [music]
to invent new techs for different
match-ups. So, to make it to the finals
already [music] at the last regional
qualifier for the Unleash format is
impressive. To take it is a quite a
notch in your belt there as a pro
>> [music]
>> player.
>> They're both players on the table
communicating with each other here
getting ready for the match, taking a
look at each [music] other's deck lists
and making sure that they're comfortable
going into the match-up.
>> It's just so exciting to think that
we're going to add another name to the
champions wall for Riftbound regional
qualifiers.
>> Yeah, and it's it's nothing to you know,
shake your nose at because this is a
grueling weekend that these players have
to go through. We had you know, players
that
13 rounds of Swiss into a top eight
which is a single single elimination.
A grueling grueling grueling weekend and
as someone who usually experiences this
on the judge side, I can see the toll it
takes on players. But both these guys
look fired up and ready to go.
>> Yep, both of them look determined is how
I would phrase that one. You can tell
focus and determination are going to be
what gets you across the finish line
here. You need to make sure that you
keep a clear mind. Don't panic.
>> What happens
>> Players like
>> Fiora Peerless
I'm just curious to a single unit. And
then I play a Kazix.
>> May I read both parts?
>> Okay, so asking a ruling question here
about Fiora Peerless.
It's one of those differentiators
between the win effects and the while
effects. If Fiora Peerless says while
I'm one-on-one in combat, then that
would be removed. But if it says when I
enter combat one-on-one, then I believe
that would be a trigger that enters onto
the chain and would
then still resolve even if a Kazix comes
out. Do you happen to remember what the
wording is, Grenton?
>> Yeah, so Fiora Fearless is a trigger.
>> Okay.
>> So, it'll check that it's attacking or
defending one-on-one.
And that's all it all it cares about.
>> Okay, sure.
>> you're bringing in a Kha'Zix afterwards,
it will still double the might.
>> Yes, because it adds to the chain and
that means that, you know, it it's
fulfilled its uh necessity to activate.
Um but it's a good thing to confirm
because it's not one of the most common
cards in Master Yi. I've seen a lot of
Yi lists move on from it thinking, "Ah,
it's it kind of deramps you for your
Rengar plays cuz Rengar's on the five
ramp and Fiora's on the three ramp, but
it depowers you a power cost, so then
you're not able to play that Rengar
right away." And uh some folks were
like, "No, the Rengar's now the more
important one to focus on." And uh
because of that, I think that uh Fiora
might be taking some players by
surprise, but
uh Beastyqt's definitely making sure
he's doing his due diligence, asking
exactly how that interaction works
because Kha'Zix is one of those ways for
him to swing in and get that extra
damage.
>> Yeah, it's definitely a tech piece for
this Master Yi list. It's something
different that we saw get iterated upon.
We were talking you we had some
interviews with, you know, Houses Are
Big who kind of popularized that that
that Master Yi, excuse me. And it was I
like that inclusion. It's something that
I played in Spirit Forge in my Master Yi
mid-range deck in the sideboard was that
Fiora Fearless because it can catch you
off guard.
>> Yeah, it was one of those ones that the
first like couple of events I went to
for Spirit Forge, never saw it. And then
once Master Yi's figured out the
interaction, it was like, "Oh, yeah,
this is how you're supposed to play Yi."
And uh I'm happy to see it find its way
back into deck lists. But again, the big
one is still going to be that Ruin
Runner. Every time you're a Chaos Domain
deck and you're playing against the Ruin
Runner, you need to have a plan for how
to deal with that. The Moonfall's going
to be one, the Huwei's going to be
another. So then, when I think of that,
when there's only going into it in the
main deck, two Moonfalls, two Huweis,
expecting a lot of digging and a lot of
searching for Be Shweiß to try and find
those cards to make sure he has the
answer.
>> Yeah, both these players in good spirits
ready to go. We reviewed the deck lists.
We've taken a look at what our strategy
is going to be going into it. Obviously,
Be Shweiß got his question answered by
by the judges. Figured out kind of how
that Fiora Peerless interaction works.
And it's something that is very
interesting. And I think he was asking
what happens if I, you know, bring in a
Kha'Zix.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? Cuz Kha'Zix now cares about if
the other unit's alone. So, both those
cards Um funnily enough, they only check
on, you know,
finalization to trigger it. The
condition needs to be met.
>> Yeah.
>> And then, once it's met, doesn't matter
what happens afterwards. We're going to
resolve that trigger. We're going to get
it. And you were right. We're seeing a
double Seat of Power game one.
>> Incredible. Double Seat of Power here
from Factor and Be Shweiß. I wasn't sure
cuz sometimes the match ups go for that
the Emperor's Dais first, but instead
it's going to be double Seat of Power.
So, that means whoever can establish
control of the battlefield can
theoretically then get more card
economy. But, we're into turn number one
or at least into opening hands.
Factor is going to be putting a few
back, at least one.
>> And it's just the Pit Rookie saving the
Scuttle Crab sabotage. And there was a
Ruin Runner in the opening grip for
Factor. Already found a very powerful
tool.
>> All right. So, we're going to start
things off here. Be Shweiß first to go
as he is the first Sorry, he was second
seed technically, if I'm not mistaken,
in our
in our bracket. So, he gets to decide
who starts in this first game, which can
be pretty impactful. But, we do know
that Factor does have that Ruin Runner.
Scuttle Crab, our friend, we love him.
Going to replace itself, little can
trip, getting another card back in hand.
And I'm not sure if that was another
Scuttle Crab that we drew or it was a
Charm.
>> Uh well, Charm or Scuttle Crab, either
one was drawn for turn, the other off
the Scuttle Crab. And now, uh the Ruin
Runner won't be able to come out
immediately. I think that's a Discipline
as the fourth card
uh in Factor's hand right there. So, a
couple of different tools. I see two
crabs, a a sabotage of charm,
and then I'm not sure Was that the Rune
Runner at the end? Might be the Rune
Runner at the end, yeah.
>> We develop the Diana back in our base,
and we're just going to pass again.
We've seen these players at this high
level now being very patient, right?
They're not going to overextend. It is
an eight-point game, yes, but
the single odd numbers are not really
important.
>> And also has just the two develop here
for Factor. Rune Runner we expect on the
following turn, and not going to send
out that Skewered Crab for an early
point, instead going to save it.
Sometimes I think that you can just send
it out for that point, cuz even if it
dies, you get the death nail, you get to
look at your opponent's hand, you get
some information, but being on the odd
number of points doesn't really
accelerate you that much. So, Factor
just going to save the unit for now.
>> Yeah, we're going to move that Diana
into one of the two seeded powers, use
that legend ability score to the moon
that to create that energy to resolve
our Diana Lunari trigger, revealing a
Fizz that we're going to leave on top.
Obviously, the trigger doesn't make us
recycle it, just makes that known
information now, so Factor can take his
next turn with the knowledge that there
is a Fizz coming, but nothing in the
trash yet. Two target with that Fizz
trickster.
>> Yeah, I have not gotten a good look at
Beach White's hand yet in terms of what
else they're working with.
Fizz is not a bad one to have in your
hand though, as it will eventually come
more online. Beach White's is just going
to pass with all runes up, and now it's
on Factor for the play.
>> Yeah, and this could be even a sabotage
into the Rune Runner, and it looks like
that's what we're going to see here from
Factor. So, now we're going to get to
look at what Beach White's hand is.
Thank you, Factor.
>> I'll stupefy a mastery in response.
>> Okay. Interesting.
So, opting to stupefy, that means that
Factor will get the additional
information of what was drawn with the
stupefy, but now it gives one less
option. It looks like I would imagine
that Moonfall was probably the one
drawn, and that's probably the one
that's getting hit here.
>> Yeah, I'm curious. We did have the hard
bargain. We could have
if we think they're on Rune Runner in
hand, we could maybe hard bargain them.
So, if they want to see my hand, then
they can't play Rune Runner this turn.
>> Sure.
>> Or if they just don't care about the
sabotage resolving, they just let it and
my hard bargain did its job, and then we
have to deal with the Rune Runner.
>> A lot of targets available here. Sprite
Fountain,
hard bargain, stack deck, Moonfall.
So, pretty big choice for Factor. I feel
like the Moonfall is just so valuable.
Take that out of the equation, but I
suppose there are arguments for things
like the hard bargain and the Sprite
Fountain as well. Um Sprite Fountain is
really the only way he could get back
out quickly cuz the two units are there.
If you can clear these, it's nice, but
the Moonfall is too big of a threat, and
that is removed.
Especially with the Fizz in rotation,
too. Like that you could get two
activations of the Moonfall, and then it
gets crazy.
>> Yeah, and Fizz notably uh has to
interact with the trash sabotage. A
very, very lovely card that gets to put
at the bottom of your deck.
>> Mhm.
>> So, you don't get to see it unless you
draw your deck, which this D'aeliyr list
beat with the Whisp.
We saw the Whisp uh
ready to go in the hand. So, maybe we
can get some draws going there, but
Factor trying to decide what he's doing.
The Supervisor really heads-up play
because it does make it so that Ye is
only trading if it goes in. It's trading
with the D'aeliyr, and it's trading with
the
uh Ravenbloom Student because of that
Stupefy trigger on the Ravenbloom
Student uh getting that extra might.
>> True.
>> We have to be careful though cuz we did
see the entire hand. We know there's
some more that we can be doing.
>> Yeah, and that's a good point, actually,
that the Stupefy was reactive. Yes, it
allowed Factor to get something else out
of the hand, but it did mean that you
can't remove the Stupefy. So, I think uh
Rune Runner into pass could work here.
We know that there is a stack deck in
hand for Beach White so that uh
Ravenbloom's always safe. The D'aeliyr
relatively safe. Will hold for four
points now for Beach White and can now
retreat those units.
>> Yeah, and I think the
your win con here is to protect that
Whisp as much as possible.
>> Yep.
>> Cuz that's what's going to be allowing
you to go over top of the Rune Runner.
Otherwise, the rest of your deck can't
really interact with it. Nope. Getting a
ruin bloom student big enough is uh a
very large investment.
Or you have to use that moonfall like we
talked about earlier.
>> But I will say when we were talking
about the outs that Diana has, it's both
way and moonfall. Bish white saw both
way and moonfall. Moonfall was taken
away from the sabotage, but the way is
still in play now. And Bish white's will
develop a pretty intimidating board. I
mean, this is multiple card cycles. This
is
uh a unit that can buff itself to pretty
extreme levels if you have a lot of
spells.
>> We drew the primal strength.
I'm trying to think here though because
we do have a charm in hand. Uh charming
a way is very dangerous.
>> Yep.
>> Cuz we are giving our opponent a draw. I
think I did see a star uh sprite
fountain, excuse me, in hand for Bish
white. So, if he does draw a moonfall,
he can actually pitch the sprite
fountain to ready to runes to then pull
something else in with the the ruin
runner, blanket the minus two, and at
least try to force some sort of trade.
>> to go see the power trigger. Yep.
>> All right. Factor letting us know what
he's triggering here. You're going to
conquer one seat of power, then the
other one triggering the seat of power
to draw a card as well as the master Yi
to get two experience points. Very rare
that you get up to six XP.
If it happens, it's cool, but in
general, you're just using this as a
very efficient turn two unit defense for
six for just four energy.
Let's see what Factor does for the rest
of the turn. I don't hate the charm
play. I mean, anytime I see a way, I
think
>> Get rid of it.
>> Yeah. As soon as you have an
opportunity, just full send it. But
you're right that discarding that sprite
fountain
could give Bish white's more tools, let
alone the fact that there's the Diana
legend still. So, two energy in combat
already presented.
>> And here comes the charm. It looks like
we're debating slamming it. And again,
there's so many cards that just make
this really bad for us if we're Factor.
We can ride the wind over to the master
Yi's battlefield if you pull it into the
ruin Runner. We're actually pulling it
into the Yee.
>> Wait here. Wait here.
>> Okay, yeah. A missed point, so to speak,
but we're going to bring it in. We have
a Hwei trigger.
>> Makes a little more sense. It's going to
be seven defending five. Hwei move
trigger will happen. Draw card, discard
card. If it's a unit, this way will go
to eight. If it's the Sprite Fountain,
two runes will be readied. If it's a
spell, Beischwitched will draw another
card. I'm expecting a unit or that
>> Sprite Fountain.
>> Sprite Fountain. And you're right.
>> There it is. Sprite Fountain.
>> I am clairvoyant.
>> Um
>> This was known information from Factor,
who had another sabotage in hand. So, if
he was worried about this, could have
sabotaged away to Sprite Fountain.
>> Yep.
>> And he's looking for the Moonfall, I
think, or something.
>> Using an Iron Legend to
>> A gust.
>> use the stacked deck.
I mean, even like a a Star Crossed would
be probably pretty worth it here. Save
the Hwei and then return the Master Yee
back to hand as well.
>> Yep.
>> I don't think there was a Star Crossed
we saw in Beischwitched's hand earlier.
>> I think we might have taken the Eclipse
unless we shuffled the cards.
>> I assume you're passing.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hwei Hwei Hwei
>> Okay, it works. That is ideal scenario
for Factor. You've dealt with the Hwei
threat very early, and the Moonfall was
a hit by the sabotage. So, now, I mean,
Factor knows the deck list. He was able
to look at Beischwitched's deck list
ahead of this final. So, Beischwitched
has one more Hwei and one more Moonfall
that will be in rotation, realistically,
in this game.
>> This is a very stacked hand for Factor.
Two Scuttle Crabs and On Guard, a
Sabotage, a Primal Strength, and a
Lonely Poro.
>> Wow.
I don't think Beischwitched will ever
not give information of his hand over to
Factor.
That means [laughter] two Scuttle Crabs
and another Sabotage.
>> We're seeing your hand every turn at
this point.
>> Factor's going to be clairvoyant here
for the rest of this game. You have to
imagine. We're going to develop one more
unit. It's the Lonely Poro. Has a little
more might than the Scuttle Crab. does
not get to draw immediately, but can hit
in a little harder with things like that
on guard in a pinch or even the the
primal strength.
>> All right, passing with
five runes up, more than enough for that
on guard.
>> Mhm.
>> So, we have to play around that
obviously.
>> the iron guard and the primal strength I
believe, right? Primal strength is four
recycle one.
>> I believe primal strength is seven.
>> Well, it's seven plus might, yes.
>> Um but for the the cost of it.
>> Believe it's
>> four, yeah.
>> It's been a while since I've seen that
card actually played. I I want to say
it's four recycle one, in which case you
would have enough for the on guard.
>> Either way, Factor has options. Let's
see how Beischwitz wants to approach
this one. Three units up, all uh two of
them will essentially cycle cards. He's
going to start with the eclipse,
lowering the might of the Master Yi by
four. So, with the legend passive, that
would go up to two might while
defending.
And yes, it is four energy.
>> Four energy one power primal strength.
So, yeah, he has access to both that and
the on guard on this turn.
>> Yep.
>> And that primal strength really does
take a lot of people by surprise. Now,
Factor knows or at least should remember
Beischwitz has a hard bargain in hand.
>> Yeah, and if we do primal strength here,
we can't hard bargain.
>> Yeah, so I don't think it's ever I think
you just let the Yi go. And we have the
rebuke.
>> Oh, that's a big hit off Diana.
Not going to help against the ruin
runner, but does help against pretty
much everything else, specifically the
rearguard.
>> We do have point tempo here as well,
which is notable for Beischwitz, so we
can try to create a board state where we
can ignore this ruin runner.
>> Yeah, pretty much, yeah.
But I'm telling you, once that second
ruin runner hits
the field. Okay, so on guard will go
through. Currently, the Master Yi is a
two might defending. This will go up to
four might.
>> Yeah, cuz I guess I'm at minus two right
now because of yeah.
>> So, basically, the eclipse will go away.
>> Okay.
>> Yep.
>> We have un-eclipsed our Yi.
>> Mhm.
>> I will pass focus again.
>> So okay with this is
B Shwitz.
Pretty much saying hey you can kill my
Diana, it's all good.
>> Yeah.
Has a stupefy but that would not save
the Diana. It would just save the
Ravenbloom.
>> Now Factor has to decide
do I primal strength? I don't recall if
he took notes when he saw the hand.
>> Oh.
>> So he might have forgotten.
>> He was a lot of notes right now. He he
just peeked at what was left.
>> Okay. I think this is the correct call
just go for the trade.
>> Conqueror five.
>> Yep.
>> There also is always the argument that
like maybe you just chew through the
hard bargain. I don't like that call but
some players will choose to say ah it's
in hand I got to get rid of it
eventually so let's just make them use
it but I think that makes way more sense
from Factor but it is a point for B
Shwitz now five to two.
>> Yeah, you don't want to chew through
that with a one of.
>> No, it's not a surprise card
>> like that.
>> Now if we were if our information was
given somehow that we had a primal
strength then okay sure but we're going
to stack deck here we'll go look for
another card.
Acceptable losses Star Crossed and
Traveling Merchant coming off the top so
this is really good here it's going to
keep that Ravenbloom student protected
unless I'm looking here.
>> I think he was just trying
>> some first mates in the deck list for
Factor so
>> Oh sure.
>> can bring that Rune Runner home if we
draw first mate, play that ready the
Rune Runner, send it in but again
Rune Runner on attack is admittedly less
scary.
>> less scary especially when there's a
Ravenbloom student which can kind of
shut that down but all that being said
Factor will have a lot of ways to punch
in heavier and B Shwitz will only have
three runes up for a hard bargain so
only one counter. I feel like if you're
B Shwitz you're not that worried about
saving this Ravenbloom student at this
point. It maybe is what you would just
hit with your Star Crossed but typically
we see the Fizz used for that so I
wouldn't be that surprised if the
Ravenbloom
is sacrificed if Factor can even get
onto the battlefield because the Lonely
Poros itself doesn't do a great job of
checking the Ravenbloom.
And the Scuttle Crab, unfortunately,
unfortunately, that's a zero-might unit.
He's just a little guy. He's a little
guy.
He's probably friends with Beast Below.
As harmless as it is delicious.
It's the flavor text on it.
>> That's a crazy flavor text.
>> It's yeah, I never even thought about
eating the Scuttle Crab.
>> Me neither.
>> Until now?
All right, let's see if Factor wants to
punch in here. I I didn't get a look at
what was drawn for turn. It seemed like
it could have been a discipline,
but I'm not confident on that.
>> Yeah, maybe this Lonely Poros about to
get active.
>> Yeah. It's going to make a friend out
there at the battlefield.
Now, if you're a fan of Metal Gear
Solid, you know, friendship on the
battlefield is a pretty canonical thing.
>> Not wrong.
Factor now in the tank. Really trying to
map out this line. A lot of options. We
don't have a sabotage in hand, too. So,
in what world do you maybe,
you know, either
send the sabotage or just send the
Scuttle Crab into its death to try to
just see what you're up against.
>> Yeah, I mean, that's not a bad option as
well. Remind yourself cuz a few more
cards have been drawn uh specifically
off of things like the stacked deck. So,
you can see, okay, what was Bee Swarm's
uh digging for? A sabotage is another
way to do it though. Costs an energy and
a power, but it will get rid of a card
in hand.
>> Probably the [snorts] Star Crossed if I
had to guess.
We do have the rebuke as well.
>> And uh is that a Ride the Wind?
>> Uh it looks like a Ride the Wind,
rebuke, Acceptable Losses, Hard Bargain.
The entire hand
>> hand is legal. There's no units in this
hand.
That's a wild hand to look at. Um
I guess Factor picked Star Crossed is is
what I would initially think just cuz
then the Fizz can't keep looping with
it.
>> Mhm.
>> Star Crossed feels like a good hit. Um
the rebuke as well. Even the stupify
denied them a draw.
The everything except for acceptable
losses feels kind of good.
>> Yeah, acceptable losses is definitely
not the scary one. I would argue hard
bargain isn't the scariest, but you can
also get rid of it just so that way your
primal strength is online and you don't
have to worry about the hard bargain
anymore.
>> That's a very
I don't know what I would choose.
>> Tough call.
>> It is a star crossed.
>> Star crossed is my initial gut reaction
just cuz of what it can do with Fizz.
It's just getting rid of that
interaction right for right now at
least. It feels pretty good.
The second one I would say is maybe the
hard bargain just so that your primal
strength is alive, but with that hand
you I don't think you're going to need
the primal strength immediately in the
future. So, you're probably all right
anyway.
>> Now, call me crazy, but I think I might
have seen a charm.
>> Ooh, that would be fancy.
This is going to be a
>> Tough.
>> Skuttle crab developed draw another
card.
>> If actually can get like an on guard or
a discipline
>> I imagine that's what you're looking for
here so that way the lonely poro can try
and deal with that Ravenbloom student.
You know that in combat really the
things that would be played acceptable
losses could just be thrown out I
suppose.
>> Yep.
>> Just to buff the Ravenbloom and then
maybe like a
the rebuke would feel pretty bad. Yes.
He's on a lonely poro.
>> Five to three, yeah.
Yeah.
>> Ooh, challenge drawn as well.
>> Stupify was the other one so it would be
like stupify and acceptable losses would
be the um
the response from Bee Swifts if the
lonely poro goes in with a discipline.
>> It looks like we're prostrating for the
challenge that we drew off the skuttle
crab and challenge is really good in
this spot.
>> Yeah.
>> Especially if you throw it on the ruin
runner.
>> Mhm.
>> You can't really modify it's might on
the side of Diana. We can't stupify it.
We can't do that stuff. So, we're going
to challenge the Ravenbloom student. But
can we we I don't think we have enough
to play three spells
unless we draw one cuz we had a stupify
and acceptable losses I believe in hand.
>> Stupefy, uh Hard Bargain, Acceptable
Losses, Rebuke. Those are the spells, I
believe, still in hand
for Beischwitz.
>> What?
>> Now, he could Rebuke this.
Or Stupefy to see if he draws into
something that you'd rather play.
>> Ride the Wind, my Fizz.
>> Ride the Wind, the Fizz. I I I forgot
about the Ride the Wind. So, the Lonely
Poro is the attacker, I believe, still,
and then Fizz will be defender. So, the
Lonely Poro will not get the plus two
from the Master Yi.
>> Yeah, so, how this works, obviously,
whoever applies contested status to the
battlefield, if it turns into a combat
showdown, will be the attacker. So, this
is what's uh most commonly referred to
as a surprise defense.
But, there's the Primal Strength. No
more ruins available for the Hard
Bargain. Found value out of the Primal
Strength. It denies the Fizz. And now,
there's only one Traveling Merchant, one
unit for Beischwitz. We know that the
hand had no units in it. So, Factor has
taken control of the game for now.
>> It's a draw off of the Conquer from Cede
to Power, and is currently holding with
uh quite a lot of defense here with that
Master Yi. That's seven on the Rune
Runner, four on the Lonely Poro, while
in combat defending.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, so, I looks like Beischwitz was
trying to make, you know, Master Yi have
it there a little bit, saying, "Hey, if
you have a
If you have a discipline, I have the
Stupefy, right? So, at least I'm
offering you a trade there." Uh Primal
Strength being a one-of,
more often than not, they won't, right?
So, getting rid of it now,
>> Stupefy.
>> point tempo's a little wonky,
cuz we're going to go to six next turn,
so only two turns left for Beischwitz to
try to figure out what to uh do to get
out of this hole.
>> Stuck deck.
>> Yep. I also just dawned on me how funny
it was that there was a nine-might
Lonely Poro attacking in there for a
brief moment.
>> My record is 21.
>> Why?
>> On a defense, when I I Yi in set two
with a lonely poro.
>> For what purpose?
>> Uh they attacked into me and I used I
think three disciplines up two punch
firsts.
>> I guess punch first will get you there.
>> Yeah.
All right.
>> Good times.
>> Stack deck being used by Beeschwitz
alongside the stupefy. So digging
digging digging. You already lost one
way and one moonfall. Those are two of
the best tools. Things like Khazix now
come up.
The second way you're looking for those
hitters at this point. I If you can get
to the Khazix it feels great. The
rebuke's going to have to be used.
Just so Beeschwitz can get back onto a
battlefield and go to six points.
>> Yep.
Yeah, that doesn't feel great. But I
mean it does put you in striking
distance next turn if you can find a way
to develop. But again, if you're trying
to win next turn, that ruin runner can't
be ignored anymore.
>> Discarding the hard bargain here
realizing that yeah, you're not going to
get the most value out of that
especially now that the
uh primal strength is gone. But we got
the way.
Beeschwitz is maybe back in this if this
way can live.
>> I do believe that when we stacked decked
I saw a moonfall. I didn't see if we
took the moonfall.
But I did see we saw a moonfall. And
this has to be if I'm not mistaken a
Khazix.
>> No, Khazix is not a Khazix.
>> Khazix ambush.
>> Uh
>> So what would this be here?
>> Uh in terms of hiding yeah, tide turner.
>> Tide turner, yeah.
>> I think that's the only one that's in
the main deck. Switcher's in the side
but we have not sided yet.
>> And we only got two crabs
to get active with.
>> Have a little crab party.
Could always just crash one in, take a
look at the hands, see what was added. I
love plays like that. In the past two
times we've brought that up as an
option, there was also a sabotage. No
longer a sabotage. So now I think you
can send it in. There's a punch first
and a discipline and a charm.
>> Oh yeah.
>> An incredible suite of spells for the E
deck. And we're topped out. Wow. Yeah,
you can just charm that way straight
into the ruin runner. Even if they
discard a unit, you can then discipline
and you're going to be a nine to their
eight.
>> Yeah, we got to be careful though
because we can discard a gear if we have
it.
>> True and Diana uh legend is still
available, so that would then give
uh uh three total power to play with and
uh could
>> Could be a moonfall.
>> But with the discipline, I still believe
that gets us over it.
>> But this is where I attack with the
scuttle. You have two bodies. I think
that you don't need both of these in any
world. So, just crash one into the
merchant and get the information. I like
this play a factor does it. He's
second-guessing
>> discipline.
>> Oh.
>> This is good because when we send that
scuttle crab in now, that hidden tide
turner can't protect against the charm
anymore. We're going to have to flip it
at one point. We can do it in response
to the death knell trigger normally
cuz we won't lose control. But it looks
like we're going to do it first.
Uh
>> Yep.
Huey gets one move.
>> It's a little bit of a weirder
interaction.
>> Yeah.
>> you can actually respond to the death
knell trigger of the scuttle crab
because control doesn't lose You can't
lose control during an active chain.
>> Mhm.
>> So, that tide turner could stay hidden
and you can respond when the uh death
knell gets finalized on the chain to
bring the Huey in or leave, you know,
the Huey back and that scuttle crab will
be dead.
>> Mhm.
Well, it looks like scuttle's going to
be trading with the merchant regardless.
The Huey is now an eight might. So, now
if Factor charms the Huey over to the
ruin runner and the Huey discards
another
>> another death knell.
>> unit, it would go to 11.
That's a seven defending, so punch first
would be enough. But there's a ride the
wind
>> Not enough of
>> So, that would be literally the If you
charm the Huey, they have to draw a
sprite found specifically, discard the
sprite found, ready to ruin, to ride the
wind the Huey away. Otherwise, that Huey
is dead. You have the charm, you have
the punch first. I think you go for it.
>> Yep. You have a discipline, I believe.
Or no, we used a discipline. We have a
punch first though. Yeah.
>> And again, the Huey's going to move. It
might draw a unit and then discard the
unit. So, you have to be ready with the
punch first. Uh you you have to punch
first regardless cuz the ruin runner is
going to be seven defending eight.
>> Scuttle.
>> Mhm. Okay. I mean yeah, you do you do
have this yeah, sure. I don't mind this.
Charm. Charm.
The second way, there's only two in the
main deck or even the side deck.
Any unit, any gear helps here.
A gear is what you need. If it's a unit,
it's not enough. If it's a spell, it
just gets you another draw and then you
have one Tide Turner to try and fight.
>> And it's a unit.
>> Okay. I mean again, you the punch versus
always happening so it just didn't
change Factor's play at all. It just
means that now that vaccine no longer
available for Bishwitz who was really
hoping maybe he could find a way because
if it's just like a discipline, you need
to discard that unit. Punch versus the
only out that Factor would have to an 11
might way.
>> Yeah, and this is really rough now.
It's looking pretty in favor of Factor.
We're going to hide Azoneous probably
with our Rune Runner.
There is an Acceptable Losses in hand so
if we're in a showdown, we flip Azoneous
and we get focused back, we can always
Acceptable Losses to get rid of it.
Effective.
>> Effective.
>> We still need some way to get over at
least seven might with a Tide Turner.
And right now, Bishwitz has nothing to
do it. The Tide Turner checks the
Scuttle Crab. There is a Ride the Wind
and an Acceptable Losses in hand and
then whatever is on the draw.
>> Yeah, and right now
even the if we had a Moonfall, that
still doesn't get us there. It'll put
the Rune Runner to three.
And then Scuttle Crab to negative
>> Tide Turner is only only himself.
If you're Factor right now, I think
you're weighing how much cuz I I believe
there's a Lonely Por in hand. I would
play it because
if if Bishwitz can get onto this
battlefield, you kind of want something
that can hit. Ooh, playing it to the
battlefield so that way if Tide Turner
goes in, still trading with something
but then Lonely Por will get a draw. So
Factor just wants that extra Actually
no, it won't cuz it's not a loan.
>> It won't is just trying to
insulate maybe a little bit and say like
hey, you can't just come here for free.
And you know,
kill my scuttle crab and then do
something else. But it doesn't really
change much cuz it's still just two
mites. So not sure the reasoning of
putting it here if I'm being honest.
>> Yeah, I I think I would rather see it in
the base but I I understand I suppose to
an extent. Like if it's a a rebuke
another again or like a gust, but no
it's uh it's going to be a scoop for
game one. Bishwitz cannot get it done.
Factor did a fantastic job getting to
through two ways
and the moonfall with that sabotage
showing why Master Yi is such a good
match-up in these decks. Once you get
that ruin runner on the field, it just
comes down to deal with the threats to
ruin runner and you can win the game.
>> So notably there was one challenge in
the main deck for Factor and one primal
strength. So we saw
both are one ofs in that match. Uh and
looking at the list for Bishwitz,
we saw two of our three one ofs in that
match with eclipse and rebuke.
So it looks like What I like to do is
look at their sideboard and try to guess
what we're bringing in.
>> So I'm going to guess Bishwitz brings in
another moonfall. You want more outs to
the ruin runner.
Um
I I don't even may maybe like a
singularity just cuz you you can then
spread some of the damage around to the
things that aren't the ruin runner cuz
sometimes the Yi
with like the
you know, first mates with the Master Yi
itself can get a couple of units out
there cuz like there's a few things in
the deck main deck that just aren't
going to get a lot of value at this
point. Like I don't know if you like
keeping the star cross. I know it's
fantastic with Faze and it feels crazy
to take it out, but like maybe that's
something you you look at. Um maybe you
take out things like the uh
the Vex Apathetic just cuz it's not
quite the numbers you're looking for,
but at the same time it's one of the
only numbers that you have. So it's a
tough call. Tough call to make. I think
for sure though that one moonfall goes
in.
>> Yeah, I'm looking at Factor's sideboard,
notably two alpha strike
in the sideboard.
>> Very, very cool signature spell. It's
the second signature spell now for
Master Yi.
>> Yep.
>> Uh it's able to choose a unit and then
it deals its might spread out to units
at a battlefield. Uh or I I believe any
battlefield, right?
>> At battlefield, yeah.
>> At battlefield, yeah. So you don't have
to pick one, it could be multiple
battlefields. And then uh say you have
your, you know, ruin runner, you primal
strength it, that's 12 might, then you
alpha strike, and then you spread 12
damage to a bunch of things. It's kind
of like a much more uh efficient
challenge cuz you don't take the damage.
>> Right.
>> also do it in combat. So one of the cool
tricks is you attack in, play it, spread
the damage, and then still punch for
more damage, and you can clear a whole
battlefield. The only difference is that
you can't hit things at base. Uh
challenge can hit at base, alpha strike
cannot.
>> Yeah, we do have an extra Fiora Peerless
as well in the sideboard. An
interesting.
I only I was today years old when I
realized Factor's running only two ruin
runners in the main deck.
>> Yeah, only two. One in the side. So for
sure the the sec the third ruin runner
>> Yes, that comes in.
>> I would say the second challenge comes
in because then you can deal with things
like Vex
uh and the Huwei as well. Like it's a
fantastic tool for sniping the Huwei.
Um
maybe the alpha strikes simply because
if a Huwei attacks in at like 11 might
and you're a seven might defending ruin
runner, you can alpha strike, hit it for
seven, and then punch it for seven, and
then they trade, Huwei versus ruin
runner. So for things like that, I think
alpha strike might have a place, but you
have to find space for it. And yes, so
many of the just innate spells in the
deck already are really good.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Um
so yeah, it's going to be tough
decisions for Factor. I think that you
keep the three sabotage for sure. I like
keeping the punch first. Maybe you take
out the primal strength. I know it did
find value eventually, but um
it is one of the nicer targets for hard
bargain from Beaswitz. But, it looks
like the players have made their
decisions and now choosing a battlefield
here.
>> Interesting. Oh, Factor
kind of flipped over the Arena's
Greatest.
He knows that his opponent's on the
Arena's Greatest. So, maybe
debating going double greatest here.
>> That would be
>> crazy to
>> Crazy. I don't think I've ever seen
that.
>> Me, either.
>> Taking his time.
After You know, for for somebody who
just won the first game, seems very
stressed.
>> Yeah. I mean,
there's a lot of pressure, right? These
are This is a very important series for
both these players. It would be their
first ever regional qualifier win.
Obviously, they're both locked in for
the best of. They're both locked in for
the regional championship, but these are
competitors to their core. It's not
enough until they lift the trophy, and
we can see it on both their faces.
>> And it is stressful being at the finals
table.
>> We're already giving them a show.
>> Let's give them a
>> Oh, we're doing a double greatest.
That's what it sounds like to me.
>> You don't know I submitted Arena's
Greatest. I'm going to submit
>> [laughter]
>> Who get Who would?
>> And it's double
>> And there it is, greatest. Double seeded
power game one, double Arena's Greatest
game two. It's going to be a six-point
game. Each player will start the game
with two points, only needs six more to
win. This is going to be a very fast
game, too, you have to imagine.
I've never seen this before in my life.
This is awesome.
>> Good luck. I'll give us both two points.
>> two.
>> Yep.
>> So, a gentleman's agreement to just
acknowledge that we're both starting at
two. We don't want any funny business of
people forgetting their triggers or
anything like that. So, both players are
going to be starting at two here as we
start things off. Beaswitz gets to go
first since he did lose the previous
one, and we're going to be doing
mulligans here. Looks like we have a
sabotage charm, a mate, and something
else in hand. Snap keep here from
Factor. Looked at it for about 3 and 1/2
seconds and said, "I got it."
>> I mean, if you're on the the three
energy, you can just play the first mate
or if you have a two drop then you can
have it with like an Ongar or Defy. Lot
of options when you're on three energy
with Mastery. Now, well, let's see what
Beischwitz wants to do.
>> Beischwitz did mulligan into a Tide
Turner, so we know he at least has eight
two drop. Not the ideal one, but
something at least in there that's going
to come Well, maybe not.
>> Hmm. Baiting us out here.
Thinking about it.
>> most games I wouldn't do this,
>> Oh, here we go.
>> The turn one Sprite Fountain?
>> Since you've decided to give him a show.
>> Oh,
the turn one Sprite Fountain would go
crazy.
>> There it is, yeah?
>> That's awesome.
>> All right, we're playing a fast game of
Riftbound, everybody. Ready Sprite token
comes in. We'll conquer at the arena's
greatest. That is three points on
Beischwitz's first turn.
>> I don't got anything against cool, just
a first mate and a pass.
>> [laughter]
>> So, now I'm wondering does Beischwitz
have the second one?
>> That would be insane.
>> This is the fountain will die. It'll
create another Sprite token that's
ready. That will score to four points.
Four points on the second turn.
Yeah.
Incredible.
>> And now we're playing regular Diana.
So, we're going to have Factor now
finally able to get one of his own
points and not a battlefield point.
Moving that first aid probably first
mate, excuse me, probably into that uh
right hand battlefield for him.
>> Yeah, no need to contest the Sprite
token. It will die in the beginning
phase, not hold a point.
And then the first mate will easily
check the Diana unless Beischwitz wants
to send in some extra resources with it.
Now, what else does Factor have in hand?
Cuz something like a charm on this Diana
right now would be really good.
>> I think there was a charm in the opening
hand if I'm not mistaken.
And we can actually develop our Yian
charm if there is a charm in hand.
>> There is. There is.
>> I would I would sabotage first. I would
sabotage first. Make sure that there's
no gust cuz gust would be
>> Diana is is untapped, excuse me. Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's ready.
Oh, we're not doing it. This might be a
mistake.
Okay, we'll see. There's a react window.
Okay, never mind.
>> No, I just can be the Diana. And I
suppose that now you can't even gust the
first mate because the Master Yi is
making it plus two. So
>> Oh. There's a switcheroo that he's
looking at right now and debating.
>> Was a gust.
>> Yeah. But again, when the when you're
attacking on the first mate, he's now a
five might. So the gust is no longer a
valid target.
>> Yeah, at the very least could save our
Diana, but maybe there's another
strategy here going on for
Bishwitz. Notably
uh going to be on odd points is factor.
So the clock is plus one turn from the
best case scenario.
Uh Bishwitz here on four points. So able
to maybe take a turn here to develop and
challenge stuff next turn. We don't
really see a ruin runner yet. And unless
I just cast her cursed it into existence
we have a turn that we could do
something here.
>> Huwei. Switcheroo switcheroo. Another
Sprite Fountain. Like this is a stacked
hand for Bishwitz, but doesn't have a
lot developed currently. You could just
play the Huwei here.
>> Yes.
>> Sprite Fountain.
>> Into
moonfall technically just clears the
board if my math is correct, right?
>> Minus two minus two.
>> You would attack the first mate. You
moonfall in the Master Yi. That would be
a one and a two. It would crash. You're
right.
>> Yeah. Cuz the Master Yi passive would
not be working. There would be two units
on the battlefield. It's not a win. It's
a while.
So if a second unit enters the
battlefield, that plus two will go away.
And there it is. I think Bishwitz sees
the same line you do.
>> Nope.
>> But we can pull the Yi in.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> True.
Gust and pull the E in could be a play
or we wait for them to develop and then
crash.
>> Yeah.
>> Or we're doing it now. Passing here
doesn't feel the worst.
>> Okay, he's better than me cuz he found a
cooler line.
>> Yeah, I will say though
yeah, if you don't do it proactively,
you you give them a chance to defy cuz
Factor is exhausted and it's scary into
these calm decks to say, "Okay, one
three and an energy or three and a power
spell
is going to be like what makes or breaks
the entire game." I agree. I think if
you're going this line, you have to
proactively do it now.
>> The issue here is I think the
point of contention is
do I
save it so I can maybe do something
extra next turn, but next turn we're
going to have a popped Sprite from the
Sprite Fountain's death knell trigger.
We're going to have enough if we want to
just play a Hwayito base as well. So,
we'll be able to go to six points next
turn with a Hwayito. We're in striking
distance with stuff like Ride the Wind
and you know, some combat tricks. Here
comes the Fiora though.
>> Development from Factor plus the
Radizat. That's going to go clear that
Sprite. That's a six might Fiora.
>> Do the trigger.
>> And that Fiora defends some fears. If
it's fighting one-on-one while
defending, it gets plus two and then
doubles, which would go to a 10 total
might. The Sprite can go conquer the top
arena's great. It's going to six points
for Bishwitz.
I think the game plan is still probably
the same. You go for the Hwayito
development, get your point.
But Factor's got a lot more currently in
the tank.
>> He also has a Rengar in his hand.
>> Ooh.
That could cause some problems on a
surprise defense.
>> Look at the six.
>> Yeah.
>> Sprite goes in, conquers the point. Six
points. Bishwitz is two points away from
winning the game. Tie Turner to develop
just a unit in base, not playing the
way.
>> Hold to five.
>> Try to remember what was in hand for
Bischwitz. We saw a lot of options. Was
there a star cross?
>> We're going to find out.
>> Okay.
>> We have a sabotage from Factor.
>> Yeah.
>> I will star cross my sprites and your
units.
>> Nice.
>> Looking for Defy maybe.
>> doing this so that way the sabotage will
not clear the star cross.
>> If there's a Defy Factor, could use it
here.
>> Oh.
>> Oh, reacting with the Rengar.
>> Uh yep.
>> Okay.
>> Back to hand.
>> Notably, now there's a showdown staged
until this chain resolves.
>> I provide the wind.
>> I I can't do the six off and yeah, yeah,
yeah. Yes, yes, yes.
>> Yep.
>> Okay, way switcheroo is not going to be
enough to do it. The switcheroo will
help with the Tie Turner that's on the
field to at least clear that Rengar.
>> Yep.
>> But I would say Factor's in a very solid
position here. Bischwitz had to deramp
significantly to make his last couple of
plays. Pretty much every turn he's
deramped one if not two.
>> Saba.
Another sabotage.
>> There goes the switcheroo.
Good luck.
>> Good luck is [laughter] crazy.
>> We are one turn away from potentially
crowning a brand new champion. Bischwitz
has to find something off the top of the
deck to turn his fortune.
>> Gust. Okay.
>> It's a gust. That'll do it.
>> work way. Go.
>> All right, we bought ourselves one more
turn.
>> Hold to seven.
>> Yep.
>> Can Factor do it right here, right now?
There's a lot of cards that could do it.
That's one one them. Oh, he played it.
Okay, ready?
>> first.
>> And the punch first.
That's going to be a GG. Extend the
handshake, and there you have it. A
brand new regional qualifier champion.
Congratulations, Factor, for the 2-0
victory.
>> On a double Arena's greatest game where
his opponent opens Sprite fountain,
Factor is able to find the line. Look at
the shock on his face. I think it's a
mix of emotion and just ex
>> masturbation.
>> Back-to-back
wins. Back-to-back going second. Winning
going second into a double Arena's
greatest. He said, "Let's give them a
show." And they did just that. Your new
champion, Factor, on Master Yi, Wuju
Bladesman. What a performance. What a
show from this gamer. Let's hear from
him now on stage with Barrett.
>> And there you have it, everyone here,
everyone at home. Your regional
qualifier champion, Factor, with Master
Yi, Wuju Bladesman. How do you feel?
>> Incredible. [cheering]
I going into the finals, the player I
played against actually played in
Vancouver a couple weeks ago, and he
beat me. So, getting my revenge there
felt nice. I As you could have seen on
stream, I sat there deciding what
battlefield to flip for like 3 minutes,
and I was like, "You know what? Double
Arena's greatest. I've done it a couple
times already this weekend, and it's
done me well." So, I figured if that's
how I was going to close it out, that's
how I wanted it to be. So, yep.
>> You have now joined the hall of legends
that are regional qualifier champions
with Master Yi for the first time in a
regional qualifier. Factor, one more
time.
I know you're getting emotional, but I
mean, that is what it takes to be a
champion in this game. Hours and hours,
and with a legend that finally has now
topped. I've got to ask you as my final
question, Ruin [music] Runner, you
talked to me earlier today saying it was
the worst card that you had seen all
weekend, but time after time it ran to
the top of your deck and it got you to
this run right here. What do you think
of that one?
>> I I am happy that it was there. Granted,
well, day one and all most of day two
until top eight and and until my winning
it didn't really do me much, but it
closed out in the end, so I'm happy I I
had it there and I'm Yeah, just happy to
to have gotten the trophy and and win
one, so.
>> One more time, Factor, your Regional
Qualifier champion in Hartford.
>> [music]
>> I know.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Mhm.